[Music]
on March 15th 2011 Martin Sims was
wandering down the streets of Carson
California his clothes were ragged he
was filthy and gibbering like a madman
with a full beard and long unkempt hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition what
made Martin sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing for 3 years
when he was interviewed by police they
asked him where he been all this time
they couldn't believe his answer he'd
been trapped in an Ikea since 2008 but
this was no ordinary Ikea this was a
dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as SCP 3008 Martin's strange
answers in his interview were laughed
off by his interviewing officers who
assumed he was either crazy or under the
influence of something but they caught
the attention of an SCP Foundation field
agent embedded in the precinct the
report was passed up the chain to a
local site director who approved a
Detachment of foundation field field
operatives to look into Martin's case
while he was reluctant to lead the
foundation agents back to the offending
Ikea the foundation can be extremely
persuasive his screams of please I'm
begging you don't take me back don't
make me go back were noted But
ultimately disregarded when the SCP
Foundation had triangulated the position
of SCP 3008 which was indeed an active
Ikea the entire retail Zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretense of a
severe black mold investation armed
Foundation personel also arrived on the
site shortly after based on Martin's
vague statements that there were
creatures of some kind inside due to his
deteriorating mental health Martin was
unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of
SCP 3008 but one phrase he kept
repeating was bigger on the inside once
researchers were satisfied that Martin
had delivered all the pertinent
information he was able to he was
administered Foundation amnestics to
erase his memory of the last 3 years and
return to his family a cover story was
formulated Martin had been kidnapped and
abused for 3 years by a mentally
unbalanced stalker in downtown Carson
he'd been able to escape as said stalker
took his own life out of guilt a suicide
that the foundation expertly fabricated
to make their cover story airtight with
the loose end of Martin Sims taken care
of the true observation of SCP 3008
could begin a base set around the
perimeter of the mysterious Ikea kept a
24-hour watch on the building covering
all potential entrances and exits no
exploratory missions had yet been
approved by the Foundation Ethics
Committee so they first wanted to
perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store's anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building after a week of nothing
it appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class D Personnel to explore
the interior of SCP 3008 the d-class
operatives would be split into four
squads of five men alpha bravo charlie
and Delta Squad each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store and
would deliver information back to the
control team on site via a live audio
and video link three of the four teams
upon entering the store reported nothing
out of the ordinary neither the audio or
video they were sending back indicated
anything different from a standard IKEA
store from the flat pack wardrobes to
the Swedish meatballs Team Delta however
suddenly began experiencing a scrambled
Audio and Video Connection shortly after
communication with Team Delta dropped
off entirely they disappeared somewhere
inside the store and haven't been seen
since with one notable exception after
The Disappearance and the extraction of
teams Foundation researchers classified
SCP 3008 as uclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store and even then
seemingly not the entire interior the
anomalous area within SCP 3008 became
known as SCP
38-1 and containment appeared to be 100%
secure there was no telling how many
people had already gone missing in the
store over the years but the
disappearances Must Be Stopped the
foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of SCP
3008 but it appeared they could prevent
any further incidents by simply
preventing other civilians from
accessing the IKEA store Martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium until a
surviving member of Delta team suddenly
reappeared the date was November 3rd
2011 it was a cold night a few hours
after what would have been closing time
if the store were still active and 7
months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of
SCP 3008 there had been no anomalous
activity outside the store since the
perimeter was first secured and the
foundation researchers hadn't expected
that to change until the last surviving
member of Delta team came barging out of
the store's entrance startled field
operatives were amazed to see him again
but they were even more amazed to see
what was following him out of the store
repeating the same phrase the store is
now closed please exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the Delta team Survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an Ikea
store employee the being definitely was
not human it was around 7 ft tall with
no visible face The Entity had grossly
extended limbs with each arm being
around 5 or 6 ft long and ending in a
huge oversized hand the whole process
was so sudden that the field agents
present at the perimeter weren't able to
save the Del team Survivor as the entity
reached forward with his freakishly long
arms grabbed him and twisted his head
off like a child with a doll the field
operatives present Drew their weapons
and peppered The Entity with bullets it
would later be classified as SCP 3008-2
the being appeared to collapse and die
from the physical trauma at which point
it and the body of the former Delta team
Survivor were taken for an autopsy by
Foundation researchers there were no
biological abnormalities of the body of
the Delta team Survivor so it did not
appear that the anomalous properties of
SCP 38-1 had any effect on the
physiology of its occupants he was not
malnourished despite being missing for
months and the contents of his stomach
looked to be half-digested food
consistent with the menu of a typical
IKEA store restaurant SCP 38-2 on the
other hand raised a number of perplexing
biological questions the autopsy
revealed that the creatures clothes were
actually part of its body like an
additional layer of skin the creature
lacked blood or any kind of vascular
system even stranger The Entity didn't
appear to have bones or internal organs
not even a brain or nervous system it
was a being made entirely of skin all
the way to its core how it was able to
move or even live for that matter
remains a mystery though when you work
for the SCP Foundation you learn to
accept that something will always remain
unexplained one thing was certain though
Martin Sims was right about his monsters
after the incident with Delta team the
foundation deemed that sending man
Explorations Into the Heart of SCP 3008
was too much of a liability and planned
a series of drone-based reconnaissance
missions into the anomaly the first of
these drones experienced connection
issues and failed when attempting to
venture into the Ikea's anomalous Zone
however after a lengthy period of trial
and error the foundation was able to
establish a more secure connection with
its drones even went deep into the SCP
38-1 anomalous Zone it was only then
that some of the most extraordinary
discoveries were made SCP 38-1 seemed to
break the laws of spatial reality as the
area of the Ikea's interior was at least
in order of magnitude larger than its
exterior just as Martin Sims had said it
was bigger on the inside but just how
much bigger the foundation has yet to
find evidence of any physical
Terminators within the store that might
indicate SCP 38-1 has an end point while
an area of at least 10 km squared has
been uncovered in SCP 38-1 it could in
theory be infinite Laser Rangefinder
tests which are normally very reliable
have only given inconclusive results
interestingly the anomalous area doesn't
have any clear visual differences from
the rest of the IKEA store except that
it extends forever an individual trapped
within the confines of SCP 38-1 wouldn't
even realize they've entered an
anomalous zone until they tried to
locate an exit and leave at which point
they'd find they were already hopelessly
lost the geography of SCP 38-1 does at
least appear to be consistent so people
trapped within are theoretically able to
retrace their steps and Escape if they
haven't already ventured too deep
according to data collected during the
Drone reconnaissance missions SCP 3008-2
of which there appear to be a vast
population would wander the stores
aimlessly during the day they are
unresponsive to the drone's presence and
did not appear to be aggressive while
the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
follow the same overall trend close
consistent with an Ikea uniform no face
either seemingly Too Tall or too short
and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies as the
foundation began sending drones deeper
into SCP 38-1 they found another
incredible Discovery there was an
unknown population of humans trapped
inside Ikea's anomalous Zone and these
people had used the IKEA furniture
around them to create entire settlements
and towns within the store there were
several of these towns all of which
seemed to cohabitate peacefully even
Foundation personnel found this
development in their research to be
truly extraordinary since SCP 3008 was
first identified there have been only 14
civilian escapes some had been trapped
inside for months others had been in
there for years some far longer than
Martin's 3year stint while every one of
these escapes has eventually been
released back to their home after a
liberal application of amnestics and a
proper cover story has been devised the
foundation interviewed each of them
extensively first according to each of
these escapes the people trapped inside
the Ikea have built an entirely new
Society across the various settlements
contrary to the lord of the flyes
expectations of a group of people
isolated and afraid there's immense
cooperation between the trapped
civilians the food in the several Ikea
restaurants in SCP 38-1 mysteriously
replenishes while nobody's there so
there's no threat of starving and the
automatic turning on and off of the
lights forms as a rudimentary kind of
day and night cycle nighttime however is
when things get dangerous as the SCP
3008-2 entities which are known to the
people inside as the staff become
extremely hostile after dark aggressive
hordes of the staff swarm the
settlements at night repeating this door
is now closed please exit the building
the civilians inside are usually able to
repel these attacks with minimal
casualties but the constant War of
Attrition slowly wears down those inside
the bodies of the creatures also need to
be removed from the area after each
attack as the presence of corpses or
even parts of corpses has been known to
heighten the ferocity of the next
night's attack during the day the staff
returned to a docile and unre responsive
State though they'll still defend
themselves violently if anyone dares to
attack over the course of the interviews
with the 14 escapees Foundation
researchers were able to answer another
of their key questions how had so many
people gone missing in the store for so
long without being noticed but the
answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries according to the
escapees there were people inside the
settlements that despite being otherwise
of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence seem to lack very common
knowledge that even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the International Space Station
orbiting the Earth or stranger still the
existence of the Statue of Liberty this
led the researchers to a frightening
conclusion SCP 38-1 may not only be an
nexcess point of multiple Ikea stores in
our Dimension it could be connected to
Ikeas in every Dimension where Ikeas
exist while it only abducts a handful of
people from each store over an extended
period of time it suddenly becomes clear
how this SCP was able to trap so many
people without detection over such a
long period of time which in turn led to
an even more terrifying Revelation the
SCP Foundation may not have SCP 38-1 as
contained as they thought it might even
be tucked away in an Ikea store
somewhere near you just waiting for you
to visit after all there's always room
for one more when an anomaly is first
detected by an SCP Foundation field
agent it's up to the foundation's mobile
task forces to tag and bag The
Impossible entities before they can do
any more harm sometimes these retrievals
are un uneventful other times not so
much especially when they're dealing
with brutal forces of nature like scp096
also known as the shy guy a creature
that from the very first interaction
with the foundation had a reputation for
being dangerous and needed to be feared
a series of vague sightings and
mysterious disappearances up in the
frosty mountains of the Yukon first
sparked the foundation's interest when
they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams Zulu 9A and Zulu 9B were
dispatched to secure and contain the
entity Zulu 9A took the lead in a heavy
duty Chopper equipped with 50 caliber
g19 heavy machine guns and carrying an
at4 anti-tank launcher they were
prepared for anything or so they thought
as they established a visual on scp096
while two clicks away from the target
they couldn't get a clear line of sight
on the creature but it appeared to be
station Ary docel and was making no
attempt to flee piece of cake right
little did they know that scp096 was
just looking away from them if it was
facing towards them it'd be a whole
different Horror Story as Zulu 9A were
about to find out the team landed their
helicopter next to the creature and were
shocked to see that it was completely
naked in spite of the Sub-Zero
temperatures all around them the
creature was unnaturally thin as though
it had been starved for weeks with bone
white skin and unnaturally long limbs
the team guessed that the creature's
arms must have been at least 1.5 M long
but its dosil nature and insubstantial
body mass gave the impression that it
wouldn't prove too difficult to contain
that is until they saw its face Zulu 9's
Captain was the Lone Survivor of the
incident as he was lucky enough to be
looking away when the creature turned
towards his team the rest of the squad
ended up staring eye to eye with scp096
and from that moment on was IND doile
anymore the creature began to whimper
then cry then SOB uncontrollably in a
way that sounded eerily human this
Sudden Change in temperament startled
the rest of zulu 9A and they opened fire
on the creature under the hail of
gunfire scp096 entered a murderous
frenzy and began tearing into the
hapless Squad of soldiers while its
flesh and organs did seem to take damage
as a result of the barrage of 50 caliber
rounds from the helicopter mounted
machine guns its skeletal structure
remained intact and it continued its
Onslaught tearing the team limb from
limb even after they' blown practically
all the flesh from the creature the at4
anti-tank launcher proved equally
ineffective at stopping scp096 while it
was in attack mode it was only after
slaughtering the entire team that it
returned to its docile State nobody
knows exactly what the creature did to
Zulu 9A after the gunfire started but no
trace of the team was left behind Zulu
9B touched down soon after and with a a
grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over SCP 96's face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby Foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and Chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp096 were put under the command of
Dr Dan a senior researcher at the site
it was his job to find out exactly what
this being was capable of the more he
tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class Personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its Attack Mode just as it had during
the initial retrieval Mission scp096
went berserk when any of the attending
Personnel saw its face in this stage it
would enter a period of considerable and
Unstoppable distress for 1 to 2 minutes
covering its face and wailing loudly
when the period of distress ended the
creature would mercilessly Slaughter
every declass that had seen its face and
just like with Zulu 9A no trace of their
bodies would be left behind Dr Den was
horrified and intrigued by this
phenomenon the creature killed anyone
that saw its face directly but could the
same be said for indirect depictions of
the creature's face such as images and
videos Dr Dan was desperate to find out
more d-class personel were brought in to
test this to frightening results Dr Dan
found that the creature did indeed still
enter Attack Mode when people saw
pictures and videos of scp096 his face
the creature seemed to have an innate
sense of when people were viewing these
representations even when it should have
had no conceivable way of knowing it
didn't matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the
viewer and the creature the attack mode
would still activate and once it did it
seemed as though nothing could stop the
creature from hunting down the the one
who saw its face with all this new data
special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key it cell was a 5 MX 5
m x 5 m airtight steel Cube fitted with
Advanced pressure sensors and Laser
detectors to ensure that scp096 remained
in its cell without risking anyone
having visual contact with the
creature's face all cameras and video
equipment were strictly forbidden and
weekly checks for any cracks or holes in
the containment cell were mandatory of
course none of this would stop the
Creature if anyone somehow saw its face
in order to solve that little problem Dr
Den would need to continue his
research to find a method of subverting
the creature's deadly gland they needed
to know exactly what they were dealing
with but how could they when even a
glance at a photo or video of the being
meant certain death a potential solution
was proposed creating an artistic
representation of the creature's face
something that hadn't yet been attempted
but but how would they achieve such a
fee simple they'd procure a d-class
prisoner with some artistic talent and
they found one who had been a tattoo
artist before becoming a foundation
guinea pig Dr Dan formulated an
ingenious plan for keeping this d-class
alive for long enough to accurately draw
an image of scp096
face he would be placed in a bosphore
diving bell several kilometers
underwater and tens of KM away from the
containment cell where the SCP was being
held the d-class was made to look at a
photo of the creature's face and then
replicate that image in a pencil sketch
Dr Dan first confirmed that the
creature's Attack Mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the deadly context
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp096 send someone viewing its face and
entered its inconsolable crying State
followed by its Attack Mode it broke out
of containment easily and began making a
b line for the d-class traversing the
miles between it and its prey the
d-class didn't know it as he locked the
finished drawing into a separate
autonomous submersible but he was
already dead as the drawing made its way
up to a researcher on the surface scp096
dived into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathos spere was breached and
the de class was torn to shreds scp096
was recaptured without issue by surface
recovery team foxtrot 303a and further
testing on the drawing showed that
artistic representations of SCP 96's
face were in fact harmless from this
experience we now know that the creature
has a gaunt face with totally white eyes
possibly indicating blindness and a
grossly extended jaw nevertheless Dr Dan
was adamant that scp096 was too
dangerous to be left alive and requested
per permission from the upper echelons
of the foundation to terminate the
creature by any means necessary however
the doctor's request would fall on deaf
ears until it all started with a
seemingly innocent image while it's now
been redacted for your safety the black
spec inside the yellow circle was once a
minuscule image of scp096 taken
unknowingly in the 1990s by a
semi-professional mountaineer one day
they were looking at Old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny Speck
without even noticing that he had seen
anything but scp096 noticed and began
entering its Attack Mode it tore through
its steel containment unit like tissue
paper causing the release of a nerve
agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force to one in Hot
Pursuit Dr Alexy who was helping to
manage the site where the SCP was
contained was in dismay over the
situation Dr Dan was out of the country
at the time trying to discover more
about the creature's Origins
however he did leave the mobile task
force with a new secret weapon against
the rampaging Shy Guy project scramble
scramble were state-of-the-art goggles
featuring a new technology created by Dr
Dan which using artistic Renditions of 0
96's facial features could detect and
scramble the features of scp096 into an
unrecognizable form preventing the
normally deadly effect of gazing upon
its face in theory this would allow MTF
t one to engage safely with 096 Once its
prey had been eliminated and bring it
back into containment but disaster
struck on two fronts first the prey in
question was located in a population
Center creating the potential for a huge
loss of life and the second bigger
problem was that the scrambled
technology didn't work as stray pixels
of the creature's face would reach the
eyes of the task force before the
internal microprocessor had time to
scramble them the mission turned into a
death sentence as scp096 slaughtered
almost the entire task force as well as
a number of civilians in town including
an infant and its entire family it was a
Monumental disaster made even worse by a
final Revelation Dr Dan and Dr Alexi had
themselves facilitated the entire
Containment Breach and allowed the
resulting Massacre to happen with Dr Dan
hoping it would be enough motivation for
foundation command to Greenlight his
research into destroying the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the Bloodshed his plan worked and
the SCP Foundation sought him way
approving his request to neutralize
scp096
however success comes at a cost for Dr
Dan once he figures out a way to finally
kill the creature though done in his
line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity but considering
how much damage scp096 is capable of
causing if it ever got to a major
population Center or even worse was ever
caught on camera and broadcast to a
worldwide audience the doctor himself
would likely deem his own death a
justifiable cost to this day the
foundation is researching ways to kill
the creature and they're still looking
for their Silver Bullet and the pressure
is on they hadn't known about the
seemingly innocent picture that sparked
the last containment breach the one
taken decades ago in which the shy guy
had only occupied four tiny pixels four
tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives
lost so be careful where you look
because who knows how many other photos
of the creature are lurking up there
photos with an innocent dot in the
background your eyes glance over it not
even noticing the little blip until you
hear a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer and closer and closer and
then it's already too late SCP 682 must
be destroyed as soon as possible so
Begins the SCP Foundation file on the
dreaded SCP 682 a highly intelligent
reptilian monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death for God
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called hard tokill
reptile it's been subjected to some of
the most deadly weapons and traps the
foundation could devise and survived
attacks from some of its deadliest
fellow scps but before we tell you about
the foundation's many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard tokill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about SCP 682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead unlike
some other creatures like scp096 and SCP
173 which are murderous but exhibit no
real higher processing skills SCP 682
possesses cunning Advanced reasoning and
even human level logical intelligence
SCP 682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage state where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit cuz if you don't you better
believe it's going to hit you back a 100
times harder this brings us to the main
event some of the SCP foundation's most
ambitious and frighten in attempts to
terminate SCP 682 or even understand how
it could theoretically be terminated
there are quite literally 2 many
unsuccessful attempts for us to list
them all here so think of this as a
highlight reel of the foundation's most
prominent failures 682 was first cross
tested with SCP 017 a humanoid Shadow
entity shown to be able to consume
matter with its shadows and leave no
traces behind test on tissue samples
from 682 showed that SCP 017 was able to
consume said tissues with no adverse
effects however when SCP 017 was placed
into the containment chamber with the
actual creature 682 let out a horrific
Roar that was so loud it damaged nearby
audio equipment SCP 017 fled to the
corner of the room and 682 in its rage
State attempted to breach containment
agents managed to suppress and remove
the creature but no meaningful damage
was logged attempt failed SCP 173 the
killer statue was later brought in
hoping that its thus far impeccable
track record for killing what hold
strong the second that 173 was
introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over 6
hours as 682 stared at 13 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682s eyes with High
Caliber snip sniper rifles breaking the
line of sight and causing 173 to attack
those 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes
regenerated the creature was not killed
it then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carrase that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their insiration the SCP Foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682 scp096 also known
as the shy guy as astute SCP fans will
already know this being kills anything
that sees its face with no known
exceptions and when it enters its attack
mode it's thought to be quite literally
Unstoppable or at least it was while
scp096 was able to to destroy 85% of
682s original body mass during their
27-hour battle it was left mentally
broken wounded and huddled in the corner
to this day if ever confronted with SCP
682 the shy guy reacts in pure Terror
turning away and clawing at its own face
attempt failed during a deadly
Containment Breach SCP 682 also went
head-to-head organically with another
iconic SCP Hall of Famer SCP 10 6 also
known as the old man the old man and a
shape-shifting psionic anomaly known as
SCP 953 broke into 682s containment cell
the old man pulled both of his fellow
anomalous combatants into his pocket
Dimension to continue the battle on his
terms however despite losing 67% of his
body mass during the ensuing pocket
Dimension Showdown 682 still prevailed
with the old man eventually fleeing back
to his cell and 953 being collected and
taken away by agents once again SCP 682
continued to hold the title but it
wasn't just cross testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to SCP 682s highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the outset for example launching a
powerful thermonuclear missile at the
creature was soundly rejected by 05
command on the premise that if the
creature wasn't destroyed and Evol to
the point where it could shrug off nukes
Humanity would be pretty much done for
other ideas were abandoned just for
being too ridiculous such as one
researcher suggestion to fly the
creature through the air and drop it
from a considerable height hoping to
kill it with a high altitude impact I'm
not sure we even need to tell you why
that's a terrible idea but during the
experiments on SCP 682 the studies range
from honest to incompetent to straight
up
evil one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for a
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct after all the foundation is
meant to be cold not cruel it was SCP
682 that had the Monopoly on cruelty mic
kill agents were a resounding failure
they attempted to dismember 682 with a
powerful laser only to have the creature
develop reflective services that displac
the beam and caused catastrophic damage
to the area around it they attempted to
kill the creature by sucking all the air
out out of its containment facility and
create a vacuum but it expelled a
dangerous gaseous compound that reacted
violently and exploded when air was once
again introduced into the room the
foundation used High Precision Blades to
slice SCP 682 into approximately 12,000
pieces then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12,000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know in fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
car Pace composed of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance it had set a trap and that
trap had been wildly successful the
creature's ability to adapt to seemingly
any offense is unparalleled to the point
where found Foundation staff have no
idea how to classify this creature
whether it's organic inorganic or even
alive at all based on any definitions we
could understand at every turn the
creature just raised more questions what
is it is it possible to destroy it at
all by any means who was even trying to
kill who here because it certainly
seemed like SCP 682 had a masterful KD
ratio by now more extreme Feats of cross
testing continued in the foundation's
growing desperation to eliminate this
monster SCP 162 which is a hypnotic ball
of sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682s
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for scp's
001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level naturally SCP 682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross test of all was between 682 and
SCP
053 who manifests as a kind innocent
little girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal
Tendencies and all who come into contact
with her for more than 10 minutes the
people with these Tendencies would then
attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attacked
053 and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacked 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell but
that didn't happen what did occur was
considerably more shocking than any kind
of violence when 053 entered 682s
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a single
act in Defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards 053 also wept
sad at being separated from her new
friend to this day despite further
testing the foundation has no idea how
or why this happened like many details
surrounding SCP 682 it shrouded in
deeply frustrating
mystery and so the tale of SCP 682
continues in spite of the foundation's
best efforts the monster continues to
breach containment and Slaughter with
some regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath nobody knows where exactly the
creature is from what its true nature is
or why its ability to adapt and
regenerate far exceeds any known
organism on this planet perhaps one day
through enough research and cross
testing we can someday answer these
questions with scientific Precision but
until then we only have one answer
hatred Never Dies the esteemed Doctor
Thomas morstead entered the cell of the
anomaly he'd been warned and even
chastised by his colleagues but who in
the foundation could tell him what to do
he was the best at what he did maybe the
greatest in the whole history of the
foundation as he entered the room SCP
049 bid in welcome cordial as always
always so polite in fact that you'd
never guess you were talking to a killer
Dr morstead knew the truth of what he
was dealing with but he also believed he
could get through to
049 calm him exercise the devil from him
it was the meeting of two great minds
one of them human one of them part human
part something that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles this one would
turn into a massacre before we get to
that fateful meeting there are some
things you should know about the anomaly
known as SCP 049 if you saw him in the
street the first thing you think of is
playing because 049 always looked the
same a man dressed in black robes with a
plague doctor's mask but this wasn't a
costume that could be taken off in fact
it wasn't a costume at all it was him
the robes had grown out of him like an
exoskeleton that horrible mask with the
pointed nose wasn't covering his face it
was his face a kind of shell that had
seemingly sprouted from bone the first
reports came during World War II in a
pictures town in the south of France
called montal people had begun going
missing children disappeared from their
beds in the middle of the night and
weren't seen again adults went to the
market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't Criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eye witness who would break the case no
this was something else something that
the town's folk could never understand
word spread and that's when a search and
Discovery team was sent from the
foundation it was a cold Dark Night in
January of 1941 when the team found what
they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the grand
chatau deu to find a mass man sitting
next to an open fire and he wasn't alone
the floor around him looked like it was
moving a on closer inspection the team
saw that the floor was covered with ring
grasping bodies it's patience as it
called them beu sha said the thing
welcome to my home those so-called
patients crawled towards the team
intented seemed to cause harm the
hostiles now known as SCP 049 d2s were
deemed dangerous and had to be
eliminated a sight it seemed that didn't
bother 049 in the slightest it just sat
there occasionally looking up from
writing notes in a leatherbound book as
his patience were gunned down once the
Carnage ended it simply closed its book
stood up and allowed itself to be
escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 02 site 19 the few
that came into contact with 049 remarked
that it was a pleasure for them with its
impeccable manners vast knowledge of
medicine and human Anatomy sharp tongue
and stinging wind they almost became
Spellbound listening to it caught in the
throws of its charms until with the
Simple Touch of its hand it would drain
the life from them that's why SCP 049
was classified as a uid that's why armed
guards were always stationed outside
itself cell it's why doctors took great
precautions when in its presence and
it's why Dr morstead should have known
better remember when 049 was discovered
in France it willingly went with the
team like it was half Happ it had been
found as if it had planned its own
capture when it arrived at the facility
it didn't act like it was contained
against its will it was like it was
returning home initial findings as to
the biology of 049 were that it didn't
require any sustenance at all not even
water it seemed contend to be left alone
with its notebooks it did not object
when it was asked if it could share some
of its notes and gladly handed over its
journals but upon examination it was
discovered that they were written in the
language that no linguist or
cryptologist has so far been able to
translate it's apparent that 049 derives
much satisfaction from seeing so-called
experts struggle over its text unable to
read those notes a long line of doctors
visited 049 in itself cell each
fascinated by what they beheld it was
learned that it has travel the globe it
speaks many languages but prefers to
speak what it calls Le long de French it
asks for only one thing warm-blooded
animals the facility agreed to supply
049 with various kinds including rabbits
cattle and even an ape on one occasion
just like with humans it could kill the
animals with a mere Touch of its hand
sucking the life right out of them but
that wasn't even the most incredible
part soon those animals would rise again
as if reanimated by 049 they would
become for all intents and purposes the
Living Dead and they were hostile after
several unfortunate incidents they were
taken from the cell the moment they
arose and disposed of in the incinerator
this was not not to the liking of 049
who would claim it had cured the animals
for it the world was sick it saw plague
and pestilence everywhere and the
meaning of its existence was to rid the
world of disease humans it said
contained a virus and had to be cleansed
in the first days after arriving at the
facility 049 didn't seem to pose a
threat to humans it was quite friendly
in fact it seemed aware of the fear it
caused in staff and would often go out
of its way to make them feel comfortable
and safe
this was a ruse of course or a Canard as
049 like to say it had no intention to
help humans no it had come for humans it
wasn't trapped it had set a trap one of
the first people to truly upset z49 was
Dr Raymond Ham a well-respected
physician that had twice been a
contender for the Nobel Prize for his
more mainstream work what had confused
Dr Ham the most was not 09's cloth-like
exoskeleton or even his ability to
reanimate the dead but the bad that it
used 049 was somehow able to pull a
seemingly endless supply of surgical
tools from that bag sometimes it would
even pull out objects that Were Somehow
larger than the bag itself it was as if
the bag connected to somewhere else and
that's what Dr Ham wanted to talk about
on that fateful day with 049 on one side
of the cell and Dr Ham on the other he
asked how is it that you can produce a
great quantity of tools from that bag
I've observed you and it seems to me
that you are doing The Impossible dear
doctor replied 049 The Scourge The Great
dying cannot be fought with a handful of
toys my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what I require
you dear sir it seems are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at Dr Ham I detect you
are unwell it said in a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah just a cold if you had
seen what I have seen you would not
utter such insulting words Dr Ham pulled
out some papers from a briefcase and
approached 049 holding them close enough
so it could read them you see said Dr
Ham pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not disease they were perfectly
healthy before they died and your
so-called cure it turned them into
something quite terrible we found that
if they were left alone they began to
eat each other and then themselves 049
did not respond and after a brief pause
said only a good day to your doctor
please close the door on your way out
you should get some rest ham refused to
go and instead turned the conversation
to this real interest the bag demanding
that 049 let him see inside of it very
well doctor 049 said in private 049
began to pull a series of long metal
poles out of its bag followed by a
rolled up curtain that it hung between
them creating a kind of medical tent
around Dr Ham it seemed to stare for
just a moment into the observation a
camera outside of itself before whipping
the curtain Shut Dr Ham was discovered 3
hours later crawling around the floor of
049 cell now another mindless Undead
when he was retrieved by security 049
didn't even look up from his notebook Dr
Ham didn't get the incinerator treatment
but he did receive a fatal dose of drugs
a mercy a removal team was sent to 049
cell but it had said there was no need
for special extraction techniques it
would go willingly wherever they wanted
to go it was not it said an enemy of the
people the hypocritic oath forbids me to
hurt a human being it said while walking
to the interrogation Center my only
desire is to offer you my services and
expertise the floors and walls of the
interrogation Center room were painted a
bright white even the table was white
which contrasted with 049 a mass of
black sitting in the middle of the room
during the interrogation it refused to
admit or even accept that it had killed
Dr Ham I cured him I removed the
pestilence from his body it said it was
later asked if it regretted its actions
to which it replied well good sir one
always regrets the loss of a colleague
for any reason but I stand by my actions
the pestilence must be abated before it
is too late every 2 weeks from that
point 049 was given animals the
scientists at the facility observed it
time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them up organs would
be carefully removed with perfect
precision it was astounding to even
train surgeons just how talented 049 was
I require a close relative of yours said
049 one day to a young Doctor Who
expressed shock that it was asked for
one of the doctor's family members I
mean a great a said 049 not your dear
Aunt there were several instances of 049
displaying a crude sense of humor staff
would almost forget that the thing that
they were talking to wasn't human almost
and it was Dr Thomas morstead that had
supplied the great a AP orangutanes in
fact that had been rescued from the
rainforests of Borneo only to be taken
to 049 South then one day something
changed 049 told Dr morstead that its
work was done that it accomplished what
it had wanted to do and could someone
remove the cured animal from itself I
think you'd find that it's quite the
work of art a Triumph 049 said through
the intercom when the removal team
entered the cell they found the
orangutang or what was left of it it was
lying in the corner of the cell the top
of its skull had been removed leaving
its brain Exposed on its face was the
expression of relaxation and from its
mouth it issued very soft squeaks like
that of an infant 049 said tell Dr Mora
that its rage mechanism no longer exists
I've removed the amydala and made some
changes to the hypothalamus and lyic
system it is cured and quite harmless
the next day Dr morstead announced that
he wanted to visit 049 cell himself
after which he heard A Chorus of
disapproval from his colleagues all
telling him that 049 was now too
dangerous Dr Ham was sick replied
morstead and 049 has assured us that he
would never take another human life he's
never lied to us and I'm going to take
him at his word it appeared that 049 had
created the perfect specimen so what was
next Dr morstead had to know everyone is
sick 049 told Dr morstead after the two
had talked for a couple of minutes the
great pandemic has started Fe not doctor
I have a cure no longer will you humans
spread your disease I'm afraid you are
wrong replied the doctor this pandemic
you speak of does not exist we can
happily live with our pathogens we have
done so for Millennial Dr morstead
became angry that he couldn't get
through to 049 I'm afraid you are
suffering from paranoia it is you who
need to be cured you have no idea said
049 standing up what are you doing
shouted Morad you promis you wouldn't
hurt a human again I'm not hurting you
I'm healing you 049 said and leapt
across the room in a Flash placing a
hand on the doctor's head morstad
slumped to the ground they were being
watched in the observation room and this
had gone too far he had to be moved to
the containment cells permanently mobile
task force Epsilon 11 was right on the
scene and burst through the door no
imagination 049 said to himself those
humans have no imagination at all he
began walking towards the task force to
open fire on the anomaly but the bullets
bounced off its black coat and mask SCP
049 calmly touched each of the members
of the task force one by one draining
the life from them the last one standing
stopped firing and attempted to run but
again 049 leapt across the room black
cap billowing out behind him and gently
touched the man causing him to drop to
the floor 049 stepped over the bodies of
the Fallen team and walked out of the
containment cell the full details of
what happened next are available only to
to the 05 Council what are sometimes
called the overseers the redacted report
that is available reads standard secure
humanoid containment cell research
sector 02 site 19 subject SCP 049 date
of breach redacted euklid class SCP 049
breach cell and subsequently gained
access to adjoining rooms and nearby
buildings breach lasted approximately 3
days and 5 hours total casualties
redacted with redacted number of
survivors requiring incineration therapy
course of action Department of science
Alchemy division suggested injecting
anti-trans morphi disinfectant into
class D former prisoners who were
transported to site and allowed them to
come into contact with SCP 049 SCP
failed to reanimate injected prisoners
and cure them SCP 049 acknowledged this
failure and surrendered to mobile task
force alpha 1 SCP 049 then requested to
be contained present containment under
responsibility of redacted redacted
present location of SCP 049 redacted end
of report we were a team despite our
differences in spite of the Terrible
Things they'd
done we were still a
team that's not how the hups saw it
though no the guys upstairs with their
perfectly pressed shirts for them we
were judged by our level of
expendability and they knew that our
next mission was a death
sentence one by one that thing took out
my team my
friends snapping their necks so quickly
with such ease that no sooner did I hear
the scream they were dead we had been
used I'd been used delivered as prey to
the Predator a plot that was sanctioned
by the bosses and approved with a blood
red
stamp why did they do it I'm still
trying to figure that out maybe that's
something you can tell me after you hear
how these so-called scientific men left
us in the
cell and in the hands of SCP 17
3 for me it had been the best of times
before it became the worst of times the
best because I'd quickly risen through
the ranks of the facility the worse
because well I'll get to that I was
never the best student I finished high
school by the skin of my teeth and my
job prospects looked Bleak but I was
lucky I guess or at least I thought so
at the time you see I have an uncle
sigfried who did some work for the
government I never actually knew what he
did just that it was secretive work I
used to imagine he was some sort of
super spy so you can imagine how excited
I was when he found out I needed a job
and he offered to help me out I couldn't
believe it I always thought he hated me
I'd overheard him telling my parents
that I was a no good dead be but now
he'd had of a change of heart and was
willing to take me under his wing what
would I get to do undercover
intelligence gathering International
assassinations just you wait he said and
that's how I found myself walking into a
sprawling futuristic looking facility
where they handed me a level one
security clearance card with big bold
letters that read janitor but I was
happy just the word security clearance
made me feel important and it beat
flipping
burgers I pushed mops turned off lights
fired up generators clocked in and
clocked
out but all that time they must have
been watching me grooming me waiting for
the day they could throw me to the W
I should have known I've always been an
Expendable kind of guy after a few years
I was called to an office and there was
a man in a plaid shirt and kind of a
tweed jacket that professors wear he
asked me do you have any idea about what
we actually do
here and to be honest I didn't I knew
that there were many parts of the
facility I couldn't enter I imagine that
down a maze of corridors were weapons
being built or prisoners being
interrogated
but I had no idea about the anomalies
how could I before I was told anything I
had to sign a bunch of forms there were
so many I thought I'd get to find out
who really killed
JFK and while they didn't come out and
say it what I inferred was that if I
ever talk about what happens at the
facility to someone outside the facility
well let's just say it's not the kind of
thing they'd spell out on a piece of
paper but it involves padded cells and
Rusty
tools I wasn't scared though I was part
of something big
something secret and I left it so I
signed my life away with no hesitation
soon after I was introduced to my first
anomaly the safe class of
course they took me to an observation
room and from that room I could see into
another room with a sign on the wall
that read SCP 067 I just stood there
waiting for something to happen when in
walked another guy in a white lap coat
welcome to your first anomaly he said is
it okay if I hook you up to this heart
monitor we want to gauge your reaction
to what you see all I can see I told him
is an empty room with a table and what
looks like a pen on top of some papers
correct he said half smiling as if I was
some kind of idiot that's SCP
067 I thought about telling him that if
I needed years of training before I
could see a pen that I probably should
have taken that fast food job could have
been a shift manager by now then they
brought a young chimpanzee into the room
small enough to be harmless one of the
guys forced a pen into the scared shim's
hand and something strange happened
started scribbling nonsense at first but
suddenly it was sketching and drawing
faster and faster I could catch glimpses
of words and images by the time they
dragged it out it was flailing around
like it was possessed that pen has power
said the man in the lab coat a power
whose Source or origin we don't fully
understand that's why we're here that's
why you are here one of the guys in the
other room held The Chimps drawing up to
the window it was a perfect sketch of
the Tower of London intricate and
Brilliant above the sketch was the title
Tower to of London tutor period Circa
1541 the year Margaret pole the counts
of Salsbury lost her head on The
Chopping Block underneath that the chimp
had written pity she was no traitor take
it from me I was there they didn't need
to look at the heart rate monitor to see
that I was
shocked that was far from the only
anomaly I'd come into contact with and I
must have been doing something right
because in time I went from level one to
two to level three security clearance
and that's only made me a containment
specialist I won't bore you with all the
details but as you can guess I dealt
with the containment of anomalies a lot
of my time was spent looking through
small windows and cell doors making sure
that whatever was inside was still
inside and still in one piece other
times I worked with field agents when
anomalies were brought in a transition
period that the arrested freaks didn't
much like there was one certain anomaly
though that I was tasked to oversee on
many occasions I like to think of it as
my pet but in hindsight I was its pet
this was SCP 173 something that was in
what we call the uid class
classification meaning that we don't
fully understand it but know it is very
dangerous we know it's intelligent we
know it's unpredictable and we know it
will kill and for that reason there's
people tked with containing it and
keeping an eye on it at all
times at first glance you wouldn't guess
just how dangerous 173 is you wouldn't
think it's incredibly intelligent in
fact you'd think the opposite that's
because it's more or less a walking slab
of concrete and rebar with stunted Limbs
and traces of spray paint that give the
impression of a Dopey face we have to
enter it sell twice a week for cleaning
duties it leaves a disgusting foul
smelling liquid on the floor a reddish
brown substance that I can only describe
as a mix of blood and waste products
where that stuff comes from has remained
a mystery since we first contained it in
93 going into the cell was always a
three-man job because and this is maybe
the weirdest part about 173 it can't
move if human eyes are watching it
that's why you need at least two people
watching it at all times if you were in
the room watching 173 by yourself and
blinked you'd be dead before your eyes
open we don't know how it moves that
fast but in that fraction of a second
your neck is snapped so hard it's almost
like being decapitated I've seen the
videos to prove it all it took was a
sneeze he wasn't even finished getting
the rest of the auu out when there was a
Flash and his partner was left lying on
the ground his head twisted around the
wrong direction so you can understand
why we now require three men for any
time we must enter 173
cell then a few months ago I was told
that a long process would begin to train
and re-educate some future class D's
class D's are mostly prisoners with
lifelong sentences or those we've taken
from death row and given a new lease on
life we were apparently underst staffed
so why not employ these men whose lives
had pretty much ended anyway that was
the rationale or at least that's what
they told me I was told to train them on
their new job mopping up 173s mess so
that me and the rest of the containment
Specialists could focus on more
important tasks they hadn't been through
the training I had seen what I had seen
But after showing them the video of 173
nearly taking off a man's head they were
more than willing to follow the rules
they understood not to Blink or turn
away or sneeze and that any lapse in
Focus could lead to a violent death so I
started to show them the ropes how we
move as a team into the cell and always
keep the others informed on what we're
doing 173 was always sitting in the
corner of a cell no expression on that
crude face but when we walked in its
cell I got the feeling it knew something
had changed I felt almost as if it was
communicating with me but I couldn't
tell what it was trying to say and then
it
happened it was a Tuesday after
afternoon 3 days from the last time we'
cleaned as usual 173 had covered the
floor with that horrible liquid we
headed in to clean my new team alert as
always and some of them cleaned While
others kept their eyes focused on the
thing in the corner things were going
smoothly when we heard a noise I knew
very well it was the sound of the cell
door locking someone must have screwed
up hey guys we're locked in here I
shouted through the intercom nothing
guys the damn door is locked
nothing I lost it a bit open the door
will you
nothing my team looked at me the ones
not on eye contact Duty that is as if I
should know what to do hoping that this
had happened before and that there was
some kind of standard plan to deal with
it there wasn't we were always observed
when in the room and I knew that a
technician couldn't accidentally lock
the door it was impossible there were
protocols someone had done this on
purpose the four of us sat in the corner
of the the room as far from 173 as
possible our eyes locked on it it didn't
move an inch as usual just stood staring
at the wall as it always did we stayed
awake through the night talking a little
holding on to the slim hope that
something had gone wrong but as night
turned to day again we all began to lose
hope we weren't sent here to clean we
were a test totally Expendable Lab Rats
but I wouldn't go down without a fight
we couldn't just stay up forever that
was a death sentence I suggested that
two of us stand one sit and rest and one
get some sleep we take shifts couple
hours on couple hours off maybe we could
show that we wouldn't give up they'd
have time to realize what they were
doing was insane call off the test and
come free us we made it through a couple
of shifts like this and it seemed like
we'd actually be able to make it another
day or two when everything went wrong it
was my turn to sit and rest when I heard
the worst possible noise
snoring the con next to me was sleeping
quietly so it must be one of the
standers I glanced over for just a split
second and saw both of them leaning
against the cell wall dozing at the same
time I saw the flash crack snap pop one
after another their necks were snapped
I'm not sure how it happened but I was
standing again staring at 173 who was
now in the corner dead bodies with their
heads twisted around piled up in front
of it I couldn't take it anymore I
couldn't see at this thing forever I
felt myself giving up I lowered my head
to the ground and then finally broke my
gaze ready to
die and then nothing happened I slowly
raised my head back up and there it was
its hideous face inches away from mine
it was then that I understood what we'd
been containing what we'd
underestimated I felt it again like it
was telling me
something it was telling me to close my
eyes to sleep
so I did but as my eyes closed I didn't
see Darkness I saw 173 or something like
it but not in the cell I saw it outside
in the world standing over children
sleeping in the beds watching I saw them
hiding in the shadows staring out at
passers by then I realized they weren't
watching waiting to pounce no they were
hiding
my eyes popped open as the door opened
and inrush six security Personnel they
took me outside jabbed my leg with a
syringe injecting me with something as
the world faded
away incident report time and date
redacted following the experimental
forced interaction with uclid class
anomaly SCP
173 subject has ceased responding to
external stimuli and appears to have
taken on the traits and behaviors of the
anomaly subject now spends entire day
sitting in corner of cell staring at the
wall staff are advised to proceed with
caution when dealing with subject as the
only Behavior they engage in is an
attempt to strangle anyone who enters
the cell no treatments have shown any
Effectiveness and subject will
unfortunately require incarceration
likely forever almost all cross testing
to kill or pacify SCP 682 had failed
miserably if you haven't seen it go
watch our video on the legendary hard
tokill reptile to see just how powerful
and terrifying this creature is it faced
the gate Guardian an SCP with a flaming
sword hotter than the sun capable of
tearing your atoms to shreds and came
out fine in its face off with a
horrifying scp096 also known as the shy
guy it broke the Shy Guy's mind and
reduced it to gibbering despair even as
scps with supposedly unlimited Powers
simply refus to engage the beast in
combat so when it was proposed that they
test 682 with SCP 999 a creature known
among found Foundation staff as the
Tickle Monster the idea was considered
laughable 682 had been burned suffocated
cut up incinerated and growled in the
faces of the Gods how could this
so-called Tickle Monster ever hope to
survive an encounter let alone win a
fight some even believe that this was
the last we'd see of SCP
999 but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover SCP
999 is an amazing and unique SCP in of
itself but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy creature Beyond
extraordinary prepare yourself for the
heartwarming Yes you heard that right
the heartwarming story of SCP
999 several highly trained agents on 682
detail Place 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 lb SCP 999 was
nothing compared to the monstrosity it
was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past caused minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long- lasting damage
of any kind to a living thing even its
diet consists only of candy and sweets
with a particular preference for M&M and
Necco Wafers it consumes these treats
through the cell membrane of its slimy
body much like amoeba this extremely
stretchy membrane means the creature is
highly malleable including the ability
to stretch and flatten itself out to a
mere 2 cm thick at rest the creature
takes a dome like shape around 2 m wide
and 1 m in height the closest things the
creature has to limbs are preh hensil
pseudopods those are the arm-like
projections normally seen on single
celled organisms of which it has at
least three the more you hear about this
utterly harmless creature the more that
matching it up with the pure embodiment
of absolute hatred known as SCP 682
feels downright cruel in absolute
contrast to the misanthropic attitudes
of the reptile 999 loves humans it has a
playful doglike attitude much like an
overe excited puppy when approached 999
will react with extreme joy and Slither
towards the nearest person in order to
interact it will leap onto them using
two of its three prehensile pseudopods
to hug the person while the third
nuzzles the person's face emitting
high-pitch cing and gurgling noises
throughout the creature is apparently
Pleasant in every conceivable fashion as
even its odor has been reported to smell
just like the favorite scent of whoever
is smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
Play-Doh it's almost impossible to
oversell just how beloved and benevolent
this strange creature is it's one of the
rare Sapient scps to earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times apart from a
1hour bedtime period between 8: and 9:00
p.m. in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of doglike apology the closest the
foundation has ever come to having a
real incident with the creature was the
time someone accidentally FedEd a can of
caffeinated Cola causing it to become
hyper for an hour before becoming
visibly queasy you'll be relieved to
know that it's since made a full
recovery but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster
the employees observing the test watched
in suspense as 999 began to
enthusiastically Slither towards 682
it's no surprise that after being
tortured and almost killed hundreds of
times during testing 682 had grown jaded
to the Cross test it was regularly
subjected to when it saw this strange
orange blob squelching across the ground
towards it it sighed and groaned
expecting the worst what is that the
creature asked of its gelatinous guest
SCP 999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitch squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682s
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682s acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and said H what is this
I
feel
good well The Observers looked on
stunned at what was happening 999 began
to Slither and crawl up from between
682s toes reformed on its scaly leg and
slithered up along its side until it
reached the neck there it began to
nuzzle like it had never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling repeating a
phrase that the foundation never would
have imagine coming from
682 feel so
happy
happy happy just when you thought SCP
999 couldn't possibly be more adorable
you learn about its greatest power
bringing Joy anyone and anything that
comes into contact with the creature
even in past ing will experience a kind
of mild Euphoria as one's contact with
the creature is prolonged this
overwhelming sense of Joy increases and
continues long after you've separated
from it prolonged contact has completely
cured depression anxiety and PTSD along
with a number of other conditions
including rage and antisocial
personality disorders serial killers
practically become Saints after coming
into prolonged contact with 999 and in
that moment 682 was no exception and
there truly does not appear to to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to SCP 999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more scp-999
also appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be a
true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
Staff as a result the creature is pretty
much universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one SCP who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the Beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that The
Observers and attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter it rolled onto its back
slamming its huge tail against the door
it had just Fallen victim to one of 99's
favorite pastimes tickle fights hence
how it earned its Tickle Monster
nickname among staff the tickle fight
continued until 682 appeared to tire and
fall asleep with a smile still on its
face after 15 minutes of inactivity two
d-class Personnel were commanded to
enter and retrieve SCP 999 from the
containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its Slumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all Personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent Rampage however in spite of this
999 showed no fear and helped save some
of the bystanders as security officers
subdued and recaptured 682 and even
after all of this 999 showed no hard
feelings towards 682 and indicated a
desire to play again it's a creature
whose capacity for love is so Limitless
that it's practically immune to fear
which is all well and good because the
true enemy that 999 is destined to face
is infinitely more powerful and
terrifying than 682 could ever hope to
be what is this monster and why should
999 have to face it someday the answers
to these questions all lie in the true
origins of SCP 9999 available only to
those with level five clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no SCP 999 without
scp-231-7 SCP 231 was a collection of
seven girls all impregnated by horrific
nightmares in a ritual performed by a
cult known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these girls over
the years that followed gave birth to
some of the most horri rfic monsters
imaginable one of which According to
some was SCP
682 these beings were manifested by the
Scarlet King a powerful interdimensional
nightmare God believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within R and many other
dimensions Foundation hups have declared
the Scarlet King to be the greatest
existing threat to the Multiverse at
large and SCP 231 was his latest direct
interaction with our universe the only
surviving member of SCP 231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to SCP 999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that the
creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments SCP 999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a Scarlet King aligned culture
known as the deas SCP 999 is still very
much in its infancy yet it already has
the power to pacify its monstrous
siblings like the AFF forementioned
682 it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of SCP 999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted while the humble
SCP 999 rarely outshines its frightening
competitors to those truly in the know
999 is one of the most powerful and
valuable scps in existence and may be
the greatest asset in the foundation's
Arsenal for the war against dangerous
anomalous activity after all what could
strike more fear into their hearts than
the knowledge that it might be love
rather than Firepower that finally
dethrones the Scarlet King and for the
knowledge that it may one day save
everything we know from a fate so much
worse than death with nothing but
affection for everyone and everything
it's worth offering thanks to the little
orange block
or at least an extra pack of M&M's
before bedtime this is impossible the
SCP site director wasn't normally a calm
or cheerful man but the researcher had
rarely seen him as angry as he was right
now his face turned a deep beat red as
he scanned the documents on his desk
before he asked how months of valuable
research on this subject had suddenly
gone blank the data was completely gone
the researcher gulped nervously hoping a
demotion wasn't in his future and nodded
how could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions could the being they were
studying somehow have erased all these
documents himself that's just what the
researcher had been trying to find out
for months with hours and hours spent
trying to learn the extent of its
abilities well where are they the site
director asked I want everything you
have the researcher dropped a print out
of their research on the mysterious
subject's abilities on the director's
desk every relevant line read data lost
the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew well everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researcher sat down and began to relay
everything he could about SCP 343 which
some of the other researchers had
started to refer to by the nickname God
SCP 343 was first cited in Prague just
an unassuming older man wandering the
streets he seemed completely normal to
everyone who passed him by until he
decided he was tired of staying on the
ground an SCP agent stationed in the
area noticed the old man disappear from
the streets as if he was blinking out of
existence only to appear on a rooftop
nearby the local SCP teams were
marshaled and they had soon Tracked Down
what seemed to be a very powerful
specimen but SCP 343 didn't seem
concerned he reacted calmly when
detained by the foundation and went with
them willingly he was detained in a
standard holding cell for interrogation
and examination but he seemed completely
at ease with his sudden confinement it
would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man was anything but
doctors Beck in nlu was brought in to
consult on the scp's classification and
that's when the first anomalies began
their assessments matched initially but
when it came time to describe him
physically things took a strange turn
older male seemingly non-descript and
with no unusual physical features
Caucasian in appearance Dr ndlovu was
confused by what Dr Beck was describing
in his report this man was clearly black
the two doctors quarreled unable to
square their differing perceptions they
decided to bring in a third impartial
view to settle it their fellow
researcher Dr Juan she didn't take long
before coming back with her assessment
older male seemingly non-descript and
with no unusual physical features Asian
and appearance possibly Chinese whatever
SCP 343 was he seemed to be perceived by
each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race but that was only the
start of the anomalies surrounding the
old man in the holding cell Dr Beck
started making regular visits to the
mysterious man and in their first
interview he asked the old man who he
was and how he came by his abilities the
old man had a simple response I created
the universe Dr Beck stifled the laugh
and decided to indulge the old man's
delusion it was a fascinating claim but
could he prove it without another word
SCP 343 got up from his chair laugh and
turned around and walked through the
solid wall in the holding cell and
disappeared Dr Beck was about to hit the
panic button and Marshall the facility
security to find him when the strange
man reappeared walking through the solid
wall the only thing that was different
he was holding a hamburger which he sat
down and enjoyed the facility quickly
went on lockdown and a full
investigation was done into how SCP 343
breach containment but there was no
evidence of any security breach no
failures in containment and no evidence
of any other cells failing SCP 343
hadn't broken through the security he
had just ignored it as if it wasn't
there at all when questioned about how
he had gone on his hamburger run he
simply repeated his belief that he was
God in between bites of his fast food
treat this would be far from the only
time strange things happened around SCP
343 SCP Containment cells are as secure
as they need to be but even the least
strict containment isn't known for its
Decor which is why Dr Beck was in for a
surprise the next time he paid visit to
SCP 343 the barebone cell now looked
like a comfortable home decorated in Old
English Fashions the scientists assumed
that SCP 343 had been making many more
trips out of his cell to get accessories
to feel more at home home but that
didn't explain all the changes to the
cell no one could explain how he had
installed the Roaring fireplace in the
containment cell and everyone who
entered could swear the cell looked many
times bigger than any other cell in the
facility SCP 343 wasn't just breaking
containment he now seemed to be breaking
the laws of physics in the facility the
rules of the SCP Containment facility
didn't seem to be a concern to SCP 343
but there was one thing he didn't seem
to want to do Escape after every sudden
exit he would always return to his
personal cell and treat it as his home
when interviewed by staff members he was
polite but vague and everyone seemed to
enjoy talking to him it was decided to
keep him on sight not attempt to
increase his security but restrict
access and keep his room guarded at all
times to ensure only researchers with
level three access and above were
allowed to meet with him but God works
in mysterious ways minimal Security Site
17 was one of the least restrictive SCP
Containment sites hosting anomalies that
could be safely contained and weren't
likely to mount violent escapes but as
in every SCP facility security was still
taken seriously and only those with
proper clearance could interact with the
subjects so why did SCP 343 seem
impossible to guard while only level
three clearance and above were allowed
in the guards assigned to protect the
entrance all seemed to fall down on the
job security officer James James who was
supposed to be keeping people out of SCP
343 cell had instead LED in multiple
visitors in addition to dropping in
several times himself when questioned on
why he had gone against orders and done
so he simply replied that 343 seemed
lonely and was so happy every time he
got company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do the security guard was
reassigned and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure but SCP 343's presence always
seemed to influence them anyway his
containment cell was a revolving door
with staff members at the facility
entering regularly for friendly
conversations Dr Beck decided it was
time to take matters into his own hands
he would meet with SCP
34311 and express how dangerous these
security breaches were he would try to
convince the mysterious being that he
needed to stop influencing the minds of
the guards watching him or the facility
would have to look into new measur
measures to contain him Dr back entered
the containment cell and had a long
conversation with SCP 343 and when he
emerged he had a big smile on his face
like he had just finished a reunion with
an old friend he gave the current guard
a friendly clap on the back and told him
not to worry so much about security
after all nothing bad was going to
happen from letting people at the
facility visit SCP 343 right he wasn't
dangerous in any way he also said that
security should bring him anything he
request so he would feel less need to
leave a cell minimal Security Site 17
soon became a model SCP facility with
morale being the highest of any sight
with most giving the credit to the
presence of SCP 343 employees generally
make daily visits to his chamber and he
seems to have an encyclopedic knowledge
of anything they want to talk about
including things he should have no way
of knowing guards no longer quit their
posts or break protocol as their only
real duty is to keep track of who meets
with SCP 343 so they can be interviewed
and debriefed after everyone's
conversation is different but they all
report being in a better mood after
leaving than when they came in no
further information is available on SCP
343's origins the full extent of his
powers or whether he is telling the
truth about being The God Who created
the universe the site director rubbed
his temples after hearing the
researcher's explanation so what you're
telling me is that we have an
uncontained highly powerful SCP that has
not only been breaking containment
whenever it wants but has managed to
destroy all the files regarding the
research on it the researchers answer
was yes however the situation at site 17
seemed to be stable and they had come up
with a plan that should help to maximize
the positive effect SCP 343 has on the
facility they were even hypothesizing
that staff from other sites and even
certain anomalies could be pacified by
343's presence the site director wasn't
impressed though he wanted the research
SE Archer to go back to the drawing
board and redo the research after all if
all the files were blank how could they
ever learn how to properly contain it
that's what the C and SCP stood for
after all containment the researcher
finally had a stand to the director
though and told them that it wasn't a
good idea that they had already tried
everything to contain SCP 343 but that
it wasn't that he broke containment it
was as if he didn't even acknowledge
that an attempt had been made to contain
him he was omnipotent aware of things he
shouldn't and able to do things that
broke the laws of physics without
breaking a sweat there was no evidence
that this was God the creator of the
universe as he claimed to be but there
also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn't the
researchers best guess was that this was
a powerful reality vendor whose
abilities knew no limits and that the
only reason he was staying in the
facility was because he wanted to and
doing anything to change that might
cause him to change his benevolent way
the director sighed as much as he hated
to admit it his researcher was making
good points he wanted to meet SCP 343
personally but did he need to know
anything first well sir the researcher
replied he likes hamburgers but beyond
that he'll take care of the rest he's
right there where we left him in his
home waiting for his next guest now for
a less friendly old guy in SCP custody
check out
scp-106 the old man escape and for
another ancient uncontainable being
watch SCP 3000
Anisha the SCP Foundation does their
best to live up to their famous namesake
they secure and contain anomalies and
monsters from all around the world or
sometimes even offworld and protect the
public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose however
despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under
lock and key there are sometimes
creatures so clever so devious and so
Det determined to escape their captivity
and wreck havoc on the world that even
the SCP Foundation struggles to keep
them from getting free one example is
SCP
035 or the possessive mask SCP 035 is
one of the most dangerous test subjects
in SCP Foundation custody and its mere
Presence at the foundation has resulted
in Untold damage death and destruction
it seems innocent enough to the
untrained eye The Mask which resembles a
classic white porcelain comedy mask
though it occasionally changes its
expression to tragedy has been in
existence since at least the
1800s in the late 19th century the
foundation discovered the mask in a
sealed cryp beneath an abandoned home in
Venice it is unknown how it got there or
how the foundation knew to look for it
if there was ever an explanation for its
Discovery it has long since been removed
or redacted from the foundation's
archives you're probably wondering how
can a simple mask leave multiple season
Foundation employees dead well like
everything at the SCP Foundation this
mask Is Not What It Seems there is a
reason its classification is ker a
designation that refers to an entity
that's excessively difficult to contain
and it couples this difficulty with a
pronounced hostility towards human life
and the ability to cause widespread
destruction in the event of a
Containment Breach these are the
qualities that the Poor Unfortunate
Souls assigned to guard SCP 035 would
come to understand all too well the
possessive mask is a parasitic entity
constantly seeking out a host willing to
put it on any human being in the mask's
proximity experiences a sudden
unexplainable urge to put it on and once
they do There's No Going Back SCP
Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask their
brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host brain function
has been eliminated the mask takes over
piloting their body and even speaking
through them however the mask can only
occupy a host for a small amount of time
before the body begins to Decay and
decompose eventually rotting away
completely leaving nothing but
desiccated Flesh and Bones where there
once was a person SCP 035 is capable of
possessing any humanoid being whether
that's an actual human being or a
lifeless humanoid shape despite all
their research the SCP Foundation
unknowingly gave the mask all the tools
and resources it needed to containment
and leave a trail of bodies in its wake
for a Time the mask was given host
privileges meaning that it was purposely
allowed to occupy a host in order to
speak with the scientist studying it in
order to avoid murky ethical issues the
host was usually something inanimate
like a mannequin or a statue these
conditions however unsettling allowed
the researchers to carry out interviews
with the Consciousness housed inside the
mask in the hope of beginning to
understand it and its motivations
however SCP 035 lost all access to its
host privileges after it almost pulled
off an unprecedented shocking and nearly
catastrophic escape attempt in its early
days at the facility when it was still
allowed host privileges it was contained
in a tripl locked room and monitored by
several research Personnel these were
experienced researchers who had been
with the foundation for a minimum of 5
years each an unusually long tenure in
such a dangerous and mentally corrosive
line of work these research staff
members were thought to be the most
capable of handling interactions with
the mask and be able to resist its
attempts at manipulation unfortunately
these assumptions were naive and
seriously underestimated the mask's
power research on the mask indicates
that the mask is incredibly intelligent
and a skilled manipulator it has a
photographic memory intelligence that
would rank it in the 99th percentile of
humans and the ability to incite
dramatic changes in the behavior and
people that it talks to one particularly
in famous interview between the entity
and an unnamed doctor at the foundation
suggested that the mask may even possess
telepathic abilities the mask was able
to give details about the doctor's life
that no one else was privy to including
knowledge of an affair that his wife was
having following the interview the
doctor suffered a psychotic break and
committed suicide just 24 hours later
the mask is able to use its Superior
intelligence charismatic personality and
mind reading abilities to get inside the
heads of those it speaks with it will
pull out and all psychological stops to
get What It Wants leaving Broken minds
and Spirits in its wake it was really
only a matter of time before it used
this skill set to its advantage and
attempted to escape its confinement the
day of the escape attempt was like any
other the research staff a team of three
intelligent experienced men checked into
the facility measured the conditions of
The Masks containment unit and began the
process of interviewing The Mask like
normal its motions were slow and looked
to require great great effort as its
current host was beginning to degrade
Beyond use the mask was attached to the
blank face of a mannequin and corrosive
black liquid could be seen oozing from
its eye and mouth holes this liquid is
excreted by the mask at a near constant
rate and it's thought to be at least
partially responsible for the
accelerated decay of the host bodies in
spite of the entity's unsettling
nightmarish appearance it was just
another day's work for the men assigned
to monitor SCP
035 and so they carried on with their
daily routine everything was going
according to plan until one of the men
Dr Jones began to behave erratically he
demanded that his fellow scientists
leave him alone with the mask for a
while and allow him to engage in a
private conversation with it it is
unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were
absent as the security footage captured
had no sound however several minutes
into the conversation and the footage
Doctor Jones can be seen dissolving into
a fit of Tears laying on the ground and
shaking with sobs as the m mask
dispassionately watches he then climbs
onto his knees begging the mask for
something before he Embraces it he holds
the mannequin in his arms for five
straight minutes weeping again before
they separate after this disturbing
emotional display Dr Jones brought the
other scientists back into the room with
him what happened next is still
uncertain but there are a few things
that we know for sure the other
scientists began to speak with the mask
in later interviews the other scientists
were bordering on incoherent babbling
about various traumas from their lives
one repeatedly referred to a drunk
driving accident where a dear friend was
killed and he was at fault another
simply cried out for his mother again
and again whatever the masks said to
them it was enough to completely destroy
their mental health after The two
scientists had been emotionally
devastated by The Mask Dr Jones
escalated the situation further Dr Jones
removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body and shocking everyone who
had later reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends at the command of the Mask which
was now speaking through Dr Jones the
other two men switched off all security
camera monitoring SCP 035 containment
facility The Mask piloting the body of
Dr Jones like a horrible fleshy puppet
made its way through the facility
avoiding detection until it reached the
exit doors where it was finally stopped
by a team of over a dozen security
guards knowing the dangers of touching
the mask all Foundation employees
involved in the recontainment of SCP 035
refused to remove it from Dr Jones face
instead he was placed in the lock room
with the mask still on left alone to be
observed over the security cameras until
his body had decomposed Beyond use his
body paced back and forth in the cell
for days flesh rotting and dropping away
only until senu and Bone remained only
when the bones began to turn black and
brittle crumbling apart into dust did
the body finally stopped moving his
family was notified the mask was
carefully removed from what was left of
his body and his remains were destroyed
the other two scientists involved in the
SCP 035 escape attempt were terminated
and their files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed Escape
attempts and the acknowledgement of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population SCP 035 lost its
host privileges altogether several
research staff protested this decision
insisting that there was more to be
learned from speaking with the entity
and citing valuable information that it
had given about other scps however the
risk was determined to considerably
outweigh the potential reward and the
request to reinstate 035 host privileges
were denied several staff members went
so far as to erupt into violent
outbursts on 035 behalf attacking their
supervisors who refused to provide the
mask with a new host clawing at them
with animalistic rage any staff members
that submitted a a request to reinstate
said privileges were considered a
security threat and reassigned to a
different SCP or in some cases
terminated any staff member who had
Direct contact with SCP 035 was also
terminated in order to avoid the risk of
any more staff Aid at Escape attempts
the mask is now kept in a hermetically
sealed glass case and there is a
psychologist on call to provide
assistance to anyone guarding it in case
of adverse effects on their mental
health from The Masks presence Personnel
that work around the mask even in its
current dormant State experience
frequent violent outbursts and a higher
rate of suicide even without a host the
mask corrosive effects have spread
across its containment facility the
walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from
The Mask which tests have revealed to be
highly contaminated human blood that
damages the structural Integrity of the
walls following prolonged contact this
blood has begun to form patterns on the
walls spelling out words and phrases in
Italian Latin Greek and Sanskrit as well
as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice and mutilation staff members
also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying high-pitch
laughter when in proximity to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and nose and an eventual psychotic
brain between the corrosive substance
appearing on the walls and the physical
and psychological damage to employees
SCP 035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible SCP 035 will be
moved into a new containment facility
and its previous cell will be isolated
from the rest of the foundation's
property and destroyed for the safety of
all involved we can only hope that the
new containment procedures are more
effective than the last ones and that
this mask never makes its way into the
world again if it does who knows how
many lives it will claim in the mean
time if you ever come across a strange
maskk and feel a nearly uncontrollable
urge to put it on ignore the whispered
please to just try it ignore the echoing
laughter and The Sensation of something
older and more powerful than you can
imagine rumaging through your deepest
darkest secret thoughts turn around and
run as fast as you can in the other
direction you'll be glad that you did
the SCP Foundation is no stranger to
Pure Evil whether it's a reptile that
wants to end all life a sadistic old man
with his own tortur Dimension or the
personification of death itself lurking
Beyond a limestone Cavern but what if
there was something even worse out there
the embodiment of chaos and cruelty
existing across multiple realities and
dimensions and what if it was coming for
us this is the Scarlet King believed by
many to be the ultimate evil behind much
of the trouble the foundation has faced
and some even speculate that fighting
him was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the Scarlet King he's known
by many names almost always including
some illusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power harak
karak the red sha the Crimson con pte
616 Mendes exmachina the Lahar Raja and
of course SCP 001 to name a few and like
many of the foundations mysterious
enemies stories about his true nature
and Origins abound and are often
contradictory according to the official
SCP 001 files of tto's proposal
symbology of the Scarlet King has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the King often depicted the
same way as a huge Red Demon figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating royalty he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities that the
SCP Foundation is familiar with are
believed to be somehow connected to the
Scarlet King including SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
05 Council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Monto if that name feels oddly familiar
to you it's because of its association
with one of the Scarlet King's most
recent attempts to enter our reality SCP
231 this SCP often referred to as the
brides of the Scarlet King was formed of
seven women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent
and a line of the king's devoted Cults
known as the children of the Scarlet
King each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
Horrors such as the infamous SCP 682 and
every time one of these Horrors were
birthed a catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the time Dr Monto was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly and as six catastrophes had
already OCC occurred pressure was
mounting to figure out a way to prevent
the final birth but as he was working on
the issue Dr Monto was struck with a
personal tragedy the mysterious
disappearance of his 14-year-old brother
Jacob in his fear and anger monok believ
that this must have something to do with
the Scarlet King and his disciples
wanting Revenge monok proposed an idea
so horrifying that the details were
never made public a procedure known as
110 Mont talk to be performed on the
final bride at regular intervals however
this wasn't the end of Dr monto's fra
relationship with the Scarlet King it
was just the beginning to give you some
perspective on just how dangerous the
Scarlet King is the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition decided to
put aside their differences and form a
joint effort to Stamp Out the children
of the Scarlet King they were successful
in this Mission and even managed to
capture the children's leader a
mysterious man named depesh spivac Dr
Monto who became the lead researcher on
231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Monto could never be the
impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though the suspicion
that the Scarlet king or the children
had something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still link lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders depes was extremely cryptic and
his answers to Dr Mon Talk's questioning
he' already heard of the doctor from the
reputation of the horrifying Monto
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had sto stolen sacred
text from the mystical Wanderers library
to assist in their summoning rituals
depes also revealed that the Scarlet
King is bound by Three Laws the law of
blood the law of concrete and the law of
howling Dr Monto confused and frustrated
by dep pes's secrecy had to learn more
he found an old Memoir from a former
member of the children of the Scarlet
King Jack hir who had the ability to
invade the minds of people from the past
and and experience what they experienced
he recounted a battle between the
Scarlet King and his followers and a
group of time-traveling turkmen Warriors
from SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective of the children of
the Scarlet King their lord ruled over
them from an immense Fortress embedded
in a volcano from the perspective of the
Turk men the children were starved and
beaten peasants commanded by the king's
voice in The Roaring howl of the Wind
Monto also found extensive records of
summoning rituals performed by various
Scarlet King aligned Cults interestingly
some of them Incorporated the use of
carved SCP Foundation symbols what could
this mean Monto returned again to depes
who finally gave him the truth about the
law of blood this is the law of the
Scarlet King it's defined by poverty
violence starvation hate and most of all
fear like the surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles to the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food Health Care knowledge
technology this is everything that the
Scarlet King despises but the mystery
only deepened as monok found files from
a former Foundation operative by the
name of agent D buis monok learned that
the Scarlet King didn't seem to appear
until after the foundation was created
and in fact it seemed that the greater
interest the foundation took in The
Scarlet King the more powerful he became
how could this be things were also
getting stranger on a personal level for
Dr Monto depes repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the mon talk procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
monto's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Den cartrite who said we must learn
what it is to die to be enslaved truly
brutally enslaved with no compassion or
compunction from our masters we must
learn what it is to be taken towards a
single purpose to know and truly
understand our lack of agency we must be
beholden to the words of gods in
darkness The Tempest cost Refuge of a
race of fools we must kill modernity
post modity with all its analysis and
sneering observation there is only one
rule the rule of chaos for Humanity for
life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Monto was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depes demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depes hated the foundation's belief that
science and rationality was the true
path to progress the king saw this as
little more than Petty arrogance the
reason monto's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is
unless our world and especially the
foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depesh told
him the answer no and in response Monto
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new New Revelations Monto
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
monok knew it wasn't enough he had seen
the truth and he couldn't unsee it well
the foundation was going on as normal
Mont grew to despise them he knew the
Scarlet King was coming he knew that he
couldn't be stopped and that our whole
reality was little more than sitting
ducks Dr Robert Monto is no longer a
researcher for the SCP Foundation no Dr
Robert Monto chose a different path he's
now a child of the Scarlet King a
devotee of Madness hate and Chaos you
can't beat this Scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat them join them there are some
things human beings aren't meant to know
and it's the sworn duty of the SCP
Foundation to discover and contain such
information but sometimes knowledge is
discover that shakes even the foundation
itself to its very core one such
Discovery occurred on April 28th 2016
that night SCP 2935 made itself known to
the foundation Personnel to this day the
exact nature of SC SCP 2935 is a mystery
that even the foundation's brightest
Minds can't completely understand
everything we know about SCP 2935 today
comes from three doomed missions to the
anomalous zones interior this is the
story of those Infamous Expeditions the
nightmare began around 5:00 a.m. when
SCP Foundation site 81 in Bloomingdale
Indiana intercepted a distorted radio
signal Communications Personnel at the
site traced this strange signal back to
the unincorporated area of japa India
indana near us Interstate 70 as his
foundation policy a team of field agents
were dispatched to the location in order
to determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned Cemetery the most recent death
on any of the Tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped Limestone Cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the Drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two mentions it was SCP
2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and your
national government one or more of our
sites is experiencing a communication
breakdown likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude all citizens
are ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
April 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
Source site 81 but not this site 81 the
SCP Foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 command to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the Potential
Threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 codenamed Manifest
Destiny to perform the first of three
Mann missions Into the Heart of the
anomalous Zone the first exploratory
Mission into SCP 2935 was code named
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates were agents kale Devon and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area position
position directly around the insertion
point meaning the other cave mouth of
SCP 2935 the mission only lasted about
an hour but what they saw in there would
stay with these men for the rest of
their lives after a 15-minute Trek
through the cave Manifest Destiny
arrived in the mirror Dimension where
they were struck by the Eerie Silence of
a place that seemed identical and yet so
different from their home Dimension the
first observation they made was the
total absence of all living vegetation
trees grass weeds everything it was all
dead on order from their superiors back
in the original Dimension that we'll
refer to from here on as Dimension Prime
Manifest Destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of SCP 2935 they
traveled 2 km without detecting a single
sign of plant or animal life not even
insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed
inside agent kale confirmed that there
was still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but They Came Upon a horri ining
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoil the team found an open
newspaper dated April 19th 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full 8 days before the discovery
in dimensioned Prime Decay would already
be very well underway by that point yet
here there wasn't even a smell instead
everything was just covered in a thin
layer of dust command requested that
Manifest Destiny collect samples of the
food as well as Hair Skin and fluids
from the corpses for further study small
electronics like smartphones were also
taken from the bodies agent Devon turned
on the television in the living room and
found that while most stations were now
running test signals the shopping
channel was still live well the feed was
live at least both hosts sat in front of
the cameras dead but perfectly preserved
the date on the screen read April 28th
2016 suggesting that the times of
Dimension Prime and mirror Dimension
were exactly the same in fact everything
seemed the same the only difference
between the two Dimensions being that
some kind of mysterious apocalyptic
event had occurred in the last 8 days in
SCP 2935 is mirror Dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when Manifest Destiny exited the
Farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of SCP 2935 but were
instructed to remain in the mirror
Dimension while additional units joined
them inside Manifest Destiny swelled to
16 members with the notable addition of
agent Roy as the new commanding field
officer the team split into two groups
of eight and agent Roy and his men
infiltrated the mirror Dimension site 81
while agent Juno's detached attempted to
access the base's off-site Deep storage
servers this second expedition was
codenamed Overland and led the
foundation's field agents even deeper
into the terrifying mystery of SCP
2935 accessing the site was easy for
Roy's Detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious Extinction event
in the distance fir still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just dropped out of the sky agent
Roy and his team like all SCP Foundation
Personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at Once In The Mirror Universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
Assumption was probably right going door
too in the administrative Wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension Prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
Universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complet complete and sudden
death on a cellular level and even the
bacteria that would typically take part
in the decomposition process had died
with it in SCP 2935 death was total and
absolute across all types of life forms
as agent Roy's team ventured further
into the bowels of site 81 they made
another unsettling Discovery their own
corpses in roughly the same spots they'd
been inside Dimension Prime site 81 8
days prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
brigh were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universe's
scps including SCP 2996 were dead in his
desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event agent
Roy revealed a terrifying secret to the
rest of his team SCP 682 The Immortal
misanthropic lizard and one of the
deadliest creatures known to the SCP
Foundation was contained at this very
facility right below them could it have
something to do with what was going on
here they descended into the containment
facility to discover an even more
unsettling truth SCP 682 the unkillable
anomaly floated dead in its tank death
truly made no exceptions within SCP 2935
agent Roy's team left the site and rev
vued with agent Juno's team to send
their research back to Dimension prime
using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another man operation codenamed 19 they
had no idea it would be their final
mission
as they descended deeper into the
facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3:00 a.m.
while underground in SCP 2935 site 81
the team accidentally activated the
base's on-site nuclear weapon a fail
safe meant to be detonated in the case
of an emergency Containment Breach due
to the base's fails safe protocols every
member of the Manifest Destiny team was
locked and sealed inside site 81 they
along with with everything else were
incinerated in the nuclear blast once
again the Mirror Universe inside of SCP
2935 was lifeless but that isn't where
it ends when the automated drones
returned out of the SCP 2935 cave to the
field operations in dimension Prime they
were in for their own horrifying
Discovery none of the footage or
information gathered from SCP 2935
illuminated how or why the extinction
event occurred everyone and everything
simply dropped dead at the exact same
moment nobody was aware nobody was
prepared death came suddenly and
silently and none were spared all the
foundation on Dimension Prime were left
with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent
Keller his final message was I don't
have any answers I don't think there are
any I'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us I'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site 81 it was a message from Keller
himself himself but not the Keller from
Universe Prime in this message Keller
described the foundation in the Mirror
Universe receiving the exact same
distorted transmission that they did a
few days earlier from a cave in japa
when he and the others were dispatched
inside they discovered the same lifeless
post- Extinction EV event world that was
now so familiar to the foundation
command but there was a key difference
this wasn't the mirror Dimension they'd
just been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror Dimension Keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror Dimension col believed this was
the Spectre of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself SCP 2935 was
the passageway through which absolute
death could pass from Dimension to
Dimension and our Dimension was the next
in line the deaths of manifest destiny
may have saved our entire universe as
anyone passing back through the cave had
the potential to bring death itself back
with them the foundation decided in the
end to follow Keller's viice they sealed
the entrance to SCP 2935 with concrete
and now kept it under constant watch
since what Waits behind the barrier is
an entity even they have no power to
stop if it ever got through after all it
had killed them all before or at least
another version of them what's one more
dimension on the pile why it may now
just seem like a simple slab of concrete
under an abandoned Cemetery this is why
SCP 2935 might be the most dangerous SCP
of all a month ago Dr Robert Maxwell was
a senior researcher working at the
facility but a tragic mistake had cost
the lives of several of his
co-researchers now he was being led down
a bleak hallway in armed biocontainment
Area 14 a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once- rising
researcher had a very different title
now D
8724 he had been made a d-class
Personnel a death
sentence however as the guards led him
to his possible demise he wasn't dressed
in the typical d-class orange jumpsuit
no he was dressed in frilly roko dining
wear more typical of 18th century France
if anything Dr Maxwell looked like he
was on his way to meet royalty and in a
sense he was the former researcher had
begged for any other assignment but the
site director insisted on committing Dr
Maxwell to tea time with SCP
082 he'd always been the talkative type
so the two would make a perfect pairing
and if the creature found him
sufficiently amusing then Maxwell might
even leave the containment cell alive he
had heard Legends of the giant creature
they called the cannibal Maxwell hoped
they were just stories Dr Maxwell was
pushed by the guards into a large
luxuriously appointed room and the doors
were locked behind him he felt like a
child surrounded by freakishly large
furniture and 10t high ceilings the fog
of obnoxious floral perfumes couldn't
fully cover up the pervasive smell of
death that lingered in the cavernous
Halls of 0 82's Palace thanks to an
elaborate ruse conducted by the
foundation SCP 082 believed he was the
King of France and that his containment
cell was a palace where he remained for
his own safety the creatures continued
good behavior and everyone else's safety
relied on visitors keeping up that lie
Maxwell had never worked in this area of
the facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
Superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive don't annoy him the down on this
Lux scientist gulped inside trying to
steady his nerves in this oversized fake
french Palace he just kept thinking
surely he can't be that big he almost
talked himself self into believing that
the accounts of the creature were just
that tall tales until a huge figure
began lumbering into the main chamber it
was him SCP 082 also known as Fernand
the cannibal SCP 082 was an 8ft tall
hulking monster built sturdier than the
castles it likes to imagine are its true
home swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 lb most of which is pure muscle
that's almost impossible to pierce with
conventional Weaponry SCP 082 stopped
just feet away and stared at Dr Maxwell
with its Beady sunken in eyes like a
hungry rat just the sight of it struck
Terror into Dr Maxwell's heart but he
didn't dare show his fear instead he
remembered his brief training bowing
politely and forcing a smile referring
to the creature as your highness and
profusely thanking it for granting him
an audience the monster continued
staring without saying anything and then
gave a wide lock jawed grin showing off
its huge teeth it did everything through
gritted teeth except eat and sing Dr
Maxwell hoped he wouldn't be a part of
either activity Fernand gave a low
booming chuckle he thanked Dr Maxwell
for coming to give him some company and
invited him to come further inside and
take a seat adding with a slly wing that
he won't bite the monster complained
that he so rarely gets visitors to the
Palace these days but he omitted the
fact that the main reason for this was
his tendency to devour them Maxwell
nodded and followed the giant deeper
into its oversized Abode he couldn't
help but notice that the monster's arms
looked like huge fleshy punching bags he
knew that if ferand wanted to he could
easily crush him flat just like he done
to so many unfortunate guards during
containment breaches ferand told Dr
Maxwell that he was thinking of having
some decorating work done the walls of
his Palace were starting to look awfully
draa and he gestured to one covered with
a rusty red streak Maxwell remembered
that declass cleaners were sent into the
containment cell twice a month to tidy
any of ferdinand's messes but they often
ended up becoming one of the messes
themselves the creature encouraged
Maxwell to take a seat at his oversized
dining table while he tended to a pot of
what he said was full of delicious onion
soup Maxwell obliged his host request
West and took a seat at a huge chair
that made him look like a six-year-old
sitting at the grown-ups table meanwhile
Ferdinand was using a huge machete like
knife to cleave onions in half for his
bubbling pot of stew even though
Ferdinand had shown no signs of outward
aggression as he watched the cannibal
hack away at onions with his enormous
knife Maxwell could feel himself
beginning to sweat after all they didn't
call this creature the cannibal for
nothing this was a monster with a truly
horrifying bodyc
during previous containment breaches it
had taken enough tranquilizer to put
down two elephants to subdue the
creature but not before multiple agents
quite literally lost their heads in the
process ferin was able to bite them off
with one huge Chomp like he was eating a
drumstick snapping right through the
bone with his incredible tooth and jaw
strength surprisingly when he wasn't on
a violent Rampage Foundation researchers
had found SCP 082 to be unusually polite
and forthcoming offer bring the
researchers plenty of information about
himself and his past the only problem
was that almost everything the creature
said was a complete lie from his time as
a researcher Maxwell knew that there
were only a few details about the
creature that could be ascertained for
certain SCP 082 would reliably answer to
the name Ferdinand and genetically
Ferdinand was technically human the
means by which Ferdinand became so
grotesquely huge strong and
cannibalistic are still unknown
Foundation Personnel are still looking
into whether it's due to some kind of
anomalous genetic mutation or by more
Supernatural means all we know is that
he's big unpredictable and extremely
dangerous Dr Robert Maxwell sat
terrified at the dining table of SCP 082
listening to fernand's slightly dull
blade chopped through the final onion
which he then tossed into the boiling
soup ferin had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters Hannibal Lecter of
course Hannibal the cannibal isn't quite
so fictional to feram while he's been
shown to be extremely intelligent in
terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding of the
distinctions between fiction and reality
he assumes all movies and TV shows are a
form of documentary or reality
television and ever since seeing the
Silence of the Lambs Ferdinand has been
eager to meet with Dr Lecter which he
emphasized to Maxwell over and over
since trying to explain the concept of
fiction to Ferdinand had never
previously worked Maxwell simply told
him that Dr Lecter is extremely busy at
the moment but will visit whenever he
gets a chance this seemed to satisfy
ferand who placed two large bowls of
steaming soup on the table before
sitting down a little too close to
Maxwell he couldn't help but notice that
the giant cannibal was now sitting
within biting distance and as a lowly
declass nobody would be rushing in to
save him if things went South ferand
began ranting through his clenched teeth
once more occasionally stopping to
consume a hefty spoonful of onion soup
Maxwell was sure to do the same not
wanting to seem anything less than
polite but soon the tenor of ferdinand's
rant began to shift typically the
monster spoke French or heavily accented
English now he was affecting the accent
of a Victorian gentleman peppering his
speech with t ho and the game is a foot
Maxwell was confused at first but
quickly realized iiz the game ferand was
playing it's well known that ferand is a
pathological liar who likes to play
numerous characters changing his
mannerisms and clothes accordingly these
personas have included a vampire Big
Bird Andre the Giant Foundation
researcher Dr brigh The Incredible Hulk
Alexander the Great Captain Hook Dr
Frankenstein and Frankenstein's monster
and of course in this case the iconic
fictional Detective Sherlock Holmes
fearing for his life in this strange
situation Dr Maxwell did the only thing
he could play along as ferand reeled off
his homesan delusions Maxwell began to
play the role of Dr John Watson asking
follow-up questions and complimenting
ferdinand's impeccable deductive
reasoning and it seemed to be working
Ferdinand played along too acting as
though the two of them really were
Arthur Conan Doyle's crime fighting Duo
towards the end of their game Dr Maxwell
was even starting to enjoy it
amazed that his quick thinking was
actually keeping him safe but just then
the cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with Dr Maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not he saw the creatures
gargantuan teeth separating its huge
Jaws stretching open this could surely
only mean one thing Dr Maxwell winced
and prepared for death cursing that all
of his quick thinking had amounted to
nothing Fernand towards him his gaping
ma with its hot onion scented breath
just inches away from Maxwell and then
he began to sing the cannibal broke into
a rockus Victorian Pub song happy and
jovial in his moment of Terror Dr
Maxwell had forgotten that this was the
other reason SCP 082 opens his
nightmarish Jaws relief washed over him
as he knew he was safe at least for the
moment not long after Foundation guards
arrived and escorted him from the cell
leaving the delusional giant to his own
devices back in the so-called Palace the
former researcher had done it he had
bested Ferdinand the cannibal and
hopefully it would be the last time he'd
ever be face to face with that derange
giant unfortunately for Dr Robert
Maxwell in a performance review later
that week one of his superiors remarked
that ferand enjoyed his company and he
had done a great job such a good job in
fact that Ferdinand insisted Ed he have
Dr Maxwell for dinner or any other meal
for that matter sometime very soon the
first thing that tipped the foundation
off to SCP 87's presence were the
reports of numerous unexplained
disappearances on campus there were
plenty of rumors about what might be
behind them but field agents suspected
that the true source of the vanishing
would be something Beyond civilian
imagination all anyone knew for sure was
that everyone who had gone missing was
last seen in the certain Administrative
Building on the University grounds and
that the disappearances only seemed to
happen when the elevator was out the
campus was soon flooded with Foundation
agents creating a barrier around the
administrative building and the presumed
habitat of SCP 087 nobody else could get
in and hopefully whatever was inside
couldn't get out one of the foundation's
lead scientists was flown into to
consult on the investigation what could
have been behind those students
disappearing the doctor's preliminary
interviews with University staff who
worked in the building yielded some
interesting details strange noises like
banging and even a faint shrill crying
would be heard from a door that led to a
no longer used stairway in hallway 3B
staff in the building had no reason to
ever take these stairs especially
considering how many of them reported a
strange sense of unease when just
standing outside the door the only
reason someone might take those stairs
is due to elevator
malfunctions in that instant the doctor
had put put it all together the staff
they interviewed had their memory wiped
with amnestics special chemicals used by
the foundation with the power to delete
human Memories the foundation only used
them for staff for civilians who had
confirmed contact with an SCP and the
doctor knew that they had a live one on
their hands the staircase there was
something terribly wrong with that
staircase and it was the SCP
foundation's job to find out what before
it made anybody else disappear this is
the story of SCP 87 otherwise known as
the endless staircase and the three
doomed Journeys down into its murky
depths the doctor was more than eager to
begin Research into the staircase and
its frightening anomalous properties
after all you don't claw your way up to
being one of the foundation's key
researchers without being brave and
perhaps just a little bit deranged as
was standard once a perimeter was
secured around the staircase the good
doctor requested a selection of d-class
personnel for testing for those those
not in the know d-class is the
foundation's polite way of saying Canon
fodder the doctor was sent three d-class
prisoners for use in his investigation
of SCP
087 the first d84 32 was according to
official documentation on the incident a
43-year-old male of average build and
appearance and unremarkable
psychological background this man once
worked for the foundation in a more
official capacity but he was given the
often deadly demotion to declass due to
a dangerous mistake handling SCP 682
that led to the deaths of several other
agents now it looked like it would be
his turn the doctor explained his
mission to him explore the staircase
gather data help us find out exactly
what we're dealing with here if you come
back alive there may even be a promotion
in it for you and with that promise
d-8432 was given his load out a 75 wat
flood lamp with battery power capable of
lasting 24 hours an audio headset and a
handheld camcorder fitted with a
transmission strain and an audio headset
that would allow him to communicate with
Dr Bryant d84 32 was then pushed through
the door in hallway 3B and out onto the
staircase according to Declassified
Foundation files describing the
staircase SCP 087 is an unlit platform
staircase stairs descend on a 38° angle
for 13 steps before reaching a
semicircular platform of approximately 3
m in diameter descent Direction rotates
180° at each platform the design of SCP
087 limits subjects to a visual range of
approximately 1.5 flights but in d-8432
mind unlit really didn't seem like the
right word he would have chosen all
consuming Darkness despite carrying a
powerful 75 wat lamp d84 32 was only
capable of partially lighting the
platform he was standing on and the
illumination only stretched down nine of
the 13 steps to the next platform when
d8 432 observed how little help his lamp
was giving him he was instructed to
shine it out of the doorway into hallway
3B when he did so the light seemed to
shine far further than it ever could in
SCP
087 already the beginning of the
anomalous activity was obvious
everywhere else darkness is just the
absence of light in SCP 087 Darkness
eats light it was like a tangible black
mass that only a certain amount of light
could survive while the rest just
wouldn't show d-8432 SW bed hard over a
lump in his throat the door to hallway
3B was closed behind him and he was
ordered to descend surviving to see that
promotion was feeling unlikely but it's
not like he had a choice if he tried to
escape SCP 087 before he was permitted
he'd be shot by SCP Foundation field
agents on the spot so he followed the
high-ranking doctor's orders and began
to descend the steps to the next
platform nothing about the physical
makeup of the staircase itself seemed
abnormal the base and walls were a very
plain dull concrete with a metal
handrail the only thing that seemed
unique about it so far was The Strange
Life bending properties and was until he
reached the second platform down and he
heard it a soft echoing cry a child's
cry it was shrieks of Panic or maybe
even pain echoing Up From Below he was
asked why he had stopped and he
explained the crying sound he'd been
hearing it sounded like he was coming
from far down the stairs maybe 200 M
below him he could just make out the
words please heal and down here coming
from the darkness but the team outside
the stairwell couldn't hear anything so
they asked him to descend further
another platform down and they could
hear it too the unmistakable cries of a
terrified child please help and down
here d-8432 was ordered to keep going
and only stop if he noticed changes to
the visual environment or in the sounds
he was hearing d-8432 knowing his life
was on the line had to keep going and
descended another 20 flights of stairs
before stopping to remark that the
sounds of the child hadn't gotten any
closer they still sounded just as far
away as when he'd first heard them he
was told his observations were noted and
pressured to continue within half an
hour d-8432 had descended a full 50
floors with no sign of a bottom in sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout as if
it was moving away from d432 at the same
rate he was descending at this point
d-8432 reported that he was feeling
uneasy the doctor said that this was
understandable given the circumstances
he'd been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire
time and something about the truly
bottomless nature of the staircase and
the ever elusive crying was undeniably
eerie but things were about to really
take a turn for the worst as d-8432
stepped forward towards the next set of
stairs he froze there was something on
the platform below him barely
illuminated by the light of his 75 wat
Bol it was a face vaguely human in size
and shape but with a few terrifying
differences it had grayish skin and no
mouth nostrils or pupils and yet d432
could feel that this thing was making
eye contact with him he couldn't move
trapped in the thing's piercing gaze in
an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d432 face eyes staring into its own d432
screamed and ran scaling all 50 flights
in an astonishing 18 minutes before
charging out into hallway 3B there he
collapsed from the exhaustion and the
fear of what he just seen upon reviewing
the footage the strange face was
designated SCP 087 D1 fascinating it was
time for a second experiment the doctor
just had to know more the second test
subject was
d935 a 28-year-old male with a history
of aggravated assaults against women he
was given the same load out as his
predecessors except this time with an
even more powerful 100 watt bulb he was
also given 100 small LED lights that had
adhesive backs and a battery life of
approximately 3 weeks with which they
intended to permanently illuminate as CP
087 however despite the extra wattage of
his bulb he still couldn't illuminate
beyond the ninth step SC SCP 087
wouldn't allow it having no ideas of the
horrors that lurk below him he descended
on the doctor's orders and began fixing
the LEDs to the walls of each platform
he passed the LED always illuminated The
Landing but the light couldn't pass the
first step on either side the flights of
stairs themselves would remain in
Perpetual Darkness after the second
flight d935 noticed the same crying D
8432 had heard and became uneasy just
like before as d935 descended the volume
of the crying didn't seem to increase as
if for every step he descended the
source of the crime descended one two
keeping them at a constant 200 M apart
still He was ordered to continue his
descent and the placing of LEDs even as
his paranoia grew when he reached the
51st floor he observed damage to the
wall and steps sections appear to have
been smashed to Rubble by an extreme
force as he descended past the broken
step he only felt his fear anxiety and
paranoia grow the doctor made note of
the fact that SCP 087 seemed to cause
instances of anxiety and Terror in its
occupants even before they encountered
SCP
87-1 as d935 reached platform 89 a full
350 M under the initial platform he
stopped dead in his tracks and saw
something staring up at him from the
platform below that same terrible gray
face with those dead white eyes he was
encouraged to stay calm and try to get
better footage of the face but it
charged for him and d935 ran for his
life he ascended the staircase at a
staggering Pace even passing out from
exhaustion and remaining motionless for
14 minutes halfway when d935 finally
gathered the strength to get up he
scrambled back to hallway 3B and fell
into a state of Catatonia he remains
unresponsive to all external stimuli to
this day just staring off into the
distance with a haunted expression
almost like he's still there in the
hallway the doctor wanted to conduct one
more test before he ordered SCP 087 shut
off from the world forever and it was
the most terrifying of all the final
subject was D
9884 a 23-year-old woman with a history
of depression and use of excessive force
the doctor had hoped that d98 A4 would
travel the deepest yet and so he gave
her the additional supplies of a
backpack containing 3.75 L of water 15
nutrient bars and one thermal blanket as
far as the foundation was concerned she
was in this for the Long Haul but none
of them had any idea quite how right
they were when D 9884 entered SCP 087
all the lights from the previous
Expedition had disappeared still she was
ordered to go deeper she heard the
crying of the mysterious child if it was
even a child at all and again she was
ordered to go deeper at the 496th
Landing even as Dean 9884 seemed to slip
into a state of mortal Terror once again
she was ordered to go even deeper every
moment he was hoping to get a better
look at the face of SCP
87-1 and when Dean 9884 finally broke
and fled back upstairs he did the face
appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her staring directly into
the camera with its blank eyes startling
even this veteran of the supernatural
the face appearing caused Dean 9884 to
panic and flee but instead of going back
up the stairs to safety she went deeper
down the staircase in an attempt to
escape it deeper and deeper and deeper
until her video feed cut out d98 A4 was
never seen again in the aftermath of the
tests the SCP was classified as uclid it
may have been dangerous but at least it
was easy to contain the door to hallway
3B was replaced with one made out of
reinforced steel with an electro release
lock mechanism it has been disguised to
resemble a janitorial closet consistent
with the rest of the building the lock
won't release unless a classified number
of electrical volts are applied while
the key is turned counterclockwise and
after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the
door staff at the building never again
reported hearing strange noises as for
the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of
SCP 087 we may never know but one can
only assume it isn't Pleasant a tangled
mass of yarn and ribbon sounds more like
what you'd find in the back room of a
craft store or a forgotten closet than a
mysterious creature worthy of
investigation and yet that's exactly
what SCP 066 appeared to be or at least
it did at first glance but the SCP
Foundation doesn't contain and study
just anything and there was and still is
something incredibly strange just below
the surface of SCP 066 also known as
Eric's toy at first Eric's toy seemed to
be completely harmless and even helpful
a knot of string that produced strange
but harmless items and effects but the
foundation soon discovered a dark side
to SCP
066 while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing SCP 066
weighs only about 1 kg and appears to be
a braided bunch of yarn and ribbon
though there is no apparent musical
capability within the strands of yarn
and ribbon themselves music can be
produced by moving individual strands
one at a time when it was first being
studied this SCP was composed of
multicolored strings and ribbons but it
has since undergone a transformation and
now presents an appearance somewhat
different from its initial description
the strands of yarn and ribbon can be
used to play the notes of a dionic scale
c d e f g a b though the research has
not been able to determine just how SCP
066 produces music or any sound at all
SCP 066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066 D2 its classification was
adjusted to a subcategory of uid uclid
impetus uid is a classification given to
scps that are more difficult to contain
than those classified as safe impetus in
Latin means attack and specifies that
SCP 066 is not only uclid class but on
the more aggressive side while 066 is
not always aggressive towards humans the
events of incident 0662 proved that it
is highly unpredictable and should not
be provoked like many scps it proved
that underestimating its capabilities
can be a dangerous mistake before the
incident SCP 066 displayed only Charming
if unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strengths
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility and went about
their work with a light-hearted Carefree
Spirit after playing an improvised 6 not
Melody with the strands a researcher was
thrilled to find that SCP 066 was
capable of shape-shifting its appearance
changed to resemble a small calico
kitten for 17 minutes the kitten was
incredibly friendly rubbing its head
against the researcher's glove hand and
purring loudly ironically enough the
kitten also spent time playing with a
piece of string after the 17 minutes
were up the kitten transformed back into
SCP 0 66's original form a few days
later another researcher played a
different Melody on the Str Str and was
surprised to find that when they stopped
the music continued on its own the sound
of an acoustic guitar kicked in
accompanied by vocals with no visible
source for either sound the SCP then
played a 4-minute song with lyrics
warning against the use of sharp objects
without the supervision of a parent
especially scissors after the song ended
the SCP was silent for the rest of the
day the following week a research
assistant used the strands of SCP 066 to
play the opening notes of happy birthday
and a chocolate cupcake with a lit
birthday candle appeared from within the
braided strings against the warning of
his peers the assistant ate the cupcake
in response the SCP played the rest of
happy birthday and the assistant
suffered no adverse effects from the
cupcake all of this fun was brought to a
swift end when one scientist suggested
that a portion of SCP 066 is yarn body
be cut off and removed so that the
specimen could be tested on April 18th
2008 the event that would become known
as incident 0 66-2 took place a Young
Man known only as d 066 d443 7 or D was
assigned to the task naturally he was a
member of the highly disposable d-class
Personnel but D was grateful for the
opportunity as most experiments of a
similar nature involved quite a bit more
obvious risk it was a simple enough job
take a pair of scissors snip off some
yarn and bring it back to the lab for
further study it was hardly on the level
of supervising 173 or being 682s latest
chew toy he entered the containment room
where SCP 066 was lying dormant in still
and approached it with scissors he
grabbed a small handful of string and
started to cut as soon as the scissors
began to cut through the fabric the SCP
rolled out of his grasp it came to a
stop 1 M away where it started to make a
high-pitch squeaking sound resembling
The Cry of a frightened rabbit unsure
what to do and unprepared for this
scenario de approached the entity again
he snagged another Fistful of yarn and
cut only for 066 to curl into a ball and
roll away from him again even faster
this time once it was safely on the
other side of the room and away from the
scissors it stopped moving only this
time it didn't squeak instead for the
very first time since its containment it
spoke in a deep uncannily human voice
and asked are you Eric after recovering
from his initial shock at hearing a
voice come out of a massive string D
responded no I'm not this answerers said
something off in SCP 066 and its form
began to shift and change the string
wriggled around on the floor unbraiding
and wrapping around itself into a mound
the colors previously a rainbow of
Shades shifted until every strand was a
blood red much to de's horror the
transformation was not yet complete
small bumps began to emerge from the
spaces between the strands of yarn
popping out all over the bright red Mass
if that wasn't terrifying enough
suddenly all together as one they
blinked open revealing themselves to be
over a dozen small eyes every single eye
was focused at D studying him staring
him down SCP 066 then began to produce
loud abrupt dissonant notes like someone
banging on the keys of a piano D had
seen enough he abandoned his task and
fled the containment room after this
failed attempt to extract a sample SCP
066 is behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began
to change dramatically before the
incident the SC P was largely dormant
only becoming active if a melody was
played using its strands following the
incident and its change of form 066
began to move on its own long strands of
its yarn body would move like tentacles
writhing and wriggling around at high
speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's Behavior the SCP would begin to
react with sound and effect within 6
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with d as she
approached 066 to take notes about its
current state and its new ability to
move a be appeared out of nowhere it
stung the assistant and flew away before
it could be captured Weeks Later a team
of 11 personnel were monitoring the SCP
when it suddenly burst into a rendition
of Beethoven's Second Symphony It
produced this music at a volume of over
140 DB permanently deafening three of
the personnel and causing permanent
hearing damage in the other a it was
theorized that the SCP did this as an
act of Retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these Personnel refused to
work with SCP 066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor The Entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete compl loss of visibility
the lights were unable to be turned on
for 5 hours and any attempt at an
alternate light source such as a
flashlight was unsuccessful it was as if
the darkness in the room swallowed any
and all light right up it was similar to
the oppressive Darkness within SCP 087
or the unlimited black of SCP 31's
Shadow Dimension the Personnel in the
room later reported hearing the sound of
loud labor breathing just behind their
shoulders though when they searched for
a source of the sound they could find
nothing there had been no recent
anomalies reported or any additional
hostile Behavior instead whenever it
sees a new human SCP 066 repeats the
name Eric again and again in the same
deep voice who is Eric no one at the
facility knows or if they do they have
not reported it to any official channels
it is possible that the SCP was once
owned by someone named Eric and perhaps
given the circumstances under which SCP
066 first said the name Eric attempted
to cut the threads of the entity while
it was in his care unfortunately there
are no official records of how SCP 066
was discovered or why it was brought to
the foundation in the first place its
Origins remain murky and as mysterious
as everything else about it all that is
known is that whoever Eric is SCP 066 is
determined to find him once the scp's
class was changed from safe to uid its
containment procedures had to be
adjusted while it was previously kept in
a simple room it is now contained in a
Tungsten carbine box at its sight's high
value item storage facility once a month
the box is inspected for damage to its
interior due to the scp's tendency to
use its appendages to wear Down the
Walls of the box over time if there is
any damage SCP 066 is to be moved to a
new box using a robotic arm that
performs this transfer in less than 3
seconds the foundation has attempted to
place recording devices in the box with
the entity in order to monitor Its
Behavior when there are no humans
present but the SCP destroys every
recording device placed inside of its
containment box and any attempts to
record Its Behavior when it is not being
observed by humans have been
unsuccessful whatever it's doing when
there is no one around it wants to keep
a secret on the surface SCP 066 is one
of the less frightening finds contained
within the walls of the SCP Foundation
it does not have claws or teeth or the
ability to cause Mass deaths but it has
incredible unpredictable capabilities
and seems very capable of holding a
grudge there is so much that is unknown
about it from its Origins to its form to
its ability to manifest matter from
nothing and there is something deeply
unsettling about this scp's
unpredictable behavior and increased
hostility towards being observed we do
not know what it has done and we do not
know what it will do next all we can do
is Wonder as we Ponder the nature of SCP
066 it does nothing but sit staring with
unblinking eyes waiting for Eric to come
back an SCP Foundation researcher sits
at a table inside of a standard
containment cell these are often
dangerous places to be especially when
the SCP you're supposed to be studying
is one that you can't see the researcher
is taking notes unsure of exactly what
is going to happen next he can hear the
sounds of knives scraping behind of
Flesh sizzling and Searing from high
heat he braces himself as a burst of
heat hits the back of his head as if a
fireball has erupted an object floats
through the air and settles in front of
him on the table it's a plate of food
and it looks delicious it may surprise
you to learn that there is no rule that
the SCP Foundation must deal exclusively
with violent and vicious creatures not
every SCP held in containment shares the
same malevolence and contempt for
Humanity as SCP
682 or the world-ending threat posed by
the likes of SCP 2317 some perhaps not
many but some are benign and might even
seem outwardly friendly but you'd still
be taking a huge risk to assume that
anything contained by the SCP Foundation
is completely harmless such is the case
with SCP 531 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this quasi
humanoid meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features is held in an
airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation Personnel on a bi-weekly
basis
SCP 5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with SCP 5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need food it does still hunt and
consume anything at encounters human or
otherwise avoiding being eaten is hard
enough with creatures that can actually
be seen But like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained SCP 55031
has developed an almost perfect defense
mechanism which is when observed it will
literally cease to exist some might
choose to refer to this as a Quantum
lock however it is worth noting that
traces left by SCP 5031 still remain
observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by SCP 5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does
not naturally this makes both avoiding
the creature and capturing it using
cameras is difficult however when SCP
531s existence ceases it still casts a
shadow from this researchers have been
able to determine several of the
creatures physical traits based on its
silhouette it has been deduced that SCP
5031 levitates about half a meter above
ground level Sports an abnormally small
necklace head a top and elongated torso
approximately 1.9 M long with three sets
of spinley lower arms that Branch out
outwards using these arms and its
Loosely hanging body SCP 531 will lower
itself to hunt any human or animal that
draws near to it and uses the bladel
likee tail to cut up
food perhaps the most interesting facet
of SCP 531 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
huxel appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kept in huxel
took over the role of HCL supervisor for
SCP 5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit huxel
devised a series of tests to introduce
SCP 531 to various different stimuli as
a way to better understand the creature
and hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering it's worth remembering that
the SCP Foundation makes its mission to
be cold not cruel in performing
performing their duties to protect
normality and many of the researchers
and staff are just as capable of having
empathy for creatures as you might for a
stray animal at a shelter the first of
hux's tests involved installing speakers
in SCP 5031 cell through which a variety
of different ambient and popular pieces
of music were played to see if they had
any effect on reducing the creature's
stress by judging SCP 5031 stress levels
based on how much it screamed when
compared to normal huxel was able to
determine how to best use music to calm
the creature SCP 531 seemed to convey
higher levels of stress when listening
to morning Forest deep Grotto and
seaside Paradise Ambience as well as the
best of late 60s British rock band Jeth
rotol however the best of Mozart Ena
kiss and Ben Folds produced dramatically
different results decreasing SCP 531s
apparent stress following this test
senior researcher huxel compiled a
playlist featuring SCP 53 1's favorite
music over time the stress reducing
effects of Music on SCP 5031 seemed to
decrease but keeping the playlist on
shuffles seemed to keep the creature
consistently calmer than it had been
previously the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into SCP
50 31's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected when a softball was thrown into
the enclosure SCP 5031 immediately
sliced the ball in two with its tail and
one SW sft motion a similar result
occurred when researchers threw the
creature a basketball which was quickly
punctured and sliced open by SCP 5031
tail its stress levels first seemed to
diminish when the creature was offered a
bowling ball which it rolled around the
enclosure and then later knocked it
against a second bowling ball however
when one of the balls chipped rendering
it unable to roll properly SCP 531
stress increased dramatically until a
replacement was offered researcher hu to
noted that SCP 5031 seemed to possess a
similar level of motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to
match next when given the choice between
two food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure SCP 531 seemed to gravitate
towards higher quality food most notably
favored cooked rotisserie chickens over
animal carcasses it even chose this
option over a live chicken using its
tail to cut its food into more
manageable bite-sized portions rather
than ripping its meat with its hands or
teeth like many of its fellow
scps researcher huxel recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though SCP 55031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive providing the creature
with food of a better quality marginally
reduced its
stress senior researcher huxel next
attempted to test SCP 531 coexistence
with other living
subjects each time making sure that the
creature had been adequately fed to
avoid any unseemly
incidents first a live chicken was
introduced SCP 55031 rolled its bowling
ball at high speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken's
stress levels and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the
process when a second chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 gently rolled a
basketball towards it but ceased any
further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball next
to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded d-class staff member
who was instructed to sit down and roll
the basketball towards SCP 5031 after
doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to Cease the creatures
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxel had another class D engage in a
game of catch with SCP 5031 while facing
away from the
creature this test proceeded
successfully and Senior researcher huxel
remarked how SCP 50 31's motor skills
were improving albeit gradually and with
some gentle encouragement through hux's
tests the creature was learning the next
test focused on teaching SCP 55031
linguistic symbols utilized LCD displays
and buttons connected to a food
dispenser One display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing SCP 531 was quickly able to
understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense
a rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional Rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image SCP 531 was able to
determine which station dispensed
chicken through a process of elimination
whenever the functions and displays were
swapped SCP 55031 would find whichever
displayed the word chicken to receive
its food the Final Phase of this test
presented SCP 55031 with a single
station displaying the word chicken but
with a button that would remain inactive
unless the creature spelled out the same
word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed SCP 5031 was able to
assemble the word correctly not only
activating the button and dispensing
food but proving to researcher huxel
that the creature was capable of
learning language huxel continued to
test the creature encouraging it to
spell words using lettered blocks as a
method of communicating by increasing
SCP 531s vocabulary and the amount of
human interaction it received senior
researcher huxel observed that SCP 531
was gradually learning to sing albeit
non-verbally as well as to juggle with
its six hands and was even communicating
its food preferences and Dish parent
ings later another class D D 52125 was
introduced to SCP 531s enclosure to Aid
in further testing through d521 125s
instructions the creature quickly
learned to draw using crayons and
created artworks depicting itself its
Newfound friend D
52125 researcher Huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie
chicken SCP 50 31's new creative side
didn't stop there though as the creature
quickly learned to play chopsticks in
only 2 days once a piano was introduced
into the enclosure SCP 5031 even managed
to start creating its own original
admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature's cell and
d521 125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be SCP 531s new favorite
hobby as it spent the next 3 days
experimenting with different
combinations of foods and spices using
its letter blocks to request more more
more garlic powder interestingly the
creature only created artwork or music
when D 52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone following this
development senior researcher hustable
devised a new test for SCP 531 providing
the creature with cooking utensils and
using D 52125 to demonstrate 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of
different dishes from hamburgers and
tacos to Mongolian beef steak clam
chowder and peritols in addition to a
small peanut allergy this eighth test
revealed SCP 55031 to be a phenomenal
Chef possessing culinary skills far
beyond the average person the creature
quickly and enthusiastically embraced
its new found talents concocting its
very own brand new recipes with d 52125
even volunteering to be the first to
taste test 5031 dishes it was shortly
after this test that SCP 5031 spoke its
very first word and it should come as no
surprise that the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxel was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development the final
test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for over the course of
2 months SCP 55031 was tasked with
creating a full 3our meal which would
then be served to Foundation staff for
Thanksgiving SCP 55031 not only Rose to
the task but exceeded all of researcher
huxtable's expectations creating a meal
that even Gordon Ramsay would be hard
pressed to find fault with the creature
created a first course consisting of
sweet potato miso soup seasoned with
turmeric next came a beautiful duck coni
blazed luxuriously with apple cider and
topped generously with sweet cranberry
compost paired with a sight of butternut
squash noi and served on a bed of kalees
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the Exquisite meal was a
cassava pie for dessert complimented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream
and a maple hazelnut syrup an SCP 5031
didn't stop there the creature also
debuted one of its original musical
compositions to complement the decadent
meal it had created as the staff enjoyed
the food SCP 5031 performed live from
its enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher h hble but
the entire Foundation staff as a fitting
end to the creature's taale Huxtable
reported that during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created SCP 5031 stress
levels reduced
entirely new Kinder containment measures
that would keep 5031 safer but also far
more contented were submitted for
approval perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that SCP 531 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world instead SCP 5031 is a gentle if a
little frightening at first creature
that just requires careful and
considered guidance instead of a cold
iron cage and round-the-clock arm guards
through testing senior researchers
Stanley huxel and his fellow Foundation
staff were not only able to help the
creature develop but also found what
makes it tick and not just for the
purposes of containing it instead it is
hoped that cp5 31's creativity and flare
for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow under
the proud watch of researcher huxel over
50 men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers
construction workers accountants this
was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler the center of
this makeshift place of worship was once
a normal school gymnasium but it's now
the home of a huge statue a humanoid
being wreathed in tentacles its head is
more like a squid or cuttlefish than
anything resembling an actual human face
while he's known to the cultist as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as SCP
2662 and he sits in the belly of one of
their expansive containment facilities
locked away from the world but not for
long if his devoted followers have
anything to say about it this is their
God all powerful and unchanging and when
it comes to springing him from
containment no tactic is too vile or
underhanded to get the job done their
mortal leader and high priest a man in a
purple robe calling himself brother
Marsh walks among their crouched forms
he whispers instructions for the great
day of Liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making and one that
if it goes off without a hitch could
free their monstrous God into the world
they would strike at the very heart of
their enemy the SCP Foundation when they
least expect it and nothing shall stand
in their way how could they lose when
they have a God on their side but why
did all these normal people become
violent zealots for a squidface deity it
all began with a dream to those who
experienced these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God holding dominion over all
at first it just seemed seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken and Afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they Clos their eyes little by
little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another they would meet in secret
exchanging information from the
prophecies their rulers sent to them in
their dreams they worshiped together
building altars and Idols to congregate
around they performed dark blood rituals
involving human and animal sacrifice it
was when brother Marsh the anointed one
arrived to guide them towards their true
mission that things kicked into high ear
just 3 months prior brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacle God invaded His
Thoughts with a simple message free me
and the new world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releas releasing
his inhuman ruler from its imprisonment
that was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson cydney
levit Jordan broch Dr Juan Gutierrez and
Jillian lson Dr Juan Gutierrez was a
researcher with level three clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney levit and Jordan
broch were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site Kelly Thompson was a
member of site Administration with
research authorization powers and
Jillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr Gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to SCP
2662 and bringing their plan to fruition
normally Personnel dossier on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential but the devotees of the
tentacled God had their ways they had a
number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in
and pulling some basic information off
of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turned to some good
oldfashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results of course while the Colts
grip on sanity may have been a little
tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against SCP 2662 was being held in a
humanoid containment cell and guarded by
on-site Task Force Town 9 better known
as the belligerent bodyguards these
aren't lazy dut chopping m cops these
are a heavily trained heavily armed
fighting force though the cultists had
one thing that these Foundation soldiers
didn't the element of surprise for
everything to go off perfectly brother
Marsh's plans would have to be executed
within a single day and they were
already on the clock to 9 had been
charged with tracking down any new SCP
2662 Colts in dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the found
Foundation tracked them down and did the
same to them if they wanted any chance
of freeing the tentacled God then they
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming Force the SCP 2662
worshippers were able to secure the
addresses of the five key Foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney levit and
Jordan broch were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian lson had
seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs in
working with some of the most dangerous
and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing
more than regular
humans so far brother Marsha's plan had
gone perfectly with all five key
personnel murdered within a 2-minute
period next the selected doppelgangers
stole clothes from their victim's
closets and were handed the correct
Forge documentation the next morning
each replacement began their Journeys to
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained while the the rest of
the cult armed themselves in preparation
for their own part in the plan nobody at
the foundation seemed to notice anything
a miss when the five arrived on site
when you work for the SCP Foundation
more mental energy is devoted to
following the rules that keep you alive
then two memorizing the faces of all
your co-workers and each one slip neatly
into position disappearing into the
familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the beligerant bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on in the ensuing chaos the five
cultists who had already infiltrated the
site could take advantage of the
distraction and break into the
containment chamber it was perfect they
launched their attack from the outside
and from within when brother Marsh
declared that the time was right the
assault began a legion of gun wielding
culas seemed to Spring out of nowhere
and started shooting up the warehouse
that was a front for the containment
site the site quickly mobilized guards
and task force members to take on the
sudden threat and just as brother Marsh
had anticipated the site director called
on the majority of town 9 to help Propel
the violent cultist from their perimeter
Town 9 obeyed leaving three task force
members behind to guard SCP 2662
containment chamber they expected to be
guarding the cell from rampaging
religious zealots seeking an audience
with their God what they didn't expect
was a group of five Foundation employees
walking right up to them and opening
fire killing two Town n members and
taking the third as hostage while the
war was being waged outside the
infiltrators had found the tentacle Gods
containment cell in the lowrisk human
Ward their hostage insisted that using
him wouldn't give them any leverage the
rest of his team would neutralize the
whole group him included if that's what
it took to stop them the infiltrators
explained that using him as leverage was
never their intention he wasn't a
hostage at all he was a
sacrifice the cultists of the tentacled
god detonated explosives creating a hole
in the wall and finally giving them
access to their deity they climbed
through and gazed upon him in awe there
stood SCP
2662 twice as tall as a regular man with
10 huge tentacles emerging from its back
in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
Gods work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured Town n
member it was at this point that SCP
2662 turned and saw what they were doing
with a look of pure horror he rose up
from his computer his headphones getting
caught as he did so he told them to go
away that he didn't want them here and
that the murdering people in his bedroom
like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultist became even more
confused why wasn't their God accept ing
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor in
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
love crafty and God to just leave him
alone so he could play his video games
this was seriously not cool the cultists
were baffled they told the tentacled god
that they were there to free him he
replied that he didn't need saving that
crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town n
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662 cell this was a common
occurrence
Unfortunately they had to deal with an
attempted cult Invasion every few months
because SCP 2662 is main anomalous
ability is inspiring violent Cults who
relentlessly track down and worship it
with Arcane and bloodthirsty rituals the
problem is 2662 doesn't do this
consciously and definitely doesn't like
the results that's why he's under the
voluntary care of the SCP Foundation who
keeps him amused with video games and
reading material while fending off the
deranged Colts who try to invade and
abduct him following the termination of
the devotees of the tentacle God just
one of many Colts who'd broken into 2662
containment cell the remaining Town n
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again SCP 2662 cell was
repaired and the foundation returned to
its task of seeking out wouldbe cult
emancipator because for the SCP
Foundation it's not always about the
anomaly that's being kept in containment
but what's being kept out it's 3:00 a.m.
and the facility is quiet office workers
and administrators roam the Halls
security officers stand at their posts
clad in advanced tactical armor and
carrying standard issue M4 carbins three
Foundation employees sit at flickering
monitors watching a live feed of footage
from the containment cell of the
infamous SCP 106 or as it's referred to
by all staff the old man no Foundation
Personnel are permitted to travel within
60 ft of the cell for security reasons
and nobody is permitted to physically
interact with the anomaly without the
approval of 2/3 of 05 command the
observer's eyes itch and Sting from
hours of unending blue light exposure
but they can't to look away the old man
is Crafty he might have the insatiable
blood lust of a hungry great white shark
but he's not mindless he's a calculating
Predator more sadistic than the worst
human serial killer and he's always
searching for the next opportunity
according to the found Foundation
records he's been active since at least
World War II and it's estimated that he
has hundreds if not thousands of victims
to his name and many of those made
simple but extremely foolish mistakes of
underestimating him after all it only
takes a few seconds of inattentiveness
in the briefest moment of distraction to
give him the window he needs to do what
you ask oh don't worry you'll find out
just like they did the old man has his
nickname for a reason most of the time
he really does look exactly like that an
old man or more specifically an old
man's decaying corpse his body covered
in Rotten Dark grayish black flesh that
looks like putrid meat though the
creature has been observed being able to
change shape the rot seems to run too
deep for the old man to ever hide it
Foundation employees that have observed
SCP 106 for extended periods of time
have reported seeing it assume the form
of grinning decayed children and women
whose rotted flesh barely hangs on their
creaking bones just seeing the images
through a video feed is enough to cause
a lifetime of insomnia and other
sleeping issues still they have a job to
do and the cameras remain fixed on the
old man he's been completely motionless
for 3 months just sitting there like a
Buddhist monk in deep meditation an
office might see this period of
inactivity as a cause for celebration
but those with experience know that this
is merely the Calm before the storm SCP
106 can remain in a dormant state for
months at a time described by the
foundation scientists as a lulling state
it's believed that the Old Man simply
waiting for its capts to get soft make a
mistake or simply have a moment laps in
concentration which is all it needs to
make its move it had happened so many
times before and it was about to happen
again one of The Observers must have
felt an overwhelming wave of anxiety as
he saw the creature ever so slightly
twitch just a tiny quiver in the
shoulder muscles but that was enough to
tell the Observer that their day had
just taken a terrifying turn he grabbed
the emergency phone fixed to his desk
and practically screamed into the
receiver that 106 is moving that they
need a Tactical Team stat but it was
already too late he the other two
observers stared into the monitors with
their mouths of gape as a gooey
rust-like substance began to pull around
the creature on the floor of its cell
slowly the creature craned its withered
neck around its face was fixed into a
broad yellow tooth lipless grin its eyes
had the kind of dull flat malice of an
underwater Predator it looked directly
into the camera directly at them and
smiled The Observers knew this was bad
really really bad with what they could
have sworn was a little nod the old man
began sinking in into the rusty puddle
it made on the ground beneath it until
it had disappeared entirely SCP 106 is
capable of phasing through any solid
surface with ease making it one of the
hardest entities to reliably contain and
earning it a spot on the dreaded keer
class reserved for the anomalies that
are complete nightmares to keep locked
up through the years of costly research
and deadly trial and error the
foundation would later devise ways of at
least slowing the creature down it's
shown to have an aversion to lead highly
complex or random physical structures
and intense bright light light none of
these cause harm to the creature as far
as we know literally nothing can but
they'll at least buy you some precious
extra seconds with which to at least try
and Escape seconds the three observers
didn't have one of them grabbed an
emergency line again and barked into it
that they lost visual on the anomaly
just then The Observers heard a faint
crackling sound behind them and the
hissing of a chemical burn they turned
in horror to see a huge Rusty burn mark
expanding across the wall right next to
the door which was their only Escape
Route they backed as far away from the
door as they could as a rotten hand
began reaching out of the mass of
corrosive black sludge followed by the
grinning face of SCP 106 ready to have
some fun meanwhile two heavily armed
security officers agents Goodwin and
Resnik came charging down the corridor
toward the observation rooms it become a
bleak slogan during SCP 106 Escape
attempts that all you need to do is
follow the screams and that motto was
proven true that night because awful
things were happening to the observation
Personnel they were certainly screaming
about it of course even with the
top-of-the-line Firearms there was
little they could do to harm the
rampaging old man he seemed immune to
all forms of physical damage all they
could hope to do was keep the thing
distracted until the scientists and
containment Specialists finished the
preparations to lure him back into his
containment cell goodwi surged forward
while Resnick covered his six vigilance
was key as unlike a standard human
combatant SCP 106 could attack from
literally any angle including above or
below physical obstacles were irrelevant
to him and no cover was safe the
hardened security officers could see the
burn mark on the wall of the observation
room as they approached SCP 106 was
perpetually coated in a thick black
mucus with powerful corrosive properties
that left any surfaces it touched
permanently marked Foundation scientists
speculated that this mucus served as a
kind of pre-digested substance that
tenderizes meat and Bone alike but to
what purpose this serves is a mystery as
the old man has never been observed
eating it's postulated that the only
purpose is causing additional pain
Goodwin and Resnik knew to treat this
hissing sludge as a Potential Threat as
the corrosive properties would remain
active for as much as 6 hours before
finally fizzling out the two officers
shared a quiet nod before Goodwin
breached the observation room door with
a hard kick the two of them searched
inside guns at the ready in their time
working at the foundation they'd seen
some truly horrific sights from the
mutilation of d-class personnel
typically death row prison inmates
brought in for use as SCP guinea pigs to
the violence and Mayhem of a containment
bre but there was nothing in their past
that would ever make the horrifying
sight they saw in the observation room
that night feel normal all three
observers were dead almost nothing
remained of two of them and the third
while still intact no longer looked
human he looked like he'd somehow been
dead a hundred years in the brief period
that the old man had been free his skin
was gray and completely dried out and
his mouth was locked into a Perpetual
scream it was a massacre but there was
no sign of the old man Goodwin grabbed
his radio and whispered this is Goodwin
in observation room six requesting
immediate backup we have no idea where
this thing but his sentence was cut off
by a sudden scream from agent Resnik SCP
Foundation security officers are as
tough as Nails the best of the best you
might say recruited from the top
military organizations in the world so
hearing one of them scream in Fright is
a rare if not impossible occurrence but
even they were forced to yell out in
fear when they looked up to see the old
man standing on the ceiling grinning
down at them Resnik raised his M4 and
shot a three- round burst at Center Mass
as he P 106 didn't care even under
sustained gunfire from the two security
officers it didn't Flinch the Old Man
simply reached down and snatched agent
Resnik from the ground like it was
picking an apple from a tree the old man
held Resnik in one hand and pounded its
other rotten fist into the agent's body
breaking all of his bones Resnik
screamed for his partner to help him but
there was no time before goodwind could
do anything SCP 106 began receding back
into another slimy burn mark on the wall
only this time he was taking his
screaming victim with him agent resnic
gave one more horrified scream before he
was pulled backward into the inky
Darkness leaving the room silent except
for the burning hiss of the corrosive
goo left behind you might think this
would be the end of it but no for poor
agent Resnik the worst was yet to come
he was being dragged into what the SCP
Foundation scientists refer to as the
old man's pocket Dimension a miniature
layer of reality within our own where
the malicious SCP is essentially a cruel
all powerful God according to witness
reports extracted from victims who were
taken to this little nightmare realm the
dimension resembles a series of twisting
endless corridors where the old man
stalks and tortures captured victims to
the breaking point manipulating space
and time to his own sadistic ends on
rare occasions the SCP will even release
its victims just for the joy of hunting
capturing and torturing them all over
again while agent Resnik was learning
the true meaning of Terror containment
Specialists were mobilizing in itself
cell preparing the one known tried and
true method meod of luring the old man
back tempting it with the prospect of
causing even more suffering in order to
do this Foundation Personnel take one of
the aforementioned class D personnel and
begin inducing extreme pain by breaking
a major bone or slicing a tendon every
20 minutes the victim's agonizing
screams are then played over the
facility's intercom acting as bait for
the pain loving old man the screams echo
through the facility's otherwise silent
Halls as the mutilated corpse of agent
Resnik falls from a new Scorch mark on
the ceiling the old man can hear the
sounds of suffering ringing out through
the air around him and he can barely
contain his excitement over the prospect
of a new play thing the snapped femurs
the torn to killes tendons it was all
too good to miss having had its Twisted
fun with the security officers and
observers SCP 106 wandered back to its
containment cell where a new screaming
victim awaited the other security
officers containment Specialists and
scientists evacuated the area leaving
the old man alone with his prey while
the unfortunate class D was left to his
the rest of the staff commenced cleanup
procedures which mainly involve wiping
the brown and black mucus from the walls
it would probably be at least another
month before anything like this happened
again and new Personnel would be
transferred over to the facility to
replace the Fallen all in all just
another night at the SCP Foundation it
had happened again some absolute schmuck
of a junior researcher had left a
certain door a jar the door that kept
SCP 049 the plague doctor locked in his
containment chamber as a result the good
doctor had wandered out and given the
junior researcher a hug of appreciation
for freeing him leaving his dead body
sprawled out across the ground typical a
problem solving itself but this time the
problem had been a little more severe
than just the one responsible facing
immediate consequences of their actions
the BL doctor had grabbed the junior
researcher's corpse and dragged him back
into a cell leaving the door once again
slightly ajar with a variety of
equipment from his magical Medical bag
the doctor had transformed the junior
researcher's corpse into a disfigured
zombie in hopes of curing him of the
pestilence and released him into the
facility 049 had followed him out to
observe his behavior and in the process
he'd given several guards and members of
janitorial staff a congratulatory hand
touch sending them to early Graves by
the time people realized what was going
on six people were dead several zombies
were wandering around the building and
049 was spotted in a lab stealing
medical equipment Dr cleff Who was on
duty at the time was getting sick of
this nonsense this was actually the
third breach that the plague doctor had
been involved in this month and it was
only the 14th he was frankly ready to
wash his hands of this particular
anomaly because it wasn't just the fact
that the plague doctor killed people
that bothered Dr kleff after all Dr
cleff himself had killed a considerable
number of people it was the fact that
the plague doctor was also so damn
sanctimonious about it CF breathed a
sigh and rubbed his temples to subdue
the incoming headache it was time to
have a little tribunal and decide what
disciplinary action he would take
against this freaky physician the plague
doctor was on his knees locked into
place by heavy chains and restraints
around his neck arms and legs these
weren't even official Foundation
property Dr cleff had brought them in
from his private Leisure room back at
his house as usual the doctor was
preaching the immense value of his work
work the pestilence runs rif Dr clef
surely you must see that the doctor
cried you're a man of science yourself
allegedly surely you can empathize with
my mission I just want to help people
can't you see I'm just like you blah
blah blah always this goddamn pestilence
do you ever turn off klef said waving
away the doctor's words I don't know
about your pestilence but I'm definitely
looking at a pest right now what the
hell am I supposed to do with you no
matter what allowances we give you you
just keep escaping the doctor hung his
head
he hated when people treated him like
this like some wild animal of course
occasionally people died but it was only
in the pursuit of saving so many more
lives he tried to convince Dr kleff that
the costs would pale in the face of the
rewards but the gung-ho Foundation
researcher simply wasn't interested in
hearing it instead he was brewing up a
new idea one that might rid him of the
plague doctor forever even without
breaking the foundation's goofy rule
against killing anomalies you know what
Dr kleff said affecting a voice of
mocked kindness you finally got your
words through my thick head I get it now
I get how important your research is all
this time we've been stepping in the way
of Nobel prizewinning work I don't know
how I'll ever live with myself for this
I just want to say personally on behalf
of the SCP Foundation we are truly sorry
suddenly the plague doctor perked up my
goodness he thought I finally gotten
through he was practically vibrating
with Glee your apology is accepted good
sir the plague doctor proclaimed let us
not obsess over the past we will look
towards the future exactly Dr cleff cut
in that's why by way of an apology I
plan to reassign you to a special
research facility where you get to run
the show you'll have live test subjects
of Plenty and no accountability to the
foundation whatsoever how does that
sound to you doc the plague doctor
somehow Rose to his feet despite the
chains perhaps propelled by the sheer
force of his love for science I suggest
we leave at once he said thank you Dr
CLE you kind kind man I always knew that
you were the reasonable one even Dr
cleff had to resist the urge to laugh
about that one smash cut to the next day
when Dr cleff the plague doctor and a
group of mobile Task Force officers were
crowded into a helicopter heading
towards SCP 3008 also known as the
infinite Ikea of course the plague
doctor didn't know that he thought he
was heading towards the state-of-the-art
research facility that Dr cleff promised
him cleff on the inside reason that what
this Birdbrain didn't know
wouldn't hurt him the helicopter landed
within the perimeter established around
the abandoned Ikea and the plague doctor
was herded off the vehicle he' bought
clef's lie Hook Line and Sinker and as
such was unusually Cooperative with the
guards Dr clef pointed to the building
and instructed the plague doctor to head
inside and just keep walking he'd find
the test subjects and the facility soon
enough and why would the foundation be
lying to him they'd even let him take
his medical B bag in there when you get
in there ask for Hugh he'll be your lead
assistant Dr CLE told him lead assistant
you mean to tell me I will have multiple
research assistants the plague doctor
said oh Splendid I cannot wait to meet
this Hue oh yeah Dr gleff said biting
his bottom lift to stifle a laugh his
name's Jass be sure to mention that
it'll help speed along the process the
plague doctor nodded his head in thanks
much appreciated Dr cleff rest assured I
will not forget this kind this as the
plague doctor wandered into the
abandoned store his heart swelling with
pride Dr clef began to quietly laugh
behind his back like the big old jerk
face he was when he could no longer see
the plague doctor clef turned to one of
his colleagues and jokingly asked does
that mean we'll need a reclassify 3008
as thel now not looking forward to that
paperwork on the inside of the infinite
Ikea the plank doctor was chuckling to
himself with Glee after all these years
of hard work his Merit had been
recognized and he'd been given the
respect he deserved from his peers at
the foundation he was so wrapped up in
his own sense of personal Pride that he
didn't even register it as strange that
he was surrounded by odd sterile living
rooms bedrooms bathrooms and kitchens
all in a seemingly random configuration
with signs next to them in a mix of The
King's English and what he believed to
be some form of Swedish that he didn't
quite understand still he didn't mind
too much he just assumed that these must
be the accommodations for himself his
patients his test subjects and his
research assistants and to think they
built this whole place just for him and
his research it lifted his soul to know
that the SCP Foundation had finally
recognized the pestilence for the danger
that it is from now on everything would
change he'd probably find the Cure in
the next few years then it suddenly
occurred to him he was a little lost the
layout of the research laboratory was
incredibly strange it seemed like an
utterly arbitrary configuration of
bizarre rooms separated by wide aisles
it didn't seem sanitary at all where
were the sealed Laboratories the gurns
the patient beds the medical equipment
and on top of all that where was Hugh
some kind of shenanigans were a foot
that much was clear now the plague
doctor quickened his pace through the
halls of this strange building one way
or another he would get to the bottom of
this nothing would get in the way of the
important research he plan to conduct
here after what felt like hours of
aimless walking the plague doctor
encountered some other sentient beings a
group of three people wearing ragged
post-apocalyptic looking clothes all
carrying defensive kitchen knives and
hammers the doctor was overjoyed to see
these people he could actually converse
with the others upon seeing him were a
little taken aback had some renfair
cosplayer somehow accidentally wandered
into the building what on Earth was
going on here excuse me good s the
plague doctor called out I'm searching
for a hug Jazz that caused the group to
break into laughter immediately
lessening the tension the deao leader of
the group Calvin replied aren't we all
049 didn't get it but these humans
nonetheless like the cut of this new
guy's chib all three of them had been in
here for at least a year each and it had
been a while since they had a good laugh
in this terrible Labyrinthian Place
Calvin stepped forward lowering his
weapons now that he could see that this
weird cosplayer guy didn't seem like a
threat he cleared his throat and asked
mind if I ask who you are fella the
plague doctor was taken back by this
question did they not prepare you in
advance for my arrival the group shook
their heads how strange the plague
doctor said well I suppose some proper
introductions are in order then I am
your new leader as appointed by Dr cleff
of the SCP Foundation I'm a reasonable
man a man of science and under my
leadership we will be a scientific Force
the likes of which the world has never
seen together we will cure the
pestilence and save all of mankind there
was a long pause after that none of the
group of humans really knew how to react
to this Calvin thought to himself great
we got ourselves a major space case
let's get him back to the camp before he
gets himself killed he forced a smile
nodded pretending to be impressed by the
plague doctor's bizarre ranting well
then doctor he said we better get you
back to our camp we're not going to get
anything done while we're just standing
around will we the plague doctor
couldn't agree more he followed the
group of his three new research
assistant further into this incredibly
strange scientific building the plague
doctor indeed appreciated Dr clef
putting all this together for him but he
would privately indulge in the thought
that Dr klef seemingly could not put
together a laboratory to save his life
this place was a bizarre confusing
disaster but he would still make it work
one way or another however his musings
were interrupted When the Lights Went
Out the three people with him began
gasping in shock and horror Calvin was
repeating to himself no this is
impossible I timed it I swear I timed it
but the plank doctor found their
attitude to be utterly baffling these
were supposedly to be Intrepid men of
science and yet they were afraid of the
dark it seemed they really did need his
leadership to get anything done here
follow me gentlemen the plague doctor
said it's merely a failure of the lights
I'll get this rubbish sorted out he
began to walk forward as the three human
beings began to panic behind him telling
him that if he keeps walking he'll die
he needs to come back they need to stick
together but he kept walking he didn't
get this far by being a coward after all
at least the others are following him
now wielding their Hammers and kitchen
kn knes he'd whip them into shape then
his attention was stolen by something
altogether stranger it was a creature
humanoid but not human standing about 10
ft away from him seemingly ignorant to
his presence the blank doctor was
simultaneously fascinated and horrified
by what he saw before him it was in some
kind of yellow and blue uniform with a
hideous mouth formed faceless head and
two long Tangled arms that it dragged
along the floor behind it like an
orangutan it was a TR truly repulsive
pitiful creature one that made the
plague doctor sad to even look at it
clearly this had to be an advanced case
of the pestilence while the plague
doctor was filled with scientific
curiosity his three human traveling
companions were filled with Terror they
were still so far away from the camp and
the staff had found them already because
there's never just one they're like big
deadly cockroaches if you can see one
more are on the way their best beted is
just staying incredibly quiet and trying
to sneak past hello there you poor
fellow the plague doctor said stepping
forwards and waving it seems you're in
dire need of some medical assistance
Calvin and his two companions were
mortified so this was how they were
going to die after making the mistake of
being kind to a clearly deranged man
dressed as a medieval plague doctor what
a way to go the second it heard the
plague doctor's voice the member of
staff was activated as were several
others in a 10 m radius they all
suddenly stood upright muscles taed with
violence waiting to happen they began
chanting their dreaded phrase the store
is now closed please exit the building
while converging and running towards the
plague doctor like a pack of hungry dogs
it was a terrifying sight to behold but
not for the plague doctor himself there
were so many of these poor infected
people and clearly the pestilence had
not only warped their bodies but broken
their minds after all this wasn't a
store this was the new Research Center
specifically designed for his research
Dr cleff would surely never just lie
about something like that he was an
honorable man then again maybe that was
exactly why clef had sent him here so
many victims of advanced pestilence
would make perfect test subjects a
paradise of research the plank doctor
couldn't be happier as a group of 10
staff members converged on him Calvin
and his men could barely look the new
guy may have been crazy but he didn't
deserve to go out like this however the
last thing they expected was for the
plague doctor to calmly raised his hands
allowing the members of staff to run
right into his deadly touch in the
following moments all 10 of them were
lying on the ground dead the three men
were utterly speechless what had just
happened had the man in the strange
costume snuck in a secret knife or a
silenced gun had he gone into some hyper
Advanced instant kill Kung Fu move that
was simply too fast and subtle for them
to perceive or had he really just killed
10 members of Staff in mere seconds just
by touching them the plague doctor
turned to them and said well then
gentlemen let us not Dilly dly grab one
each and we'll carry them to the
laboratory on the double soon after the
plague doctor and his three research
assistants arrived at a nearby
encampment several other members of
staff had attacked them on the way but a
single touch from the plague doctor had
killed each one the humans perspective
on this mysterious stranger had changed
entirely he'd gone from a goofy crank to
a Godlike Savior for as long as they'd
been in here they'd lived in Terror of
Staff but they were nothing to this man
with a single touch from him they were
gone forever as the doors of the camp
were closed behind him the people of the
camp began running towards them confused
and curious the plague doctor was
delighted to see that there were so many
other research assistants here to help
him on his Divine Mission Dr kleff that
beautiful sweet man had given him such a
boon perhaps now the pestilence May
finally be cured one of the camp leaders
ran over Furious and yelled what the
hell are you doing you know you can't
just bring those bodies in here it'll
only attract more of them you fool fool
the plague doctor found this rather rude
but he'd Overlook it for the sake of the
greater good he'd spent his whole life
dealing with the aspirations from lesser
intellects who couldn't even begin to
understand his work the masses rarely
understand processes only results and
here he knew he would be able to give
them results worry not good sir I am a
medical man the plague doctor said
simply walking past the Nayer and
bidding his first three research
assistants to drag the bodies after him
I will bring this place up to Cod you
will see soon enough that my scientific
leadership is second to none now I will
retire to my office and begin dissecting
these samples before the camp leader
could say anything else the plague
doctor had retired into a staff room
which had been retrofitted as a kind of
headquarters for members of the camp
that's when Calvin approached the camp
leader and told him the astonishing news
look boss I know he looks like a
goofball in a Halloween costume he said
but this guy he's special he's something
else he can kill the staff the camp
leader scoffed so can we he said Calvin
shook his head no you don't get it boss
not like us this guy he can kill the
staff just by touching them and the camp
leader had no response to that in his
new study the plague doctor was
dissecting one of the Dead staff members
and was astonished to see what was
happening within the creature had no
organs it was simply that strange
slightly yellow tissue on all the way
down he'd never seen the pestilence have
such a profound and horrific effect on
its victims it had horribly altered them
all the way to the core was this what
the great dying was truly capable of in
its later stages the play doctor
shuddered both with horror and
scientific excitement he'd barely been
here a day and he'd made some of the
most incredible discoveries he took
fastidious notes on these new
Revelations feeling the picture coming
together in his mind his deep scientific
thoughts were interrupted by the door
opening and Calvin and the camp leader
stepped in the camp leader was different
than before he had none of the Bluster
and arrogance of his first words he
showed fty like he was standing in the
presence of a Divine being I I'd like to
formly welcome you to our camp doctor
the camp leader said we're extremely
fortunate to have you here please if you
need anything don't hesitate to let us
know we are truly At Your Service the
plank doctor was delighted to hear this
with a polite nod he replied more pest
subjects like these will do just fine
good sir I believe I am very close to a
breakthrough here having your ordinary
life unceremoniously change Forever
Without a moment's notice is something
that people can often find themselves
hoping for anything to break life's
monotony and change circumstances to
make them more interesting although when
that change comes in the form of being
trapped in an endless Ikea Outlet it's
not exactly the different kind of
circumstances that people usually hope
for that was the situation that had
befallen Winston not too long ago what
started as a simplistic straightforward
shopping trip with the goal of
purchasing some affordable stylish
Swedish Furniture had resulted in him
having to adopt a completely different
lifestyle you see Winston was one of the
untold number of people to have an
encounter with SCP 3008 better known
colloquially as the infinite Ikea
appearing as an ordinary store those
entering the doors of SCP 3008 find
themselves in an unending Labyrinth of
aisles upon aisles filled with flatpack
Hare it can be quite the System Shock of
course especially when people that find
themselves inside the infinite Ikea
learn there's no way to escape even by
retracing their steps back the way they
came doing so they'll only be met with a
disheartening realization that the
entrance isn't where it was upon their
arrival now at first learning that
you've lost your entire life and are
doomed to spend the rest of your days
inside a limitless Ikea is admittedly a
lot to take in your friends family job
all your worldly possessions are now
unreachable and everyone back home might
likely spend many years wondering what
happened to you but it's not all bad
news as previously mentioned Winston
wasn't the only one to find himself in
this predicament over the years
countless people have found their way
inside the infinite Ikea given how
expansive the interior of the
NeverEnding Story or was there has never
been a way to know for certain exactly
how many people have come to reside
within SCP 3008 but it's enough to
populate the number of small settlements
that these survivors have been able to
establish Inside by innovatively
repurposing the materials around them
these individuals have found themselves
to be the new Denis of SCP 3008 imagine
whole towns constructed from chairs and
tables that have been used as building
materials to provide a place of
sanctuary to those that need it when
they first arrive in the infinite Ikea
sure it takes a pretty big adjustment to
this new lifestyle but luckily SCP 3008
provides for its inhabitants by
automatically replenishing the food
within its canteen naturally it only
offers items that are on the Ikea menu
but that's at least a consistent source
of food and nutrition for those dwelling
in its aisles with food already taken
care of people inside SCP 3008 didn't
even need to work that was the strangest
part that Winston found himself having
to adapt to when he first got to the
settlement of cookware named after the
nearby sign that hung from the ceiling
nearby denoting one of the many
departments of the store it was odd to
him how friendly everyone was how much
the people trapped inside 3 2008 cut off
from the outside world forever seemed
happy there were many who had been there
for the longest that even claimed it was
a better sense of life than out there in
the real world inside the Ikea there was
a strong sense of community settlements
helped each other out with construction
and because everything was provided for
no one had any need for selfishness or
greed after all there was plenty of food
to go around and money had no relevance
ironic given they were all living inside
a huge Furniture Store witnessing all of
that helped Winston adapt to his new
life inside SCP 3008 and made him feel a
lot better about being in this
predicament the only real thing anyone
inside the infinite Ikea had to worry
about was the threat of the staff these
were the tall faceless humanoids with
elongated arms and legs that roam the
aisles of the furniture store while
wearing distinctive Ikea uniforms most
of the time they remain docile paying
the human survivors little attention
that is until the fluorescent lights
above dimmed signaling the beginning of
nighttime the staff usually became
aggressive repeating the ominous phrase
the store is now closed
please exit the building and attacking
anyone they came into contact with
thanks to their Ingenuity the survivors
in the Ikea had constructed barriers
around their settlements to keep the
staff out and that did the trick
repelling The Faceless employees that
come at night but little did anyone
inside SCP 3008 realize that simple
barricades wouldn't stop an entirely new
threat from entering the store to
disrupt their peaceful way of life for
outside the infinite Ikea Something
Wicked was stirring meanwhile at a
facility belonging to the SCP Foundation
a researcher by the name of Corbin
Donell had recently been assigned to SCP
035 also known as the possessive mask
this white porcelin mask could shift
between a comedy grin or a tragic frown
it also had the nasty trait of being an
evil psychic artifact that could
manipulate anyone around it into placing
the mask over their face at that point
SC p035 would take full control of its
wearer making them into a host for the
mask itself so would you like to take a
guess as to what happened to researcher
Donell the voice in his head that
persuasive whisper it wouldn't leave him
alone all day long it was there but
whenever Corbin was near SCP 035 it got
louder and as the days he was studying
the possessive mask went on the whisper
became a shout the screams to put on the
mask were taunting him keeping him awake
at night tormenting him all through the
waking day until eventually he'd had
enough given that SCP 035 produced a
corrosive black substance that usually
melted anything around it the mask had
to periodically be taken out of its
containment case so that the container
housing it could be replaced and it was
during one of these transfers that
researcher Dell calmly swept in pushing
away the guards taking it out of its
melted case before they could place it
in a new one the aggression from the
researcher caught the security Personnel
by surprise as did what he did next not
caring what the possessive mask would do
to him Corbin lifted the white porcelain
to his face he wasn't even aware that
the Containment Breach alarms were
sounding all that noise sank into the
background as the psychic voice in his
head got louder than it ever had before
there wasn't even so much as a split
second awareness from researcher denell
of the Searing pain as the dark sludge
oozing from The Mask made contact with
his skin melting his face as he wore SCP
035 by that point it was already too
late the possessive mask had full
control Corbin's body wasn't his own
anymore although it still moved walking
quickly out of the room and through the
halls of the foundation facility the
researcher beneath was already dead
there was only SCP 035 piloting its
newest host to freedom of course while
Containment Breach was still an urgent
matter the foundation knew that SCP 035
is biggest weakness was itself the black
secretion that poured out of the
possessive mask would melt anything it
came into contact with and would
ultimately cause the body of its H to
melt into nothing once that happened it
would be far easier to recontain as
cp035 someone would merely have to pick
it up and place it back in the
containment case however SCP 035 knew
this too The Mask itself was cunning it
hadn't just picked researcher denell at
random to be its new vehicle it wanted
him specifically because of his previous
posting before he had worked with SCP
035 Corbin had been stationed to observe
any potential changes at the entrance of
SCP
3008 as it stayed firmly on the
researcher's face using him to carry
itself out of the foundation site it had
been trapped in SCP 035 was scouring the
remnants of Corbin's mind it used its
innate psychic ability ities to plunder
the depths of his brain looking for
information the location of SCP 3008 was
right there stored away safely and
researcher donel's memories as was the
way to get there and on top of that the
reason SCP 035 had taken such an
interest in making it to the infinite
Ikea during the foundation's many years
of study and exploration of sccp 3 2008
they came to learn that not all of the
survivors inside the infinite Ikea had
origin inated from the same universe the
current theory was that the entrances to
this endless Furniture Store existed
simultaneously in multiple realities
meaning that the people now living
alongside each other inside SCP 3008
were actually from varying different
worlds across the Multiverse now if you
were incredibly cunning incredibly
clever and Incredibly sick of being held
captive by the foundation then perhaps
you could figure out a way to navigate
your way through the infinite I Kia you
could enter through the front door in
one universe and then exit into another
and of course that was what the
possessive mask was planning to do as it
approached the main entrance of SCP 3008
the black sludge leaking out of the Mask
had almost destroyed what was left of
researcher Corbin Donell it wiped more
of the corrosive secretion onto the
guards stationed at the infinite Ikea
melting through them as SCP 035 made its
way inside first things first The Mask
knew it had to find itself a new body to
Pilot before Corbin expired and it
didn't take long for the possessive mask
to happen across an unwitting candidate
between the aisles of flatpacked tables
at around the same time this was
happening Winston having long since
gotten used to the Rhythm of Life inside
SCP 3008 was on his way to the food
court he knew the route by heart now and
as he strolled closer he was pondering
over what he'd help himself to today
from the menu but it was while making
his way there that that he noticed
something or rather he noticed not
something that he usually did there were
no staff anywhere around although they
did not pay the survivors any mind
during the day when the lights of the
Ikea were on Winston knew that the staff
members were always present there were
usually a couple Milling about the
aisles he had to pass in order to get
from the settlement of cookware to the
Food Hall but today there were none and
while this wouldn't usually be any cause
for alarm it kept playing on Winston's
mind as he sat down to eat his plate of
Swedish meatballs he'd been inside SCP
3008 for such a long time that he'd
become accustomed to the routine of
living there and the absence of the
staff immediately stuck out as something
that was out of its usual place
finishing his food Winston asked around
talking with his fellow residents of the
infinite Ikea asking if any of them had
encountered any of the tall faceless
staff members on their way to get their
meals each and every one of them that he
asked from varying different settlements
all answered the same that they hadn't
spotted any staff all day as much as
they were A Minor Threat to the human
beings living inside the infinite Ikea
the absence of the store's only other
residents kept playing on Winston's mind
whatever was going on the staff
seemingly Vanishing couldn't mean
anything good and so he decided to
venture out into the aisles to figure
out what exactly was going on what he
found was unlike anything anyone had
ever seen in SCP P 3008 before it took
Winston several long and uneventful
hours to catch even a momentary glimpse
of a staff member he almost felt like
someone trekking through a forest
looking to get a sighing of Bigfoot or
some other elusive urban legend but as
the third hour became the fourth he
spotted a hint of movement between the
aisles following at a safe distance
listening out for the slightest sounds
Winston couldn't help but think he
detected the noise of something heavy
being dragged along the stone floor more
peeking out from between the aisles he
saw them a huge group of Staff members
were all huddled in a display dining
room only there was something different
about all of them they still retained
their recognizable tall and humanoid
shapes with long disproportionate limbs
but there was something smeared over the
staff a dark oily black substance that
seemed to melt through the floor as it
dripped off them from his Hiding Place
Winston soon saw where that substance
had originated from the thing being
dragged across the floor was another
staff member looking more normal than
the rest one of the others covered in
the corrosive sludge was gripping it by
the color of its Ikea polo shirt and
bringing it through the group meanwhile
the ordinary creature was thrashing and
flailing its lengthy arms around trying
to get free it was dragged up to a staff
member in the middle of the group which
turned and shocked Winston at the
strange side of it this staff member
evidently the leader had a face or
rather it was wearing a mask SCP 035 was
now firmly a fix to the Slender faceless
being its expression locked in a wide
grin that seemed to convey a twisted
sense of Glee its black secretion didn't
seem to be affecting its new host in the
same way it usually did the body of the
staff member it was now piloting didn't
seem to dissolve as the uncorrupted
staff creature was presented to the Mast
leader SCP 035 compelled its Newfound
followers to restrain their prisoner the
the workers within SCP 3008 didn't have
much in the way of their own free will
or even personalities to speak of they
did however seem to share some sort of
connection to each other a hive mind of
sorts so presented with a powerful
psychic Force like the possessive Mask
The Entity had been able to not only
take over one of the staff members as
its new host but spread its influence to
the others and while Winston watched
horrified it unknowingly demonstrated
this the captive staff member was
grabbed and held by the others its long
arms and legs pulled apart the huddled
group lifted it up off the floor so that
it couldn't free itself and run off into
the endless aisles of furniture wearing
SCP 035 the leader extended an arm black
ooze dripping from it the droplets
burning Holes in the Floor as it reached
towards the faceless head of the
restrained staff member it placed a
large hand over the faceless head of the
captive more of the corrosive secretion
passed on to the newest addition to SCP
0 35's growing Army as the black
substance spread over the staff member
so did the influence of the possessive
mask Force its way into another vessel
I'm telling you I know what I saw
Winston protested after recounting the
events to the other settlers back at
cookware there's something else out
there something new and dangerous and
it's infecting the staff oh that's
ridiculous replied Bryce one of the
survivors who had been there much longer
I've been here for years and I've never
even heard of such a thing they yelled I
saw it with my own eyes Winston argued
it has a small army of them already
under its control even if what you're
saying is true someone else chimed in
what does it matter you've already got
barriers to keep the staff out and they
only attack a night anyways surely even
if this mask thing really is in control
of them now who cares as if on Q one of
the Lookouts at the cookware settlement
started frantically trying to get
everyone's attention they pointed to the
ominous glow coming from just beyond the
nearby aisles filled with wardrobe
frames an orange flicker was visible
even Under The Lights of the store which
were still on although blocked a little
by thick plumes of black smoke rising up
towards the ceiling that's lighting the
lookout said in shock disbelief stating
the name of another nearby community of
survivors that was named after an Ikea
store Department something must have
happened over there Bryce declared uh
maybe it's an electrical fire that's
gotten out of control it's them Winston
said solemnly it can't be them the
Builder Survivor snapped the lights are
still on it's still daytime in the store
and the staff never attacked during the
day I don't think the rules are the same
anymore frustrated Winston continued to
argue there's no telling what that mask
did to them uh perhaps Bryce was trying
desperately to come up with a suggestion
but was clearly grasping at straws uh
what if this mask can be recent with if
it's more intelligent than the staff we
can we can negotiate uh there must be
something it wants what do you think it
wants it wants this place this I Kia and
now it has control of enough staff to
form a small army you think it's just
going to stop there it's coming for all
of us and it won't stop until it's got
the whole store under its control and if
it has to wipe us out to do that well it
looks like it's not hesitating so what
do we do a voice called meekly Winston
turned to see the town's folk of
cookware had gathered all looking up at
him with terrified Expressions on their
faces he gazed back at each one of them
then looked back over at the smoke now
towering over where lighting had been
and was now in flame
who knew how many of the settlers there
were still alive and how long it would
be before SCP 035 and its new Army did
the same to cookware something had to be
done we need to get the word out Winston
announced to the other survivors I need
our fastest to run over to the other
towns in the store you each take one you
pass on the message and then you come
back you know your way around well
enough so avoid anywhere you'd normally
see staff even if they haven't been
corrupted we can't chance it why do we
tell the other settlements somebody in
the crowd called you tell them what's
going on you say that something has come
here to threaten this Ikea and our way
of life this place isn't where any of us
first came from but it's all our home
now it's provided for us but now it
needs us to defend it Winston explained
and how exactly are we going to do that
Bryce asked the lights had gone out but
although night had fallen it wasn't Dark
Yet standing with their fellow survivors
from numerous other settlements the
residents of SCP 3008 had fashion
flaming torches from the legs of Ikea
desks and tables and that wasn't all
they were carrying makeshift weapons
some had Spears crafted using curtain
rails with sharp kitchen implements
fashioned to the end others had wardrobe
doors in their hands to act as
rudimentary Shields they were hardly
Warriors but as an army of corrupted
staff members lurched out of the
darkness towards them each Survivor of
SCP 3008 knew what they had to do at the
front of the army towered the staff
member with SCP 035 live on its faceless
head the possessive masks wide grin had
shifted now a long frown almost one of
disgust at the amass settlers to opposed
it as it raised an elongated arm to
command its horde Winston raised a
curtain rail spear into the air for Ikea
he yelled as the residents of SCP 3008
charged it was such a normal morning
almost comically uneventful for the
first time in what felt like forever the
morning newscast had very little to say
they covered Fashion Week some protests
in the capital a new health graze
sweeping the nation a funny viral video
of a dog eating a pancake the
inspirational story of a young boy from
the Midwest beating cancer a minor
political Scandal out of Tallahassee
Florida that nobody would remember in a
week a round of interviews with an
expert who' written a new book about the
long-term effects social media might
have on our children none of them knew
back then that longterm was a luxury
they couldn't afford people went to work
to school some took the day off plenty
took walks or jogs deciding to exercise
outside for a change after all it was
such a beautiful sunny day out what a
terrible shame it would be to waste the
light indoors people were sleepwalking
so placidly blissfully unaware of what
was rattling down the tracks towards
them it was an uncharacteristically slow
day down at sight 19 there hadn't been
been any containment breaches in over a
week a couple of new anomalies had been
brought into containment one safe class
and one uclid but neither were the kind
that was likely to bring the SCP
Foundation any trouble right now the
biggest threat facing their employees
seemed to be borom and they definitely
take that over any other members of
their Rogues Gallery Dr brgh poured
himself a mug of nice hot coffee and
decided to watch some TV in the
breakroom just to pass the time the
president of the United States States
was giving a press conference on the
White House lawn surrounded by
microphones it was really nothing
special just the same andain Babble
about how he was going to fix the
deficit and with inflation On The Rise
we'd all need to work on being more
fiscally responsible The Immortal
Foundation researcher sipped his coffee
these normal boring problems felt like
the perfect escape from the insanity he
needed to deal with every day at the
foundation the president was saying
something about the importance of
families and about farmers being the
nation's real backbone when something
happened there was an odd shift in the
quality of the light Dr brigh barely
registered it maybe it was something to
do with the cameras however things
started to get stranger the president's
speech began to slur as though he'd just
been pumped with enough morphine to take
down an elephant but it wasn't just that
it was sweating buckets too wet patches
expanded all over his suit and
perspiration was dripping off his skin
Dr brigh was was in suspense was he
about to watch the president have a
stroke live on air would he be called in
to replace him yet again but no the
situation unfolding was far far worse
the president of the United States
slumped forward over his Podium while
the reporting core screamed his face
slothed off his skull like melting wax
the president's words slurring off into
Infinity it was the worst a US president
had looked on film since SCP 1981
Dr Bri dropped his coffee cup it tumbled
and shattered onto the ground below the
camera fell as the operator screamed it
pointed down into the crowd where the
reporters were shrieking in pain and
Terror steam coming off their bodies
with a sudden intense climb in heat they
were all melting all of them were
melting before his very eyes broadcast
out to how many people it would be the
mother of all containment nightmares
little did Dr brigh know that wasn't
even the half of the true Horrors
unfolding alarms went off across every
containment site in the world NCP
Foundation employees unlucky enough to
be standing outside at the time were
lost in the rapidly unfolding Horrors
they screamed as the sun cleaved their
atoms apart reducing them into semi-
liquid states without the mercy of death
people lucky to be just out of the sun
could only watch as those less fortunate
disintegrated across the ground in
Unholy shrieking puddles never had such
unnormal day been thrown into such
terrifying chaos in so little time
billions of voices cried out at once as
the sun changed in the sky above them
since the dawn of humanity it had given
us everything light to Baskin warmth to
keep us safe and the life of the plants
and animals that kept us fed it had been
worshiped as a God by countless cultures
over thousands of years one great mother
to all of humanity and now that mother
was drowning Us in the bathtub and
perhaps the most frightening part of all
it was for seemingly no reason no reason
at all the SCP Foundation was forced to
now break their silence forever the
Masquerade the veil it melted along with
so much of humanity they took over every
Communications channel in the world and
did what they could to inform people on
how to get out of Harm's Way stay in
side wrap yourself in Sun shielding
clothing and only move at night air
travel is preferable if possible if you
can make your way to one of the SCP
foundation's secure sites their only
chance of preserving humanity and
figuring out how to reverse this new
nightmare now more than ever the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Only Hope
until of course there was another
terrifying twist in the tail while those
who were melted into piles of living
flesh sludge were sadly assumed to be
lost even the foundation didn't expect
the transformed humans to become a
threat in and of themselves just as
their bodies were melted so were their
minds they became slaves cultists of the
growing Tyrant hanging up above some
would coagulate into huge fleshing
masses horrifying threats that would
seek out victims overpower them and drag
them out into the light to be absorbed
and transformed even those hiding inside
Foundation containment centers weren't
safe these behemoths of melted flesh
would find their way in using their many
Twisted voices to slowly break the minds
of their victims then gather them up
with great flesh tendrils and yank them
out into their Doom little by little the
numbers of humanity dwindled it looked
like we had a bright future ahead of us
and in this particular context that's
far from a good thing survivors for
whatever time they had left would
forever remember this walking nightmare
the foundation dubbed it SCP 001 to
reflect its ultimacy but to everyone
else it had a different name when day
breaks in a world where anything but
Darkness will kill you is there anywhere
left on Earth that's truly safe from the
horrors of SCP 001 5 months into the
never-ending horror of the solar
Singularity Alice spooned herself a bowl
full of warm Swedish meatballs delicious
she was was part of an investigative
detail from a nearby community deep
within the bowels of the only truly safe
place for human beings on planet Earth
SCP 3008 also known as the infinite Ikea
no sun had ever Shone in there only the
lights which Fizz and flicker far above
everyone inside thinks of it as a prison
little do they know what's left of
humanity out there would kill to be
inside the sanctuary Alice had a team of
10 with her their mission was simple
continue the mapping effort of the area
surrounding their community and collect
rations for the rest of the camp it was
dangerous work especially as night Drew
close but there were certain rewards
when they reached a feeding station they
were able to enjoy fresher food than
anyone else all they needed to do was
wager their lives for it to Alice it
seemed like a fair trade her Lieutenant
Darcy kept watch to the north he and
several others wielded makeshift Spears
made from curtain rods and clubs
fashioned from bed posts knives
scavenged from the kitchen section hung
from their belts in makeshift holsters
during the day there were little more
than a precaution at night it could mean
the difference between life and death
speaking of Darcy kept a close watch on
a member of Staff it was a lanky
faceless monster in that garish uniform
with a bulbous oversized head and long
arms hanging slack like pulled Taffy
dragging its Knuckles along the ground
as it stumbled along Darcy thought it
Darkly funny how stupid they could look
in the daytime like Crash Test Dummies
rejected from the assembly line bear
stood close by he never gave any of them
his real name so they took to calling
him bear because he was big hairy and
would probably tear you to shreds if you
got on his bad side he wielded the
largest Club of all a customized
Creation with sharp objects sticking out
of it on all sides it cleaved the heads
of many staff members off their bodies
Bears seemed to relish the task of
putting those monsters down for him it
was easy and fun that's why he was an
essential asset on these missions a
Berserker most of the grunts shoveled as
much food as they could carry an Ikea
branded Tupperware and coolers the more
they gathered the longer it would take
for them to be forced out beyond the
safe walls of the Haven they built
inside this Swedish flatpack hell they
all made do with what they had in here
it was all they they could really do two
members of the team were unaccounted for
sirel and Joseph what passed for
reconnaissance experts down here they
seem to have an innate sense of
direction as though they were somehow in
tune with the Ikea itself they would be
sent out on scouting missions searching
for resources food other survivors and
most prized of all potential Escape
Routes it was a dream a fantasy that
someday one of them would find the exit
and lead the rest of them to salvation
through it Alice had been trapped in the
infinite Ikea for 6 years going on seven
now she had long since given up on
dreams of Escape all they could do was
accept their situation get used to it
and just try to survive under these
circumstances but those circumstances
were about to change everyone looked up
when they heard panicked breathing it
was sirel just zero the party clutched
their weapons just that little bit
tighter unsure of what had happened
their rulle were clear scouting Duos
must never ever separate under any
circumstances getting lost in the store
and being isolated When the Lights Went
Out would be a death sentence so if
sirel was returning alone frightened
tears streaking down his face then
something truly awful had happened he
told Alice and the rest of the group
that something had attacked him and
Joseph when Alice told him that was
impossible that the staff wouldn't show
active aggression until lights out until
someone attacked them first sirel shook
his head head and let out a heaving SOB
he told them that the creature that
attacked them wasn't a member of Staff
it was something else entirely something
he'd never seen inside the Ikea before a
true monster whatever this creature was
it moved around a corner incredibly fast
it spoke in a way that was Almost Human
but something was off about it something
that sent a chill down sel's spine just
thinking about it he recalled that the
creature was large and blah BL like
flesh colored with long grasping
tendrils that whipped and flailed
unnaturally these tendrils had wrapped
around and grasp Joseph he hadn't been
quick enough the two of them were too
shocked by the sight of it to react in
time and then it was already too late it
grabbed Joseph and yanked him off into
an adjoining aisle sirel still
remembered his haunting screams getting
quieter and quieter as he moved further
out of sight on some level everyone
hoped that sirel was lying it was
preferable to believe that he himself
had snapped and murdered Joseph for some
unknown reason as opposed to some new
stronger and even more dangerous
creature that was now inside the Ikea
was this some kind of upgrade as they
acclimated to the environment adapted
gotten better at surviving here had the
Ikea in turn created deadlier
countermeasures to destroy them all just
when you thought you had a handle on
things but if sirel was telling the
truth and there was some kind of
creature lurking in the store or
potentially more than just one then they
could be in danger just standing here
they gathered up the group along with
any supplies worth taking and set off
back to their Community they would need
to deliver the bad news so they could
potentially prepare for the worst it was
just one of the many communities housed
within SCP 3008 many have theorized over
the years that the infinite Ikea acts as
a kind of Nexus point for Ikeas all
across the Multiverse a counting for the
truly insane number of people who have
gone missing Without a Trace into the
building over the years there were
children who had been born in the Ikea
raised in the Ikea known nothing but the
Ikea nobody knew an exact number for
sure but it was more than possible that
the population of a small country
resided within its walls sometimes
communities would fracture and fall
apart occasionally due to a lack of
resources or infighting other times due
to an overwhelming attack attack from
the staff that physically destroyed the
settlement often leaving many of its
members dead in the process those who
weren't picked off while wandering the
store in the following days would likely
integrate into other nearby communities
as refugees life was cruel in the
infinite Ika by the time Alice and her
party returned to their Community it was
almost lights out they spoke to the
community leaders and informed them of
Joseph's tragic disappearance as well as
this awful new creature that sirel
claimed had taken him they thought it
best not to inform the rest of the
community tonight it might hurt their
focus and cause unnecessary Panic Alice
agreed to join the watch that night she
could feel something wrong in the air
even more so than usual there was
something terrible in this anomalous
Ikea Alice stood at top the furniture
wall with several other rangers as the
lights flickered off the distinctive
call sounded across the store from the
activated staff members the store is now
Clos
please exit the building it was almost
soothing in its familiarity compared to
the frightening thoughts that sirel had
left swimming through her mind the staff
she could handle it was at least the
devil she knew and there were worse
beasts than the devil out there she knew
it in Her Bones they killed a few staff
members that happened to wander towards
the community and began beating their
deformed fists against the walls all
standard procedure but as Alice eyes
adjusted into the darkness she saw a
huge shape in the distance it looked
like a mountain that breathed a huge
wobbling mass of Flesh moving impossibly
fast for a creature of its size it was
so much vaster than the creature that
sirel had described earlier was this a
different one or had it simply gotten
bigger either way it was coming straight
towards them the community came alive in
sudden Panic every able-body adult
grabbed their weapons and prepared for
the fight of their lives behind the wall
whatever this monster was they needed to
kill it as quickly as possible before it
destroyed everything they built sadly
for everyone inside the community this
was one fight that none of them were
prepared for the Beast crashed into the
furniture wall crushing it inwards
people struck at the monster's immense
and terrible flesh with their weapons
making awful wet slabs but seeming to
cause no lasting impact it just kept
rolling in grasping everyone it could
with its long siney tendrils but the
horrors were only just beginning with
the wall destroyed the staff began to
pour in chanting in monstrous Unison the
store is now closed please exit the
building it was a massacre perhaps one
of the worst that the inside of the
infinite Ikea had ever seen while the
community battled the giant flesh Beast
the forces of the staff swarmed and
overwhelmed them Darcy was Tangled in
the nightmare tentacles of the Beast
bear was surrounded by a truly
insurmountable number of Staff members
each one balling their terrible fists
and beating him to death somewhere sirel
screamed though his scream was soon cut
short Alice watched in horror as
everything she'd known was destroyed
Alice realized her friends were dead and
her community was in ruins she grabbed
her Spear and did the only thing she
could she ran she ran from the lost
cause that had once been her life tears
running down her cheeks what had even
happened what the hell had that great
monster been the Ikea's trump card she
ran aimlessly for as long as she could
then walked and eventually limped she
went on for hours getting lost deeper
and deeper into unknown territory she'd
stop when she was dead why not she had
little left to live for but like the
Holy Grail when she eventually truly
gave up and stopped looking for
salvation it found it way to her as she
turned a corner down a mysterious aisle
she saw something that she hadn't seen
in years glass double doors she stifled
the SOP could it be the way out of here
after all this time and it was the world
escape she'd lost everything but
regained this outside Dawn was breaking
after years the Great Red Sun it was the
most beautiful thing she'd ever seen in
her life she took a deep breath smiled
and stepped into the light this video is
about two things the first is scp096
also known as the shy guy a horrific
monster who murders anyone and anything
unfortunate enough to look at its face
directly or through photos or videos the
second is you because we asked you for
your favorite questions theories and
hypothetical situations involving zero
096 we even asked if you thought someone
would be safe from 096 on the moon and
you delivered if you haven't watched our
first video on the infamous shy guy we
recommend checking that out first but
feel free to stick around even if you
haven't first of all let's take a look
at the questions you had about the SCP
foundation's most dangerous introvert
and see if we can't find some answers
how close would you have to be to
trigger it like if it was 5 km away
would it still count the short answer is
that 096 is homicidal rage can be
triggered from pretty much any distance
we'll get into some of the potentially
crazy extent of this later on but if you
see the shy guy's face while you're
sharing a dimension with him you're in
serious trouble people who view the
creatures face in different countries or
even miles underwater have met gruesome
ends 5 km would definitely not keep you
safe what were his Origins and how
strong is he compared to SCP 682 the
origins of scp096 are still shrouded in
mystery all we know for sure is that he
was discovered by the foundation in a
snowy mountainous region as for physical
durability he's about even with 682 as
both survived their encounter we know
682 has the psychological advantage
though as 096 has been terrified of the
lizard ever since they met in Cross
testing however you could argue that 096
is technically more dangerous since
unlike 82 096 has never been pacified
before killing its intended target while
on a rampage if he goes into an
Unstoppable Attack Mode when someone
sees his face shouldn't you not show his
face in the thumbnail thankfully
according to the official documents
artistic representations like paintings
or digitally drawn YouTube thumbnails
have no effect only actual photographs
or videos of the creature can be deadly
so you're safe unless we decide to do a
09 six face reveal to celebrate our next
100,000 subscribers of course this leads
us to our next question if it attacks
you when you look at it then how did the
scientist draw the picture of the thing
without looking at it that's a good
question and also one that occurred to
the foundation scientists who came up
with an extremely elaborate solution
they put a d-class tattoo artist inside
a diving bell miles underwater and had
him unseal a photograph of the creature
before drawing a copy this copy was then
released from the diving bell in a
sealed container before 096 inevitably
got to the poor d-class does the shy guy
have to be viewed through a good quality
image to enter a rage State
unfortunately no even the most poorly
rendered or minuscule image of 0 96's
face is a death sentence one of the most
infamous incidents resulted from a man
seeing a small dot that was only a few
pixels wide in a photo from an old ski
trip the dot was 096 taken from a mile
away no true image of 096 is safe
regardless of size in some cannons
despite 096 being referred to as
indestructible the foundation managed to
terminate it after many attempts and
even more bureaucracy how did they do it
while a lot of 0 96's body has been
blown away by conventional arms fire its
hypertough skeleton is what has given it
such an indestructible reputation in one
tail though Foundation researchers
actually use this to their advantage Ag
and employed the use of the next
snapping killer sculpture SCP
173 after using 173 to damage 0 96's
bones powerful acid was injected into
the skeleton destroying it from within
though of course this isn't the official
ending of the 096 story because the SCP
Foundation doesn't have a single
unifying cannon that's enough questions
now it's time for you to school us let's
look at some of your favorite theories
about the shy guy starting with I
sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice but he can't control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person
he starts to cry because he didn't want
to kill them there is actually some
evidence to suggest that scp096 might
not want to kill a great example of this
is its cross test with SCP 978 a camera
which reveals the deepest desires of
whoever or whatever is in its photos the
photo it took of 096 showed that it had
completely disappeared from the photo
showing its deepest desire was to just
be invisible and unseen maybe it wants
to disappear because it doesn't want to
Hur anybody regarding the moon question
I think scp096 would probably stay in
that hostile State until you came back
at which point it would promptly rip you
to shreds and do whatever it does to
your mutilated corpse based on what we
know about prior 096 incidents this
feels incredibly likely it's also
possible that it might enter its docile
State before becoming aggressive again
when you return to its murder range you
really don't want to find out either way
he can just jump to the Moon easy he
does squats in Containment all the time
well it scrawny physique doesn't make it
seem like 096 understands the concept of
exercise there aren't any cameras in 0
96's cell so technically we can't prove
it isn't doing squats to pass the time
in there I really doubt a blind person
would be safe from his effect since 096
has the IQ of a newborn baby I think he
will count it as looking at him this is
an interesting Theory however seeing a
096 is able to sense when people see its
face from entire continents away the way
it knows if you can see its face might
be a little more psychic in nature
therefore it's probable that it wouldn't
mistakenly kill someone who hasn't
actually seen its face such as a person
who is blind to deal with him in my
opinion simply freeze him either in
space or in the mountains his body shuts
down and when looked at it it will not
react correctly it is simply asleep
while we don't know how scp096 would
react to a zg environment for a creature
that's always nude it seems extremely
tolerant to the cold when it was first
found it was lurking in icy mountains
and a foundation agent commented on the
fact it wasn't even shivering despite
the incredibly low temperatures but who
knows if there's a temperature out there
that's too low even for the shy guy if
someone looks at it in China and it's in
the US then you get on its back you'll
get a free piggyback ride to China it's
a free trip to China and all it cost is
a human life that's my theory
technically it'd be at the cost of two
human lives unless you wore a diving
suit with plenty of oxygen 096 has
proven to be an extremely proficient
swimmer but you'd have to maintain your
grip across the entire Pacific Ocean
while it Journeys to China in other
words it's technically possible but we
here at SCP explained would rather pay
for the roundtrip flight to each their
own though but that's enough theories
for now let's move on to the main event
hypotheticals you POS some great
possible scenarios involving scp096 so
we're going to see if we can find the
answers what would happen if someone
looked at a picture of it while in or
before entering another scp's pocket
Dimension or mirror Dimension there
aren't any Canon examples to prove
either way but if there's any kind of
consistent entry point into this
Dimension it's likely that 096 would
find a way to follow you in if not it's
very possible that it may just wait for
you to eventually return before bringing
the metaphorical hammer down on you so
technically if you were pulled into the
old man's pocket Dimension and he closed
the portal you'd be safe from 096 but
then you've got a whole other problem to
deal with what happens if a person sees
his face then gets their memory of the
creature wiped considering how good the
foundation seems to be at wiping people
people's memories and their access to
amnestics if this worked they probably
would have made it standard procedure by
now so it's unlikely what happens if a
person looked at it and that person then
went on a plane or just staying in the
air or space what would it do 096 has
shown the ability to jump up and Destroy
low-flying aircraft but otherwise it's
likely that the creature would probably
run to a point directly below you and
remain there until you touch back down
since you'll need food and water at some
point and Air CS need fuel you'd
probably just be prolonging the
inevitable what if the young girl was
around it so it tried to attack her but
died trying this is another interesting
possibility SCP 053 is a girl capable of
causing homicidal urges but causes fatal
heart attacks in those who attack her
while we can't know for sure how a
meeting between 096 and 053 would go we
can use her encounter with 682 as a
potential template aggressive scps like
like the hard tokill reptile perhaps
having an innate knowledge of the danger
that comes from attacking 053 tend to
become strangely docile around her it's
possible that 096 would do the same
would we be able to control scp096 with
the help of SCP 035 the possessive mask
AKA SCP 035 is undeniably a lot more
intelligent than 096 and has even been
shown to respond to reason on occasion
it's also been able to control almost
every other entity it's been placed on
the problem is if the mask was placed on
096 and it was somehow effective the
result may be even more dangerous than
096 an intelligent monster with an
indestructible and highly dangerous body
there's no telling whether 035 would
slowly break down 096 into sludge the
way it does to humans in which case we
would be left with an immortal
0963 five combo so maybe it's best that
we never find out if someone were to be
in the infinite Ikea and looked at a
picture of its face could it finally be
contained and if someone else looked at
a picture of it outside of the infinite
Ikea could it escape and kill them if so
how long would it take it this is a
great question and while the infinite
Ikea is a terrifying maze scp096 has an
advantage here that we don't not only
can It Rip through anything in the way
with its super strength it has an innate
sense of where its victim is therefore
regardless of whether you're inside or
out sccp 096 will still come straight to
you to exact your horrible fate but at
least you can enjoy the meatballs while
you wait right and finally what would
happen if 096 were led into a room full
of mirrors and allowed or made to look
at its own face Would It smash the
mirrors or try to rip itself to pieces
this is still a hotly debated issue to
this day which thanks to the no Canon
nature of the SCP Foundation does not
have a definitive answer some theorize
that this would at least be an effective
deterrent against scp096 While others
suggest that it wouldn't be effective
because many believe that 096 is
actually blind and thus cannot see its
own face it can only sense when other
people see it again we don't quite know
for sure but it's likely to remain one
of the most contentious issues around
the shy guy for a long time to come and
there you have it folks our very first
questions and theories video we loved
hearing what you had to say so keep an
eye on our community post for the next
one are there other scps you'd like to
see us cover and explained or Theory
videos let us know in the comments and
subscribe to SCP explained and turn on
notifications for new SCP videos every
single week as you walk down the halls
of the SCP found Foundation site 19
peing in the various windows at the
anomalies contained there you might
catch a glimpse of a dark figure bent
over a table tinkering away like an
artisan in his Workshop a vintage black
Apothecary bag sits next to him open and
if you stop and watch for a while you'll
see him pull all manner of tools out of
it impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an IV stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly focused singularly on his craft
whatever that might be only one thing
could distract him from his efforts you
he feels your Gaze on him and he looks
up dark eyes glittering from behind a
beaked ceramic mask he reminds you of an
illustration you once saw in a book
about the Black Death the gear the
plague doctors wore while treating
patients on their Death Beds hello he
greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkle beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear fellow are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
help I can examine you he offers Palm
pressed flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the the surface of his
worktable back and forth listening to
the sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
Fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morg for
him to dissect and research there was a
time when the doctors here would come to
speak with him talking of
cryptobiotes of the corpses tissue
samples and jars of formaly he could
pull out when the monotony became too
much but the days of fresh materials of
enlightened discourse with other men and
women of science were over how he missed
those days the chance to work with
others as he want once had what had he
done wrong all he did was treat the sick
sure they didn't always understand their
illness didn't want to receive their
medicine but that wasn't a choice for
the patient to make that should have
been up to the physician perhaps they
didn't trust his expertise didn't see
how his work served the greater good
like those who watched yonas Sal invent
the polio vaccine or Louie pasture rid
milk of bacteria they were confused by
the advanced scientific practices and
fear that which they did not understand
he could forgive them for their
ignorance he was magnanimous that way if
only they would let him out of this
infernal room he could prove his work's
Worth to them he could cure them all
begin a new era of wellness and peace
worldwide he didn't exactly sleep but
when he rested on his little cot in the
corner of the room he dreamed of that
future of a world healed by his touch a
knock at the door stirred him from his
re y someone someone was at the door of
his containment cell he glanced at the
little window and saw a guard there with
a tray of food he greeted the man with
an enthusiastic wave sustenance he
didn't require the food for survival of
course but it helped his mind work more
efficiently it reminded him of a time
before these fluorescent lights and
these same Four Walls of crusty bread
with fresh butter by the banks of the S
the little slot opened in the door and
the tray was shoved through there was
bread just as he hoped a small dish of
butter pot of jam and a cup of tea still
seeming he picked up the cup at first
taking a deep breath ah an herbal blend
with fresh lavender lovely he couldn't
see the guard through the window anymore
but he called out to him just the same
thank you for the Libations he still had
his manners after all even in
confinement he wished he could have
gotten a better look at the man seen the
power of His complexion a Tremor in his
hand he thought he had spotted sweat
beating on his forehead could he be ill
the case required further examination to
be certain he sighed clutching the cup
of tea Tighter and frustration why
wouldn't they just let him work why must
they scream at the sight of his efforts
flee from his instruments it didn't seem
fair still the pursuit of science rarely
was a glamorous one he had learned as
much over the centuries one day though
history would look back on him kindly of
this he could be certain he was just
settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread
when a horrible sound shook him to
attention he had heard the noise before
though he had never seen its source it
was an earsplitting scream a whale of
pure Agony like the sound of a wounded
wild animal he had heard many many
screams during his life from patients
and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into
custody of the foundation he had never
heard a scream quite like this one it
was pure rage Devastation and suffering
mixed together wet with tears and loud
enough to rip through human vocal folds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain of
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thud of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the Halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire heard the gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darting p past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as Flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
workt he studied himself and climbed
back to his feet taking in the Damage
Done to the door it was crumpled in on
itself nearly ripped off the hinges and
whatever had plowed into it was already
gone from the sounds of Chaos in the
distance it had disappeared around the
corner with the guards following it he
inspected the ruin of the door to his
containment cell it was useless now
hanging loose and open well that was an
invitation he was hardly about to
decline he grabbed his trusty bag tossed
his scalpel back inside and set off to
see what all the commotion was it was
easy enough to follow the trail of blood
Stark and Vivid red against the white
tile floor and the sound of gunfire
human screams and that loud long painful
whale he had heard before he walked at a
leisurely Pace taking his time until the
sound suddenly stopped he rounded the
corner and found a mound of bodies
guards and scientists beaten and
bloodied almost beyond recognition it
was quiet here save for one sound the
sound of weeping there in the corner
huddled over with its face to the wall
was a pale thin figure its shoulders
heaving with the force of its sobs this
poor soul was clearly in great distress
it was a peculiar sight hairless and
white extended arms wrapped around
itself as it cried excuse me the doctor
cried out to the pitiful creature are
you all right do you need assistance it
didn't answer it just continued to cry
had something so despondent been
responsible for this destruction the
dozens of corpses the smashed in walls
the crumbled doors and shattered Windows
it seemed impossible sure it was large
and looked strong but he had never seen
a mon monster cry before this couldn't
be a dangerous creature not when it was
so sad he would help it but first he
would attend to some of these bodies he
sat his bag on the ground and pulled out
several vials of liquid a set of
syringes and a variety of other surgical
tools he might need now after such a
long Hiatus he could resume his work in
a meaningful way he couldn't be certain
how long he worked Reviving these poor
souls and reconstructing their bodies as
the pale creature wept in the corner the
sobbing faded into the background for a
while becoming a kind of white noise as
he removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
One By One The Milky eyes fluttered open
riger mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion salow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their their words the
work was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature it didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine and give
this to the poor fellow in the corner
please it wasn't much but it should calm
him provide some relief from his
Suffering The Corpse nodded mouth
hanging loose and open an eyeball
dangling unseeing from the socket he
shuffled over to the strange creature
and held out the vial to it it turned
lifting its head and as it locked eyes
with the cured patient something shifted
in its face its mouth opened wide
impossibly wide and it shrieked that
same terrible sound as before tears
streamed from its colorless eyes its
arms shaking with unbridled rage as its
jaws locked around the patient's head
like a boa constrictor in one fluid
motion it swallowed the revived man
whole while the doctor watched in shock
he had been wrong this was not an
innocent creature caught in the wrong
place at the wrong time this creature
whatever it was was deeply sick he had
never seen such an advanced aggressive
case of the pestilence he'd heard rumors
of course but never encountered it
firsthand as a doctor he had sworn to do
no harm but in a drastic situation
drastic measures have to be taken it was
well known by himself and the doctors at
this Foundation that he could cause any
and all biological functions in an
organism to cease with a single touch
and so he approached the creature arm
out stretched ready to administer that
necessary touch to protect the rest of
his patients as he approached appr the
creature turned to him its eyes wide and
blank an endless stream of Tears pouring
from them spilling onto the floor it
shrieked again mouth stretching wide
enough to engulf his entire head and ran
toward him at a Breakneck speed I am so
sorry you are not well the doctor said
simply as his hand pressed to the
creature's chest as soon as the tough
hide of the doctor's hand which the
uninformed might mistake for gloves made
contact with the unpigmented skin of the
Beast it's eyes closed its muscles went
slack and it collapsed to the ground
with a mighty thud the doctor paced
around the Fallen creature taking in the
sight then something strange caught his
eye the creature's chest still Rose and
fell was it his imagination he checked
its pulse and thought it was slow and
faint and though it was slow and faint
it was very much present the creature
was still alive it had merely been
rendered unconscious by his touch rather
than completely deceased
curious very curious indeed he muttered
perhaps there were comorbidities present
other infections aside from the
pestilence which rendered the creature
unnaturally strong resilient to the
usual courses of treatment what would
cause these abilities this intense
aggression it seemed to be brought on
whenever someone looked at the entity's
face if only he studied psychology more
the science of the mind and its inner
workings since he had no experience with
therapy nor was he certain this creature
could communicate using language at all
there was only one way to find out more
about how this creature's brain worked
he would have to take it apart and see
for himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell he required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive Limbs and dragged the limp body
through the Halls once back in a
familiar environment his worktable ready
and waiting the doctor instructed his
assistants to place the new patient on
the table it was a bit small unable to
accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official Foundation Laboratory he risked
Discovery and subsequent Interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an IV stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision
scalpel he held out a hand and his
favorite surgical blade was placed in it
by one of the helpful patients thank you
he slid the scalpel along the hairline
of the creature or where the hairline
would be if it weren't completely bald
once the scalp was removed he set it
aside for later when it could be
reattached Bona please he held out his
hand again and again his assistant gave
him the proper tool this however was
when things got strange the doctor had
always been been a deaf hand at cutting
he'd once even received tutelage from
the great Robert Lon but no matter how
hard he tried to saw it never left a
scratch on the creature's skeleton
naturally this was somewhat frustrating
he wanted to study the creature's brain
tissue to get a sense for what was going
up there neurologically and he couldn't
do that if it was impossible to saw off
the creature's cranial cap he blunted
two of his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he' learn while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
Egyptians he produced a long curved Hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes stew all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place he was mid Stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the KNE needle
hey what are you doing he looked up to
find a guard aiming a gun at his face
excuse me I am in surgery at the moment
please do not interrupt he admonished
the guard but the man did not listen or
lower his weapon in fact he shouted
something into the radio code words the
doctor didn't recognize then he fired a
bullet into the skull of the patient
standing at his side how dare you the
doctor cried readying himself to
confront the guard but it was too late
dozens of other guards were swarming the
room and neutralizing his assistance
some in hazmat suits grabbed his arms
and pulled him away from the creature on
the operating table no matter how hard
he fought or how loudly he protested
then something incredible happened
something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly
at the guard closest to it and the two
saw one another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared Placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing at flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole I did it the doctor
shouted overcome with Elation I've cured
you now Begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous had felt to do such a good
deed meanwhile scp096 his brain regrew
within the hour and caused another
massive Containment Breach murdering a
variety of researchers and guards but
the staff agreed not to tell SCP 049
about any of this better to just let him
have this one he really seemed like he
needed a win a very strange anomaly sits
in a humanoid containment cell in the
minimum security wing of sight 17 he
walks talks and looks like a man but
everything else is convoluted in a
question mark this is SCP 343 who like
his Nam sake God is likely to cause
arguments whenever he's brought up is he
the creator of all that exists the basis
for the abrahamic faiths or is he a
pretender a reality warper with immense
power and predilection towards delusion
a courtesan of the House of madog
Matthew Methuselah Yahweh who knows
really it depends on who you ask and
which stories you choose to believe and
few people enjoy a good story more than
SCP 343 himself if one day you take the
time to visit him in his room and ask
him to reveal a page in the long book of
his personal history he might be kind
enough to tell you a story a story like
this of an encounter with something
monstrous that few others could hope to
survive meeting face to face rewind a
few thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly God as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on worn
sandals it'd been some time since he'd
seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd seen a human being not
that this bothered him he'd never been
bothered by his own company on a long
walk like this of course he could have
sped up time or teleported but where was
the fun in that he was a tourist in the
world of sensation of experience of
Flesh bone dirt blood and Sand after all
where's the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can't drop in now and
then to visit and do as the Romans do
not that the Romans would be around for
another few thousand years even Atlas
must occasionally shift the weight of
the globe from his shoulders for a ja
around the cosmic neighborhood and
whatever passes for fresh air in the
vacuum God whistled the tune to himself
it was a craggy mountainous region he'd
found himself in the distant Peaks had
Frosted caps a breathtaking place where
many truly had their breaths taken away
how humans will so happily risk their
lives to do something extraordinary it
never ceased to amaze him his stomach
rumbled oh how he enjoyed that sensation
one of the funny little quirks of this
human form that he weaved for himself it
was no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
Friendly Village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a genal
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power God had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke Rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of The
Village's Town Square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had occurred here but something
was wrong no bodies not one from
defender or a salent How could a
thriving Village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and craved that
it left even God puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on Earth he didn't have access to True
omniscience How could a mere human mind
Bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body in its skull and leave a dribbling
out of his nose and ears instead he
chose to walk around the ruins of the
village and investigate firsthand Arrow
and broken Spears and swords littered
the ground some buildings were
demolished but there were no tracks or
stray projectiles that could suggest the
presence of Siege weapons now these
buildings looked like they were ripped
apart some even still had claw marks
what terrible Beast could have set upon
this town and done this then he heard a
voice quiet and pleading beneath some
nearby rubble a Survivor he rushed over
to the pile and evaporated it with a
thought underneath a feeble old man
covered in stone dust was quivering God
helped him up and guided him into one of
the few remaining Huts still standing in
the village they both took seats God
held up two hands cradling empty space
two cups suddenly occupied that space
both filled with warm healing tea he
passed the old man one of the cups while
sipping from his own he asked the old
man if he'd seen what had happened the
old man told him no he hadn't seen
anything in decades he'd been rendered
blind in his youth little did either of
them know that very blindness was the
only reason he was the sole survivor of
the massacre the blind man told God that
one of The Village's Scouts had gone up
into the mountain with a small Hunting
Party the group was gone for days until
one of the members the youngest among
them returned weeping frostbitten and
covered in blood he said that his
friends had been killed by a beast in
the mountains something that almost look
like a man but terribly wrong and its
face its awful awful face he would never
forget it he was just lucky to escape
with his life when the others were torn
apart but when the young man returned he
brought the shadow of death with him it
was a curse that doomed the entire
Village men women and children to a
terrible fate and that fate was upon
them a mere hour after the Survivor had
returned of course of course there were
gaps in The Blind Man's understanding
given he was lacking one of his major
senses but the sounds he could describe
with perfect clarity it was faint and
distant at first that awful whale and
the Galloping hands and feet thundering
against the ground faster than any horse
could move getting closer and closer
another villager saw approaching and
screamed then it was upon them the
Villager screamed but it screamed louder
always wailing Ing and shrieking and
sobbing like a monster crawling Straight
Up From Hell people tried to fight it by
the sounds of it the blind man with
teary blank eyes recalled the sounds of
arrows knocking and swords clashing
against something but even their
greatest warriors had screamed and died
those who saw it and tried to flee and
hide were slaughtered all the same soon
enough there were only two sounds left
in the village the monster and the blind
man but both weeping he didn't
understand why it never took him it
wasn't fair it took everything else to
leave him here alive when everyone and
everything he'd ever known was destroyed
was a greater punishment than even death
after killing all of these Innocents the
monster had simply wandered off to the
mountains again the sound of its quiet
sobs getting smaller and smaller until
it was gone altogether God comforted the
blind man as he wept for the Lost of all
his loved ones he told the blind man
that he would venture up to the
mountains himself and confront the
creature on its own territory and at the
very least find out why it had done this
terrible thing but first he must
relocate the blind man to a safer place
he placed a hand on the Blind Man's
shoulder and he vanished he would appear
in another Friendly Village miles away
God sent a silent message into the minds
of every villager take good care of this
man he is has undergone Horrors you
can't even imagine your kindness will be
rewarded later for that you have my
promise God sighed and turned his tired
eyes to the distant mountains a monster
lurked up there perhaps one of his own
Creations or maybe a Corruption of one
of his Creations either way whatever
existed without his knowledge existed
without his consent and he intended to
know of the beast in the mountains
though given what he'd seen already he
didn't expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon miles away up
in the mountains the creature licked the
blood from its cracked lips it looked
like it might have once been a human
being or something that aspired to
humanity or mocked it with its very
existence it was a huge gangling Beast
skin alablaster eyes empty and soulless
dribbling rivulets of burning tears down
a hideous gaunt face it crawled into the
Frozen mouth of a cave with great icicle
fangs wheezing and weeping all it ever
wanted was to be alone why did they have
to keep interfering didn't they know
what happened all the terrible things
they made it do the creature curled its
long gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald Cranium with long sharp fingers
Terrible Things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised it turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
no he could feel it again the rage
bubbling up deep down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel it began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who I am the stranger
asked with a deep voice that betrayed
almost infinite power knowledge and
wisdom but it wouldn't change the
outcome here the monster bounded at him
at speeds that wouldn't be seen again
until jet planes and bullet TR are
invented Millennia into the future its
jaws were hanging impossibly wide fangs
borne its arms extended and deadly claws
ready to strike but before those
terrible hands could close around the
stranger he vanished the monster
stumbled and rolled across the snow
confused what trickery was being used
here I'll take that as a
no said the voice from behind him you
want to show your father some respect
more respect than you gave to those poor
people down in the village at least
seething the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness
of the cave staring at him but the Beast
didn't have the capacity for awe or holy
Terror only violence boundless Limitless
Unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting in an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger the
stranger leaped backwards put some space
between himself and the monster but
still not breaking a sweat he breathed
in deeply then exhaled the breath came
out like a mighty typhoon shocking even
the monster with its sudden force it was
blown backwards a leaf in the wind until
its Long Claws dug into the ground and
anchored it in place the stranger gave a
rise smile at this impressed my mind
you're certainly a tenacious one aren't
you he said perhaps we can talk for a
little while instead of fighting I want
to know why you killed all those people
no answer the Beast roared its Mighty
limbs pounding into the ground as it
closed the gap between itself and The
Stranger in fractions of a second it
would kill him Rend him destroy him just
like all the others he'd left it no
choice suddenly the ground below it
seemed to give way the creature was
confused it looked down to see that the
ancient stone Below had somehow taken on
the properties of a liquid and it was
sinking the Beast panicked and it began
to thrash it was a strong swimmer but it
didn't expect to need to swim here the
shock was too much and soon the ground
submerged it entirely muffling its
terrible Roars and shrieks and just like
that the ground was solid again trapping
the Beast inside the stranger stepped
forward and looked at the ground a much
needed time out he said said you do
yourself no good struggling like this
despite its terrible capacity for evil
God couldn't help but admire the beast
at least on the level of construction it
was so paired down so unburdened a
killer to the core but seemingly
unkillable had he made this creature
billions of species and the species
those in turn had created through
billions of years of breeding and
evolution and somewhere along the line
this thing happened it was easy even for
the universe's Creator to lose track of
some of the tinier variables and in the
grand scheme of things even this monster
was still a tiny variable but right here
right now it was still one hell of a
problem the ground rumbled below God
cracks formed the mountain peak shook
God raised an eyebrow genuinely
impressed as the monster ripped free of
its Stone prison and re-entered The Fray
it roared and screamed still its blank
eyes fixed on him its skeletal body
throbbed and heaved with power unlike
any other creature in nature it was
almost like the longer their conflict
went on the more energized the Beast
became God's side all those poor
villagers they never stood a chance
against this monster it lunged for him
even faster and stronger than before he
teleported out of the way in the nick of
time and the beast's claws cleav through
a nearby cave wall effortless God
materialized nearby but he didn't have
time to speak the Beast lunged again and
again and again every time he reappeared
the Beast went for him with impossible
speed deciding to widen the playing
field God teleported to the top of the
mountain the creature somehow sensing
his presence vaulted upwards and
tunneled through the roof of the cave
bursting out of the ground in front of
God who is floating just slightly off
the ground it would be wise of you to
stop God carefully in toned all this
time you know I've been going easy on
you you don't want to find out what the
wrath of God looks like storm clouds
were gathering above Mighty Thunder
roared across the sky the Beast was
undeterred it roared and galloped
towards God and God in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flow
FL could Sting the eyes from miles away
the monster shrieked from the blast
feeling its flesh lift off its bones and
atomize in the sheer heat of the
electricity around it it could smell
itself cooking the lightning blast only
lasted for a few seconds but for the
Beast it felt like eternity when the
onslaught stopped the air was still
heavy with electrical potential God
stared down at the black Scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the
creature had been standing all the snow
within a mile had been evaporated by the
blast
it was a raw display of the power of
nature that would make even Zeus tremble
in his sandals and yet there was still
movement something started to get up
from the burnt patch where nothing
should be Left Alive a blackened
skeleton rising shakily from the ash but
still very much alive as it started to
Rise new flesh began growing over its
bones little by little even God was
astonished by the sight of it he'd never
seen a creature cling so ardently to
life in spite of having truly
unsurmountable power amassed against it
it was up against God and still it
fought the monster tottered on its
freakishly long limbs still disoriented
unusually staggered for a creature
driven by such single-minded violent
purpose when enough of its face grew
back to do so it began to weep and SOB
again tears streaking down its terrible
face looking at this creature after all
of this God couldn't help but feel a new
emotion pity he lowered himself to the
ground and approached the creature like
none had ever done before he gathered it
up into his arms and he held it feeling
its heaving wretched sobs against him
the Beast was in so much pain he could
feel it radiating from within speak my
son God said in a soft fatherly voice
and for the first and only time the
monster spoke can look can
see make me H people no wonder people
can look can look
please that was all it managed to choke
out before devolving back into
unintelligible Babble but it was enough
enough for God to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost Limitless
power to Grant it one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and God said
unto the Beast rest now child rest for
thousands of years if you must I hope
only that when you eventually awaken you
feel differently and so another story
from the catalog of SCP 343 of of course
it leaves us with certain questions
Chief among them being is it true did
343 and 096 have this chance encounter
long ago or is this just another tall
tale from an anomaly who fancies himself
a deity we have our truth and you have
yours let us know what you believe Down
Below in the comments the day-to-day
routine of Dr gears consisted of a few
constants piping hot cups of black
unsweetened coffee plain dry wheat toast
post the soothing sounds of his favorite
white noise machine and the endless
Carousel of experiments with SCP 914 not
that he was complaining he was perfectly
content to spend his time supervising
one of the few anomalies he crossed
paths with on a regular basis that was
unlikely to kill or maim him in any way
not that the Clockworks hadn't produced
its fair share of unpredictable results
over the years of extensive testing it
had definitely offered up more than a
few surprises
and anyone who knew Dr gears knew that
he was not especially fond of surprises
Dr brght had attempted to throw surprise
birthday party for the man once but when
he turned on the lights and fired the
confetti cannon all Dr gears did in
response was give a deep sigh and say
really Jack you're making a spectacle of
yourself still he had resigned himself
long ago to the fact that supervising
the experiments with SCP 914 meant
witnessing some truly unpredictable
outcomes how could he for for at the
time researcher Blas tested an
incandescent light bulb on the setting
very fine and the Machine spat out an
anthropomorphic humanoid light bulb that
spoke in German accented English and
claimed to be Thomas Edison himself this
was of course impossible as historical
records surely would have indicated if
Thomas Edison was a walking talking
light bulb rather than a human man the
impostor was eventually incinerated
after its presence became too irritating
to ignore and then there was the time
researcher Thompson filled out a
Dungeons and Dragons character sheet and
placed it into the machine on the
setting very fine the output produced
was a sheet of paper promoting the
previously non-existent tabletop
roleplaying game fear in the foundation
whenever a person read the paper they
would suddenly find themselves in an
outof Body Experience where they were
inside the game's World which contained
several characters related to the SCP
Foundation as well as items and
locations based on real world
counterparts a subject in this state
would only snap back to reality after
winning or dying in the game researcher
Jacobson red the one on stealth and saw
scp096 his face in the game and was
later found dead in the anomalous item
storage Wing there was no shortage of
foundation staff trying to use the
machine for personal gain too Dr naith
placed his credit card inside on the
setting very fine using it to produce a
card covered in unidentified corporate
insignias and reading rank Alf infinite
money privileges when Dr colr issued a
written warning Dr naith took that
warning and then placed it into the
machine on the same setting producing a
piece of official documentation from the
05 Council in support of his infinite
money privileges Junior researcher
Summers attempted to use SCP 914 in a
misguided attempt at self-improvement
placing not an object but herself in the
intake Booth before running the machine
on the setting very fine it cleared her
skin lengthened her hair and improved
her figure this was was of course in
violation of several employee guidelines
and she was promptly dismissed after
emerging from SCP 914 Dr veratos left a
note in the experiment log following
this incident reading by the time we
realized what she was actually doing it
was too late to stop her needless to say
she's since been terminated and I hope I
don't need to tell you all not to do
that again and with that the guideline
was clear no one was permitted to use as
CP 914 for personal gain or to change
anything about themselves potential
complications were too risky not to
mention the conflicts of interest that
would be introduced into what should be
an impartial research process as
scientific objectivity biggest fan Dr
gears couldn't agree more so as he
settled in for the day's round of tests
he intended to keep a watchful eye on
things and ensure that no funny business
would take place he didn't have much
reason for concern as his colleague Dr
Bonita prepped her resch SE Arch
materials she was working with two items
a small replica of Michelangelo's
sculpture of David and a sealed envelope
containing something that was to be
handled with Extreme Caution a
photograph of scp096 his face she
planned to place the items inside on the
very fine setting in an attempt to see
what result might be produced from
combining an ideal of traditional beauty
standards with the image of a creature
that felt such profound shame and
distress as its own appearance that it
would destroy anyone who looked at its
face like any good scientist Dr Bonita
wanted to remove any unnecessary
variables from her experiment so as she
placed her items inside the intake Booth
she slowly delicately unsealed the
envelope she wanted to put the picture
inside by itself without the extra
element of the envelope potentially
complicating things unfortunately like
Marie curri slowly unintentionally
poisoning herself with her own research
materials she didn't truly understand
the danger of what she held in her hands
just as she was setting the photograph
down her eyes flickered to the image
before she could stop herself before she
could even look away or squeeze her eyes
shut she caught a glimpse of the one
thing she should never look at scp096
face she gasped and slammed the
photograph down but she knew it was too
late the sound of an inhuman shriek
coming from across the facility signaled
that she was right it was coming for her
and nothing in the world could stop it
in a containment cell on the other side
of the facility Foundation staff were
horrified as they heard The Telltale
scream of an enraged scp096 the pale
thin creature once huddled in the corner
silently had stretched to its full
height of 2.38 M and was screaming
sobbing wailing and gibberish and
beginning to tear its way out of its
chamber guards tried their best to do
the entity firing their weapons at it
but the bullets did nothing to damage
the creature's pale flesh or stop its
movements it ripped through the steel
Cube that contained it and knocked the
guards out of its way with one swipe of
its unnaturally long arms sending them
kening into a nearby wall fortunately
for them as scp096 only knocked them
unconscious it didn't stop to harm them
further as it had a more important goal
in mind find the person who had seen its
face and destroy them as the alarm
blared signifying a high Threat Level
containment reach scp096 loed down the
hall toward Dr Bonita in SCP 914 room Dr
gears had not spotted Dr Bonita's grave
mistake and had no idea what had
triggered the alarm he was hearing he
stepped away from the observation window
turning his attention to the crisis that
was clearly happening somewhere else in
the facility meanwhile Dr Bonita was
panicking she saw her life flash before
her eyes the certain of impending doom
that was coming for her and coming fast
all because of one brief error in
judgment what could she do there was
nowhere to hide no way she could run
away fast enough unless if she managed
to lure 096 into the intake booth and
start the machine while the creature was
inside maybe it would transform into
something less intent on tearing her
limb from limb it was a risky move and
one that could jeopardize her position
at the foundation but she couldn't very
well keep her job if she was dead so it
seemed like it just might be worth a
shot a primal Roar of Agony Fury
interrupted her thoughts and she knew
that scp096 was moments away from
breaking down the door and getting its
hands on her she would have to move fast
with a screeching grind of metal on
metal scp096 wrenched the door off its
hinges and barreled into the room and it
search for the person who had seen its
face it ran toward the silhouette of Dr
Bonita standing just at the entrance to
the intake Booth she tucked and rolled
out of the way just as the monster
entered the booth the door automatically
slid shut behind it and as scp096
rattled the door and tried to free
itself she turned the knob to very fine
with every ounce of strength and speed
she had there was a ding of a small Bell
and the Machine word to life as the
objects inside were refined Dr Bonita
had no idea what would be waiting for
her in the output booth but she could
only hope that her last ditch effort had
managed to save her life in the fog of
panic she briefly felt an itch of
scientific curiosity too what would
become of a being like scp096 in a
machine as strange and wonderful as SCP
914 what would the addition of the
statue do to it as the door to the
outtake Booth slid open Steam poured out
it appeared her questions would soon be
answered cautiously in spite of herself
Dr Bonita called out hello no one
answered but she heard the sound of
footsteps slow and careful as a figure
emerged from the Mist she covered her
mouth and shock her eyes wide dear God
she whispered in awe standing in front
of her with pale smooth skin in the same
imposing stature was the most beautiful
man she had ever seen wide dark eyes
Shone under thick sculpted eyebrows
under the eyes an aqualine nose full
pouty lips a strong sharp jaw line his
head was topped with a tangle of
lustrious dark curls was the kind of
hair she had only seen flowing in the
Wind on the covers of the romance novels
she wanted desperately to buy but was
too embarrassed to be seen purchasing
his physique was well statuesque like
the build of the very Michelangelo
sculpture she had placed into the
machine just moments ago there was no
other way to say it he was handsome
despite still being a little lanky and 9
ft tall he peered at her curiously
towering over her in a way that had been
terrifying in his former shape but now
made her heart skip a beat in an
entirely different way hi was all she
could think to say was she blushing she
shook her head snapping herself out of
it she was a scientist damn it not some
giddy school girl passing notes in class
this was an incredible achievement
something she would need to study
thoroughly and she very much wanted to
study him thoroughly nope no time for
that she needed to write up a report to
inform her superiors to try her best not
to lose her job over this she had to
remain professional hi the man that had
once been or perhaps still was as cp96
spoke oh you you can talk Dr Bonita
laughed in Surprise the man's brow
furrowed his Newfound ability to speak
was a surprise to him too it seemed yes
I can what happened to me he asked
stumbling over his his words slightly
getting used to the feeling of them you
ran into the machine she gestured to
scp-914 I'm not exactly sure to be
honest but you're very different now he
nodded I feel different I feel calm he
sighed the relief playing on his face
before a shadow of sadness fell over him
I don't think I have to hurt anymore I
I'm sorry for what I did before Dr
Bonita did not know what to say how do
you respond when something you've been
studying from afar been horrified and
fascinated by an equal measure looks at
you with a new beautiful face and
apologizes for all the harm it caused
this whole experience was so surreal
that she might think she was dreaming if
she didn't work at a place that was one
long waking dream or nightmare depending
on the day Dr Bonita there's been a
Containment Breach are you all right Dr
gears had returned to the room taking in
the sight of the destruction left in 096
his way I'm fine she called to him and
he followed her voice into the room then
stopped at the sight of the transformed
anomaly I don't have time for whatever
this is I trust you'll handle it Dr
gears took a long sip of his coffee and
taking Bonita's shock silence as
confirmation had a leisurely stroll back
to his office a few moments later the
guards responsible for containing as
scp096 arrived on the scene expecting to
see Carnage and find a docile scp096
crouched over a lifeless body but in
instead they found the same truly
bizarre site that Dr gears had Shrugged
off and Dr Bonita was still doing her
best to process they entered the room
with their weapons drawn but quickly
lowered them scratching their heads in
confusion instead before ring their
superiors and asking for further
instructions responses from various
Foundation staff who caught a glimpse of
SCP 96's bold New Look included oh would
you look at that who's that guy he's
what and in the words of Dr Jack brigh
oh oh no he's
hot Dr brgh also proposed making the new
scp096 a Tik Tok account and YouTube
channel seeking modeling representation
for him or selling a novelty calendar
filled with pictures of 096 in various
costumes these would be in his words
quote excellent ways to increase revenue
for the foundation so really you're the
weird ones now for thinking my ideas are
weird Dr brigh was asked to leave as
scp096 alone and stop trying to take his
head shot in the days that followed the
incident with SCP 9914 the SCP
Foundation was at a loss about what to
do with this new seemingly harmless
version of scp096 dozens of d-class were
brought in to look at his face and see
if the entity would still enter one of
his rage States after a few days of
getting used to his new form but he
never did no screaming no swallowing
people whole nothing more than a polite
if somewhat shy greeting and a courteous
how are you doing today the DCL class
were relieved but confused about being
pulled from their cells just to stare at
some random handsome man Dr cleff
suggested dissecting scp096 to see what
his new body looked like on the inside
this request was denied several
interviews were conducted to evaluate SC
CP 96's mental and emotional state now
that the anomaly was capable of coherent
speech it was much simpler to evaluate
the Potential Threat Level he might pose
every researcher who spoke with him came
to the same conclusion gone with the
danger of the old scp096 he had not just
become beautiful in a classical
superficial sense but he had become
beautiful on the inside as well
interviewers reported a warm friendly
demeanor a talent for engaging in
conversation once he was made to feel
comfortable and a sincere interest in
the thoughts opinions and feelings of
those he spoke with there was only one
thing left to do to make sure that
scp096 had really changed from something
deadly to something almost resembling an
ordinary person a photograph of SCP 96's
face of its original face was removed
from a Secure Vault by a d-class then
the d-class was sent into a room with
scp096 and instructed to place the
photograph on the table SC scp096 looked
down at what had once been his face and
his eyes filled with tears a soft broken
SOB left his lips and he wrapped his
arms around himself hunching over as if
in physical pain outside the room guards
prepared to handle things if 096 began
to attack instead he wiped his tears
took a deep shuttering breath and looked
at the d-class with a somber expression
he picked up the photograph on the table
and tore it in half as he finally
summoned the strength to speak please
get rid of these that is not who I am
anymore at Dr Bonita's strong insistence
backed up by the conclusions of the
research staff who interviewed scp096 a
reevaluation of of the entity's
containment measure was ordered it
seemed cruel and unnecessary waste of
resources to keep 096 trapped in a steel
cube in its current form he would be
moved to a standard humanoid containment
cell and treated as well as other safe
class anomalies provided with books
films food and drink upon request and of
course other Comforts of course the 05
Council insisted on evaluating The
Entity before any of these changes could
be approved dressed in a specially
tailored suit provided by Dr Bonita and
scp096 appeared before the council to
present his case I know that I might not
have the best record at the foundation
I've done a lot of damage over the years
though let's be honest you all aren't
exactly innocent either sorry that was
an attempt at a joke I'm still very new
to talking all I can say is please
consider giving me another chance to
make a real life here to make this place
my home thank you for your time but as
CP 096 didn't know is that the the 05
Council was so flabbergasted by the
sight of his new face that they didn't
retain a single word he said they had
all given their official approval before
he even finished his short presentation
before long scp096 was moved out of his
steel Cube and into a new containment
chamber that resembled a mid-range
studio apartment complete with a bed a
kitchenet a television and a table and
chairs he was provided access to all
major streaming platforms as well as a
large stack of books to help him develop
his grasp of culture and language after
so very long being isolated from Human
Society though he wasn't exactly human
he was determined to act like him word
quickly spread around the foundation's
site and humans and anomalies alike
flocked to SCP 96's new home to visit
him and see the miraculous
transformation for themselves SCP 999
was the first to come and see the new
and improved 096 chirping excitedly as
it oozed into his room he pet the Slime
gently his face breaking into a warm
Smile as its euphoric effect washed over
him the Slime became so excited at
meeting this new friend someone it had
known as a source of sadness and hurt
for so long that it tackled him to the
ground and tickled him for several
minutes 096 laughing uously all the
while SCP 343 stopped by to give 096 his
Blessing and wish him well in this new
chapter of Life a few days later
scp-507 popped back into the site and
wanted to see the changes for himself he
was thoroughly impressed though
privately confessed to missing 0 96's
more monstrous form which reminded him
of some of his favorite Cryptids there
was one anomaly that was not thrilled
with the appearance of scp096 however
SCP 056 was Furious upon hearing about
the new beautiful man that everyone just
couldn't shut up about it demanded a
chance to speak to S scp096 and to tell
him that this place isn't big enough for
the both of us I'm the fairest one of
all you you sniveling little worm but
the request was denied SCP 056 soed
about it for several weeks meanwhile do
Bonito was still intent on getting to
know scp096 better during previous
testing with SCP 978 the desire camera a
photo taken of scp096 revealed that his
greatest desire was to disappear curious
about the results would be now doctor
Bonita received permission to take
another picture of scp096 she snapped
the photo while 096 was sitting in a
chair in his new containment chamber
looking directly at the camera when the
photo developed the result was simple
everything in the picture was exactly
the same with one exception Dr Bonita
was pictured sitting next to 096 her
hand clasped in his both were smiling
soft contented smiles when she showed
him the photograph he smiled at her and
shook his head it really is an amazing
camera she flushed doctor before you go
could I ask your name Dr Bonita smiled
and nodded it's Isabelle what should I
call you scp096 paused thoughtfully for
a moment he was giving himself a name
for the very first time allowing himself
an identity other than a strange Hollow
pale thing that existed to cry and
suffer and hurt finally he answered her
call me David what do you do when the
sun turns wrong when light which once
represented life joy and warmth becomes
a symbol of death and destruction
do you hide inside shutter the windows
keep out the light by any means
necessary do you Retreat underground
where the sun's Rays cannot penetrate
burrowing into the dark and the cold do
you simply give yourself to it accepting
that there is no escaping something so
vast so far reaching as sunlight itself
and allow yourself to be lost in the end
of all things we've covered this
possibility before SCP 001 F when day
breaks or SD Lock's proposal it's
difficult to know what any given person
might do in such harrowing circumstances
after all we have always learned to love
the light and fear the darkness it turns
our very understanding of reality upside
down to have that Paradigm shifted the
dark becoming safety and the light
becoming death the source of all life on
Earth of all warmth transforming in an
instant from the Sun as we we know it to
a Napoleon class SCP that melts all
living organisms that cross into its
gaze but what about a being that has
always feared the light something that
prioritizes Solitude and never ever
wants to be seen how might it live out
those darkened days today we're taking a
look at what happens when Daybreak meets
a familiar face even if a constantly
hidden one scp096
scp096 or the shy guy is something of a
celebrity around here it is a humanoid
creature with long distended arms pale
skin and a jaw that can open four times
wider than an ordinary humans there is
only one thing above all else that this
entity desires for no one to see its
face when someone views its face it
flies into an uncontrollable rage and
seems to have no other option but to
destroy the person who has seen it so it
is unlikely that a creature so intent on
Solitude would be in much Danger from
the transformed sun in fact it might
even be a positive thing and for some
time it was with so many human beings
gone reduced to gelatinous masses with
no desire but to Slither around in the
ghoulish sunlight and merge with one
another there were fewer people to
observe his face than ever he could stay
inside and know with almost complete
certainty that no one would come to
bother him no one was coming to look at
him and there were no more visitors
researchers poking and prodding that
might sneak a look at his face and so he
stayed there in the room that had served
as his containment unit before the world
turned upside down the masses of Flesh
that once were humans did not concern
him as they never looked at his face all
he did was stay in his room and never go
outside the outside frightened him
terribly though he was not concerned
with the Dead sunlight or the
possibility of it melting him as it had
so many others he was much more afraid
that someone some unlikely Survivor
clinging to their original life might
look at him that they might see his face
that was simply too distressing to risk
he would much rather stay alone in his
old cell weeping softly in the shadows
one day though we couldn't say how many
days after the end of things it had been
he was weeping alone in his former cell
the days blurred together spent the same
way and time had lost much of its
meaning through the echoing sound of his
sobs and the sloshing sounds of the
creatures outside a woman's voice cut
through it was faint but he could make
out what she was saying she was calling
out for help asking if anyone had any
food or fresh water the sound was
getting louder closer accompanied by the
disconcerting thump of her footsteps she
was coming down the hall as much as it
could be called a hall anymore she was
coming towards his room to disrupt his
miserable peace he heard her steps cross
the threshold of his room and her voice
broke into a terrified scream no doubt
at the unexpected sight of a pale naked
creature weeping in the corner of what
she expected to be an empty room
startled by the first loud sound he'd
heard in a long time in a world that had
mostly been silent since the initial
outpouring of agonized Screams had faded
into the soft slap of Flesh and SL CL on
the ground he turned around he shouldn't
ordinarily he wouldn't but he couldn't
stop himself there he saw a woman wide
eyes filled with tears face streaked
with dirt a small child next to her
holding her hand and clinging to her leg
just as he saw the woman she saw him she
saw his face anger boiled over inside of
him and he let out a scream wild Primal
and filled with inhuman rage age she
could not be looking at him seeing his
face he couldn't let her the woman ran
with the child in toe panicked by the
wild Roar and the sight of him standing
upright before her the anger faded as
she left his sight making her way down
the hall into the stairs but then he
remembered she had seen his face he
could not let her leave it was time to
do something he never thought he'd have
to do again hunt his heightened sense
picked up the sound of muffled footsteps
coming up through the floor below him
she was downstairs just beneath the
floor where he was standing his
instincts kicked in and his body moved
almost of its own accord he lifted his
long long arms above his head and drove
his hands down into the floor it was
weakened by the ravages of the elements
and time and crumbled under his
unnatural strength he dug his claws into
the plaster tearing it apart and
cracking it into pieces
he pushed his claws in deeper and deeper
until he could feel them breaking
through the other side he pulled the
floor apart until the hole was wide
enough to fit through then dropped down
to the room below he spotted the woman's
back fleeing through the door just as he
landed she was getting away he tore
after her ripping through concrete and
steel destroying everything in his path
in a Mad Dash for the object of his rage
he had to catch her she could not be
allowed to leave she looked over her
shoulder at him her face a mask of pure
Terror she knew just as he knew that
there was no Escape in sight in his
single-minded obsession and her
desperation to escape from him neither
of them noticed that she had run so far
and so carelessly that she was now
outside the building she had crossed
from the Shadows into the harsh light of
the Sun the woman's eyes widened in Grim
understanding of her fate he could only
watch helplessly as her body began to
succumb to the vicious Rays almost
instantly she began to melt as it was
closest to the Sun her head was the
first to go her nose drooped like hot
wax dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground
with a sickening Splash her eyes were
next popping out of their sockets and
hanging loose and Limp on her cheeks and
dangling from siney strands she tried in
vain to stuff them back into into place
but they squished in her hands like
overripe fruit she attempted to run into
the comparative safety of the ruined
building but her feet were already
beginning to spread out onto the street
melting into a sticky red smear on the
pavement her legs crumbled beneath her
and she collapsed to the ground her face
leaving a trail of gelatinous Flesh as
it landed she tried uselessly to drag
herself along the ground back into the
darkness but her arms were melting into
the dirt mixing with it into a horrible
red mud she let out a last scream of
Agony but the sound turned to a thick
gurgle as her lips fused together and
her mouth melted into nothingness he
watched it all sobbing and roaring in
frustration she was gone and he would
never get the satisfaction of ending her
The Infernal son had stolen her from him
now she was nothing but a wet Shadow
like the rest of the humans had become
long ago go he heard the sound of a soft
SOB behind him a tiny human voice he
turned looking for the source there was
the little girl he had almost forgotten
about her she was calling out for her
mother and crying and she was looking
right at him right at his face he waited
for the anger to overtake him but
instead there was nothing why wasn't he
angry she was looking at his face so why
then he realized her eyes were on him
but but she did not see him she was
blind she approached the creature her
arms outstretched following the sound of
his crying she touched his hand with her
own tiny fingers so small and fragile
and asked Mommy then he felt something
he had never felt before tenderness care
a desire to protect this tiny innocent
being it was the first time he had ever
felt warm ever felt anything but sadness
anger or fear
overcome with this softness he wrapped
his arms around the child and hugged her
close she hugged him back tightly and
the room went quiet as they both stopped
crying from that day on they became a
family of sorts they lived together and
he took care of her she didn't know what
he looked like and had no idea he might
be something to fear to her he was
safety he was home for the first time in
his long awful life he felt like a human
Human Instead of a monster he would
scavenge food for her bring her fresh
water lay down stolen blankets and
pillows so she would have a soft place
to rest he even found her a ratty worn
teddy bear amongst the rubble and gave
it to her as a gift she clutched it to
her chest and thanked him and for once
his tears were those of joy in this
cursed World they had found something
like happiness in one another he knew he
would protect her no matter what then
one day day everything changed the
creature and the little girl were
playing in the abandoned sight making up
little games together when he took a
break to look out at the window and
monitor their surroundings outside the
evil Red Sun waited when he turned back
the little girl was gone one of the
shadowy creatures once human was
imitating his voice to lure her away he
could hear it in the distance and her
tiny footsteps following it he chased
after her the only thing he had ever
loved and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light she screamed as one
of her arms began to melt in the light
and he knew what he had to do he grabbed
her and pulled her back inside using his
body to Shield her from the horrible
Rays as he wept over her his tears
stopped her body from melting any
further but his body continued to fall
apart it was too late for him he ran as
far as he could once he transformed he
did not want to end up hurting the the
girl he ran until his legs melted away
and he could not run anymore he had
reached the shoreline and stared out at
the ocean unable to move anymore he
screamed a final time in agony in
heartbreak in mourning for the happiness
he had finally found and now would lose
but at least he knew as his eyes melted
away and he was nearly gone that the
girl would be safe and then he was gone
and the world was quiet Dr Dan anxiously
paced in his cell it was the only way
he'd been able to occupy himself for the
past 6 months save for pouring through
files and when he was lucky being able
to oversee another failed termination
attempt he only stopped pacing when for
a brief and horrible moment he realized
that monster was probably doing the
exact same thing in its big metal cube
at this very moment that horrible
creature that he' thrown away his life
for a feudal shot at killing perhaps the
whole thing had been a Fool's errand
after all he was formerly a researcher
under the employ of the SCP Foundation
secure contain protect they had truly
sadistic beasts like SCP 106 the
nightmarish old man and SCP 352 Baba
Yaga in containment cells and there was
no plans to terminate either of them
they weren't the global ult Coalition
for three 43's sake why did Dr Dan even
want to terminate scp096 in the first
place he tried to explain it to them
again and again but his pleas had fallen
on deaf ears in his mind the impetus for
destroying the shy guy was terrifyingly
clear it was a monster that killed
anyone or anything that looked at its
face even a photograph of it even a tiny
collection of pixels when its rage state
was induced it seemed that nothing would
stop stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find
its Zen again once all of them were dead
and if a picture of scp096 was leaked
onto the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
prayed upon on the inherent curiosity
and thirst for knowledge seated in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in as many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp096
his face would be leaked online perhaps
a few hundred people across the globe
would look in disperate enough locations
that it would be almost impossible for
the foundation to detect and save all of
them as scp096 went on its bloody
Rampage of course as the image
proliferated as images on the internet
often do the purview of 0 96's violence
would only grow people across the nation
would start to take notice and soon
after that across the world mysterious
creature causing Mass casualties would
be the headline on every news desk
because why would anybody want to talk
about anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong we're refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that SC
scp096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp096 he was simply told to get back to
working on those goggles it was why he
needed to give those naysayers a
demonstration it was why a certain
photograph needed to show up in the home
of a certain Mountaineer it's why all
those people had to die there was no
other way the deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the mobile task
force members were of course regrettable
but it was the only way to prevent the
deaths of so many more they gave him
what he wanted permission to put this
gangly time bomb in the ground even if
the beast's death was inextricably tied
to his own execution at the hands of the
very employers who authorized him the
world was full of funny little ironies
like that another one is that even
though Dr Dan now had the authorization
and funding to terminate SCP 096 he was
discovering that he lacked another
important factor the capability they
tried incinerating it exposing it to
massive amounts of radiation exposing it
to an insane degree of kinetic trauma
the equivalent of being hit by an outof
control bullet train they tested every
kind of experimental off-the books
Weaponry that they had access to through
various research projects proton blasts
lasers high-intensity energy beams
nothing even when they fried off every
scrap of Flesh on the monster's body its
unbreakable skeletons still remained and
in what seemed like no time at all it'd
be back in Action its very existence
seemed to mock him a guard opened his
cell door staring disdainfully at the
disgraced researcher that same guard had
slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier one of his friends had
apparently been killed in the legendary
096 Containment Breach that set this
whole sworded thing thing in motion up
and Adam scumbag he said in a Gruff
sirly voice training a handgun on the
doctor he knew wouldn't fight back they
need you in test chamber six Dr Dan
allowed himself a small grin
imperceptible to the guard who clearly
hated his guts they had approved his 096
versus 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in a long
line of 68 two cross tests he thought it
Darkly funny in his eyes the foundation
had no hope of ever killing SCP 682 its
defining quality was being impossible to
kill and it didn't present nearly the
threat to the entire world that 096
posed their futile attempts to murder
the lizard were little more than a money
sync to justify the site's exorbitant
funding but perhaps he could turn this
to his benefit maybe SCP 682 would hold
the secret to actually killing off his
Nemesis within 30 hours Dr Dan had his
disappointing answer both anomalies had
undeniably done a real number on each
other and Dr Dan did take a kind of sick
Amusement in the mental trauma that SCP
682 had induced in
096 but ultimately it was all for
nothing 682 had skin 096 alive and
melted off its flesh with acid but once
again that indestructive skeleton stood
firm this had been the 27th termination
attempt since the incident the 27th
failed termination attempt Dr Dan
mentally corrected himself 0 96's
skeleton kept defeating them even their
most Ardent attempts to penetrate the
bones and destroy the creature within
had failed during a previous attempt
they tried to access the brain by
putting a diamond hard drill into its
eye sockets of course it was the drill
that actually broke much to Dr Dan's
seemingly tireless frustration needless
to say in the debriefing interview with
Dr Carver a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague he
wasn't in High Spirits if he managed to
kill this thing then he would always be
the hero who made a terrible sacrifice
in order to save many more lives if he
didn't kill 096 he was little more than
the monster who murdered all those
innocent people for nothing though you'd
never hear him say it at out loud if it
wasn't for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him SCP 173 the sculpture a sight
19 icon often overlooked because of its
more silent but deadly style but
undeniably one of the most frightening
and dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at 19 in
1993 one broken neck at a time and it's
one of the few creatures out there that
even the hard to destroy reptile himself
is utterly terrified of perhaps a
monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the shy guys
vertebrae once his proposal was greenlit
for initial testing Dr Dan arranged for
the shy guy with a bag over his head of
course to be brought into a testing
chamber with the ever sto SCP 173 when
all the researchers and guards were
safely outside all it took was a single
blink to make all of Dr Dan's darkest
dreams come true in the Nan seconds his
eyes were closed he heard the most
beautiful sounds in the world a loud
fleshy Crunch and a pained howl from
096 he opened his eyes to an equally
wondrous sight 096 doubled over at an
unnatural angle its spine snapped
between the fourth and fifth vertebrae
spinal fluid leaking down the creature's
flank that freaky little sculpture had
done it it had actually damaged the
Integrity of the shy guy skeleton it was
at that moment that Dr Dan knew he could
kill this thing admittedly there was a
Containment Breach shortly after that
when the bag slipped off of 0 96's head
and it charged through the nearby steel
wall killing multiple people before
being subdued and recontained but when
it comes to projects involving Dan a
mere handful of innocent people being
killed sits comfortably within the
acceptable margin of error a day later
Dr Dan was standing before a crowded
boardroom with agents researchers and
even a few members of the 05 Council in
attendance he explained his findings to
them and the fact that even more
importantly they may have a way to bring
The Wretched existence of 096 to an
absolute halt his plans were approved
not long after
he was putting them into motion Dr Dan
was surrounded by researchers and
heavily armed guards as 173 was escorted
into the test chamber with a forklift
096 was there still bagged off to the
side was a giant tub of hydrop Floric
acid connected to a hose and injector
attachment if this didn't work nothing
would everyone stood back in a safe Zone
as 173 was released to do its thing
crunch just like the previous time 0
96's spine had been successfully snapped
spinal fluid dribbled down its skin
everyone had rushed into the chamber one
group kept 173 isolated with their
stairs the other headed by Dr Dan
prepared the acid injector and shoved it
into the breach in 0 96's spine as the
acid was pumped by the gallon into 0
96's Bones the creature let out the most
horrifying whale it kicked and bucked as
more acid was pumped in melting in those
indestructible Bones from within the
creature even began to vomit acid as it
panicked melting the bag off of its own
head some panicked and averted their
gaze Dr Dan didn't he stared directly at
the creature's face for the first time
as it melted in front of him with
nothing short of Pur relation had he won
had he actually won the creature let out
a gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monsters melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and shrieked they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a mad man even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won he's
waiting for you in the dark he sits
cross-legged still as a Placid Lake and
patient as a Praying monk 6 ft deep in
meditation he's been like this for so
long his body oil slicked with deadly
black grease skin ancient and Haggard
eyes black and flat with the kind of
calm you would only find in crawling
insects and great white sharks his
lipless mouth is stretched across his
Jawbone in an ugly black Rus he may be
an old man but trust us he's got plenty
of New Tricks he'd love to show you he
sat in the lonliest place in the world
the deep dark bowels of an SCP
Foundation containment site surrounded
by a complex Confluence of containment
measures different shapes running
liquids Bright Lights the kind of Steel
so thick a nuclear weapon would only
leave it scuffed all the things that had
a tendency to confuse him because that's
all they ever did the old man laughed to
himself very quietly all the people out
there are so scared of him because of
one immutable fact he isn't trapped here
he's just resting by virtue of his
unique anomalous ability ities to pass
through solids at will and resist any
form of physical damage they can dull
out there is no way to really contain
him like all the others all the SCP
Foundation could hope to do was make
leaving inconvenient enough for him to
make his little adventures on the
outside less appealing than just sitting
around doing nothing after all he had
all the time in the world when you
always have a later there's a lot less
pressure to do anything now but like all
all thinking creatures and Please be
aware that
scp-106 The Wretched terrifying old man
is very much a thinking creature he was
subject to occasional boredom and when
most people are bored they might play a
video game watch a few YouTube videos or
re-watch It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia for the fifth time but for
the old man killing boredom involved
well killing people but not just killing
people of course truth be told for him
killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole Affair
the screams the begging the desperate
pleas warm tears on shaking cheeks
convulsions of pain cold sweats fear so
intense it gives way to gibbering
Madness the dull Sheen of dead hope in
their eyes when they realize that their
Doom is inevitable and that he their
captor their torturer would decide the
exact moment they slip into the void oh
that that was what he lived for if you
could call what the old man did living
He cracked his neck and licked his teeth
was he salivating all those thoughts
about pain seemed to have got him worked
up he could feel the distant thumping of
his heart old black blood pumping
through the dusty corridors of his
vascular system synapses booming and
sparking with excitement at the thought
of Plumbing new depths of human misery
like a scholar of suffering a pioneer of
pain all those silly Foundation drones
with the audacity to think they're in
control he'd teach them to scream again
meanwhile in the room for the old man's
containment chamber all hell was
breaking loose monitors on the monster's
vitals were all spiking heart and brain
activity peaked just as they always did
before the old man decided to get active
cameras in his containment chamber
showed him Rising steadily to his feet
cracking his joints limbering up his
body started to produce that terrible
corrosive mucus at an accelerated rate
cooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted
into the floor years of foundation
testing and they still couldn't find any
material that could withstand that vile
black sloth as the old man began
strolling towards the wall a containment
specialist in the control room grabbed a
nearby phone and sounded the alarm for
the Containment Breach they needed a
mobile task force and every guard on
site mobilized to tackle 106 before he
got into the facility proper and started
causing Havoc they couldn't risk it
escaping either the infamous incident
when the old man escaped for a Halloween
Massacre still haunted the nightmares of
many a staff member he had to be stopped
now a small fighting force was quickly
armed and assembled along with armor and
several high-intensity portable lights
to hopefully slow the monster down in
time for them to grab a decline class
and set up the femur Breaker by the time
they all reached the hallway they
intended to use as a choke point for the
escape the old man was already halfway
through the outer layer of Defense
phasing through the wall with that same
terrible manic grin he always had when
he was about to inflict terrible
violence for the sheer fun of it the
guards and task force members trained
their lights and weapons on him all of
them had seen terrible things on the job
the kind of things that would saddle
almost anyone with a lifetime of trou
but almost nothing compared to the
horror of direct engagement during a 106
Containment Breach that terrible old
coffin Dodger was hell on two legs when
they discovered to their horror that the
lights didn't seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated they fell
back on Plan B that b standing for blast
the living hell out of him with
everything they had the Personnel opened
fire pumping round after round into his
dark form while Lee gave a loud meaty
splatter the old man didn't even Flinch
when he was close enough all those
months of lethargy gave way to sudden
deadly speed in many ways the old man
was like a crocodile a Fierce and
intelligent Ambush Predator who
conserved his energy wisely he could
seem so deceptively languid that you
could easily mistake him for something
slow and harmless but when you got
within Arm's Reach the sudden quickness
and ferocity would take you off guard
and by then it's already too late within
30 seconds the old man was the only
thing left alive in that hallway all the
guards and task force operative sent to
slow him down lay dead dripping with his
black mucus there was silence save for
The Quiet fizzing of the mucus eating
into their clothes and skin the old man
sighed how boring he'd killed so many
people now it all started to seem a
little syy how many screams could you
hear before they all just blended into a
single shrill wine you can get sick of
even your favorite meal if you eat it
too often but that didn't matter the old
man had a different order of business
today he happened to be inside an SCP
Foundation containment facility filled
with so many fascinating specimens of
nonhuman entities that the one they
called
scp-106 simply couldn't wait to torture
he'd only met a small portion of the
ones they had contained here but given
what a fascinating experience his past
attack on his fellow anomalies was he
couldn't wait to meet some more
meanwhile the sight's top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second
response to the Rogue senior citizen
from Hell currently strolling through
their high security containment facility
could they get in contact with other
mobile task forces deployed in the area
maybe they could get hammer down or
samsara in on this mess before anything
got really out of hand the old man
seemed more intent on something this
time they suspected even the femur
breaker might not work in luring him
back until he claimed whatever he deemed
to be his prize maybe they should
contact the 05 Council security guards
were tracking 106's progress through the
facility via their vast networks of
security cameras they warned any
research Administration and janitorial
staff to clear out of his path unless
they felt like being tortured to death
he hadn't dragged anyone into his pocket
Dimension yet so whoever that privilege
was reserved for would probably be
getting a particular sticky experience
they could only speculate as to the
silent BEAST's intentions one guard
notice something when cross referencing
106's movements with a map of the
facility they were able to triangulate
where he was heading straight for the
containment chamber of scp096 the
guard's lips curled into a slight smile
thinking if one of you freaks can
actually kill the other maybe something
positive Will Come Out of This Disaster
the old man was having a stroll down
memory lane the time prior when he broke
out of his cell and decided to hassle
his fellow inmates was certainly
eventful he wound up in the company of
some krous reptile and a Korean foxw
woman an unlikely pair if ever there was
one after finding himself in a room with
them he decided they should have a
little more privacy and dragged them
back into his pocket dimension for
further fun of course with two at once
his attention had been a little split
they spent as much time tussling with
each other as resisting his attempts to
torment them they definitely put him
through his Paces that day and he gave
far better than he got after so many
hours of brutal mutilation there was
barely any of the lizard left despite
its frustrating insistence on quickly
healing from so many of its wounds still
it was good exercise even if the results
had been a little less than satisfying
if he could get another anomaly alone
though he'd be able to take his time and
really Savor the pain he caused oh that
sounded Heavenly soon he came upon an
incredibly strange containment chamber
that quickly caught his eye it looked
like a huge metal cube with no way in or
out not even a seam whatever was trapped
in there the old man thought it must be
something that even the fools at the SCP
Foundation really truly wanted nothing
to do with but even more so than the
strange sight it was the s sound that
Drew the old man in tempting him like a
siren song it was weeping a soft sobbing
Keen that betrayed a bottomless well of
misery whatever was making that crying
sound had known true despair or whatever
passes for True despair before you've
had a close encounter with the old man
in his pocket Dimension the old man
grinned and thought Oh Sunny I'll give
you something to really cry about he
stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube the creature was in the
corner in contrast to that stupid lizard
this monster was pleasingly humanoid
with presumably all the familiar pain
points Splendid the only real difference
was color and proportion it was far
longer and gangli than the average human
with grayish skin and no hair anywhere
on its body still it was something the
old man could work with the creature
didn't even seem to register his
presence it just sat crumpled in the
corner weeping still grinning his
lunatic grin The Old Man approached and
rested a moist hand on the creature's
shoulder its pale skin began to fizzle
from the intruder's corrosive touch a
pool of vile sludge began spreading out
beneath his feet until the creature was
encompassed too little by little they
sank into the old man's favorite place
out of the world the pocket Dimension
his own personal Eternal infinite
dungeon where the only laws are pain and
Terror for all but the old man himself
little did he know this time the scores
may be a little more even on that front
they both stood in that terrifying
Labyrinth of hallways and Chambers where
the old man had made countless lives
infinitely worse than any terrible
afterlife that could follow them and
still this creature didn't seem to
change its reaction he was almost
irritated by it and what's more this
whole time the creature hadn't even
turned to look at him he'd have to fix
that too the the old man with his
shocking strength gripped the monster's
shoulder and whipped him around staring
into his face bearing his black eyes and
manic smile but he couldn't help find
what looked back at him
disconcerting its eyes were blank and
white its face stretched and warped into
a permanent Grimace like Munch's old
painting The Scream and the second the
old man laid eyes on it that's exactly
what it did its gaping mouth let out the
most terrible whale the old man had ever
heard in all his years of torturing it
was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear but somehow the old man sensed that
this creature didn't fear Him it feared
itself feared what it was about to do
what the hell had he dragged down here
with him without warning the terrible
whales soon gave way to sudden and
ferocious aggression just like the old
man had dealt out to a group of
foundation guards and mobile task force
agents earlier that same night it was
only out of of a mix of pure luck and
his own finely tuned animal Instinct
that the old man was able to dodge the
first strike from the creatur's long LIF
forelimb he couldn't believe it they
were in his special place and this
victim of his had the audacity to fight
back well he'd soon put this monster in
its place as the monster continued
roaring and swiping for him the Old Man
simply walked backwards into a nearby
wall and disappearing into a black stain
of course the monster better known to
the foundation as scp096 or the shy guy
simply crashed through the wall to give
Chase but on the other side just another
wall he disappeared how typically when
something sees the face of the shy guy
he immediately has a kind of intuitive
connection to them he can sense their
presence it's burned into his mind a
homing Beacon an Unstoppable imperative
he knows exactly where they are and how
to get them but nothing about this
situation was typical the shy guy felt
all the murderous rage he normally did
but the rest was just static where was
the life he needed to abolish hiding
suddenly the old man emerged behind him
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy's
back his fist melted straight through
flesh and skin causing the creature to
let out another terrible whale but as
could be expected they didn't leave a
scratch on the shy guys's indestructible
skeleton the shy guy pulled the 180 and
swung for the old man again but he was
already gone here in the in the pocket
Dimension the old man had the ultimate
home turf Advantage here space and time
were his play things in the infinite
twisting Labyrinthian walls of the
pocket Dimension the old man wasn't just
the devil he was God too but it would
take far more than some cheap tricks and
bodily harm to dissuade the shy guy from
his sole purpose in life he began
running through the old man's personal
maze like a crazed labat tearing through
wall after wall forever searching for
the monster that trapped it here it
would see the smiling face of that
rotten old man every so often the flash
of black eyes and dirty teeth and
shadows but every time it tried to
strike the Shadows there would be
nothing there and every time he got a
chance the old man would emerge from the
Shadows behind the shy guy to strike
back clawing into his flesh and
Vanishing again before the trapped Beast
could retaliate the nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun it was a
reflex test a classic game of high
stakes whacka and every time the
creature failed to strike him its
distress only seemed to grow this was
perfectly fine for the old man after all
he enjoyed a little mental torment as
much as he loved physical torture and a
human would have died or given in to
despair long before now this Monster's
wonderful mix of resilience and pain
made it a great chew toy the old man
kept up this routine baiting and
striking until something unanticipated
happened he appeared waited for the
swing appeared as it approached then
reappeared behind the shyy to deliver
another painful strike this time however
it seemed his victim had anticipated his
pattern before he could hit the creature
the shy guy turned quicker than anything
the old man had ever seen and hit him
with such Force he flew through several
walls in his own maze shattering them as
he went he hit the ground stunned by the
fact that the shy guy had actually
landed a hit but he wasn't done the
shrieking monster came bounding after
him before the old man could stand it
struck him again and again and again
pounding his vile body into the ground
which cracked and crumbled the old man
sneered and sank into a puddle of his
mucus on the ground the old man was gone
again SC scp096 screamed in a mix of
Rage Despair and frustration so consumed
with its hunt that it didn't notice the
pool of corrosive mucus was slowly
growing it began to rise bubbling and
hissing at SCP 96's feet getting deep
deeper and deeper and deeper as the
walls Rose taller and taller around it
the creature wailed until a tide of the
awful stuff reached its face and
cascaded down its throat melting all the
organs within as the creature was fully
submerged scp1 06 manifested at top the
wall and looked down smiling spitefully
he thought oh you may have had me there
boyo but in the end I always win nothing
could survive surv that and yet bubbles
still Rose from the slop below the old
man gritted his rotten teeth and baled
his fists in quiet anger moments later
back in our Dimension a portal opened in
the ground of SCP 96's Containment
chamber it vomited out scp096 is
skeleton smothered in bubbling black goo
and SCP 106 096 would probably be fully
regenerated within a couple of hours and
if 682s encounter with him was anything
to go by probably extremely unwilling to
interface with the old man and the old
man himself who couldn't help but feel a
little humiliated by the whole
experience was glad the two of them
would probably never meet again he left
the regenerating 096 and commenced the
Walk of Shame back to his containment
chamber they didn't even need the femur
breaker he just felt like having a sit
down and processing it all nobody else
would ever know what happened in the
pocket Dimension that day and for the
old man's Pride that was probably for
the best but he'd know he'd always know
by the night's end he was sitting in his
containment chamber again forlornly
wondering God damn it oldtime have you
lost your Edge what does a monster look
like to you what figures Slither and
Claw their way into your nightmares
chasing you down endless halls and
stalking you through the dark until you
wake up screaming maybe you imagine
something tall and lean bony arms
reaching for you from a top impossibly
long slender legs its featureless face
showing no mercy maybe you think of a
man in a striped sweater with knives for
fingers or a serial killer in a hockey
mask wielding a machete maybe it's
something more inhuman a cosmic horror
of tentacles and eyes that can see into
your very Soul you probably don't think
of something with no arms no legs no
body at all just a face What's So Scary
About That a face can't run after you
can't grab you by the ankles and pull
you under the bed a face can only look
it may be unsettling to behold it might
send a chill down your spine but the
worst it can do is make you a little
uncomfortable and if you can't stand it
any longer you could always just close
your eyes or walk away and be done with
it right
if that's what you think if you don't
believe in monsters that can hurt you
without lifting a finger then you're the
type to fall victim to a very special
very intelligent mask in the hollowed
Halls of the SCP Foundation there is a
containment cell outfitted with a
hermetically sealed glass case
surrounded by steel iron and Lead there
are guards posted outside along with a
trained psychologist if you are ever
Brave and foolish enough to enter that
room you'll see a simple white porcelain
comedy mask with a peculiar black
substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth whatever this slime touches
surfaces begin to corrode to rot away
into puddles of black liquid you might
notice the same liquid trickling slowly
down the walls of the room corrupting
everything in its path as unsettling of
a sight as it is if you approach The
Mask to take a closer look you will find
yourself overcome by an intense nearly
irresistible urge to pick it up and put
it on to wear it to let it consume you
from the inside out and puppet your body
while your brain simply turns off like
an extinguished flame you'll simply be
gone then who knows what the mask will
do it won't be your concern anymore
that's for sure but thankfully you
haven't gone into the room with the
porcelain mask you haven't let It cast
its spell on you not yet at least it's
waiting for you there in the room with
black slime oozing down its walls and it
will wait patiently for as long as it
needs to after all what's a mask without
a face to wear it SCP 035 better known
as the possessive mask sat in its
containment cell immobile as always it
didn't really have much of a choice in
the matter the foundation had chosen
selfishly to revoke its host privileges
once upon a time they offered it bodies
to choose from mannequins dummies and
wooden dolls that could Adorn and pilot
they didn't last as long as an organic
living host of course but it was
something it was a taste of Freedom this
Dreadful news situation was almost
enough to make the mask want to change
its surroundings this Dreadful new
situation was almost enough to make the
mask want to change its expression from
Comedy to tragedy but it was determined
to still find something to laugh about
even without a body trapped in this
infernal box there had been some
delicious opportunities for
entertainment human Minds were fragile
things the mask had learned this over
the infinite years of its life if one
could call it a life apply the right
kind of pressure to the right weak
points whisper an enticing word or two
find the right emotional wound to
sprinkle a pinch of salt into and humans
would Buckle completely in almost no
time at all it had tried all sorts of
methods since being confined to this
boring little box sometimes it would
charm someone pour honeyed flattery into
their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend a confidant
once suitable trust had been built up
the mask could persuade the person to
bring it a host or perhaps even offer up
themselves in sacrifice if flattery
didn't work there were other potent
approaches to take for a being without
ears the mask was a good listener it
picked up on things that no human ever
could the darkest Secrets buried in a
person's mind if it caught wind of
something especially juice and ruinous
it could leverage that threatened to
expose an affair a crime or perhaps
something even worse something
unspeakable if praise failed and so did
blackmail there was always good old
Supernatural intimidation all the mask
needed was for someone to be left alone
with it for a long enough period of time
then its invisible tendrils could snake
out into their defenseless mind weaving
and poking around leaving a lingering
sense of cold dread of incomprehensible
Whispers in Long dead tongues what a
delight containment had been in the
early days when the foundation had not
yet figured out the masks true
capabilities when they would leave
security personnel with weak wills and
minimal training standing guard in The
Mask field of influence for hours at a
time
as the entity played with their thoughts
and chipped away at their free will
thanks to the helpers that had been able
to mold out of those hapless victims
they had been there to break open its
case and carry it to freedom but every
time the other guards thed the attempts
shooting its helpers and rendering them
utterly useless then the foundation
increased its security something about
the unacceptably high homicide rates
among staff assigned to a
cp035 how utterly boring how truly
pathetic still The Mask had found ways
to occupy itself even without any more
play things it had grown stronger with
its boredom stretching its influence
Beyond Organic beings and into the very
room itself its evil enriching and
deepening like a fine wine in the depths
of a cold cellar over the months the
walls of SCP 035 is containment cell had
begun to secrete the same black slimy
substance that would pour from the
mask's eyes and mouth the liquid dripped
Down the Walls in deliberate formations
patterns that became increasingly easy
to recognize phrases in Italian Latin
ancient Greek all detailing ritual
sacrifices and mutilations The Mask took
time to describe the sacrificial victims
in great detail borrowing identifying
traits from various staff members that
it knew would read the translations the
walls were slick with blood and
harrowing imagery and the glass case
around the mask was growing more and
more Fragile by the day anyone within 10
m of the Mask could feel this strength
too they would leave the area
complaining of unintelligible Whispers
of loud cruel laughter and a lingering
sense of nearly insurmountable despair
it was as if they knew on some level
that no one was truly safe eventually
The Mask would find a way to come for
them all the glass was weakening and
soon the mere thought of Escape would
make it shatter into pieces then perhaps
The Mask could finally get its deepest
desire
Revenge it wanted nothing more than to
try to make the foundation pay for
imprison ing it for taking away its host
privileges for trying harder and harder
to contain the kind of power that should
have had them falling to their knees in
worship the mask seeed with hatred day
in and day out it had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire the beheading of
Kings the decimation of armies it was
not going to be captured by a bunch of
rats in labcoats without ding
consequences befalling them maybe it
couldn't move from its prison cell at
the moment but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous
beasts capable of reducing the sight and
all who had dared to oppose the mask to
a pile of smoldering Rubble if it could
only find its way onto one of their
faces it would show them all just what
it was capable of as the piercing sound
of an alarm echoed down the hall the
sound of Screams and Chaos following
shortly after the mask's frowning face
curved into a broad menacing smile what
was it that had escaped the lizard
perhaps the giant grinning man whatever
it was it seemed that the action was
heading right toward 035 containment
cell perhaps today was the day finally
the SCP Foundation would fall
outside the mask cell security officer
Harper was running for dear life though
his more rational mind knew he was
living on seconds not even minutes of
borrowed time his animal brain kept his
legs pumping desperately trying to avoid
the screaming howling Predator Hot on
his heels Harper looked over his
shoulder and screamed as a long white
arm reached for him scp096 the shy guy
its tooth line jaw hanging low and
foaming with spittle that face that
terrible terrible face an absolute death
sentence to all who saw it he'd seen
what he thought was a crack in the
otherwise perfect seal of 0 96's
containment chamber but it could have
just as easily been a trick of the light
not even thinking he stepped forward and
looked at the vulnerability in the
chamber all it took was one misplaced
ray of light and he made out the vague
shape of a face in the darkness that's
when the Weeping started Harper knew in
that moment moment his life was over the
correct thing to do would have been to
order everyone else in the room to close
their eyes while he stood there and
accepted his fate minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further but humans
rarely have perfect reasoning even less
so when facing mortality back in the
present the shy guy made a perfect lunge
grabbing Harper in its iron clutches and
barreling through the adjoining wall the
nearby guards scattered terrified
keeping their eyes on the floor they
might get a slap on the wrist for
temporarily abandoning their posts but
they weren't going to die guarding some
stupid evil mask speaking of the
possessive mask was surprised to feel
two new presences enter its chamber
through the now destroyed wall these two
presences soon became just one as scp096
quickly and totally annihilated security
officer Harper leaving nothing left the
mask couldn't see per se seeing as it
had no ual sensory organs but it felt
around this new guest with its many
psychic tendrils taking in this strange
totality the creature was powerful no
doubt about that and it elicit fear from
those fools at the SCP Foundation but
the mask noticed its brain waves were
extraordinarily muted humans to The
Masks vast and malicious Consciousness
weren't the sharpest knives in the
drawer but compared to this thing's mind
they were a pile of tempered katanas it
barely thought at all the mask would
have to dig deeper to find anything it
could use meanwhile scp096 finally began
to calm down the one who had seen it had
been annihilated bubbling rage was
slowly siphoned out and replaced by the
standard low but constant hum of anxiety
and despair it would wait until its head
was bagged and it was dragged back to
the dark same old same old all the way
to the end of time that's when it felt
something else it started as a faint
Buzz an unintelligible whisper and it
was almost like a door opened in the
back of its head something stepped in
and took a
seat can you hear me
stranger KN
KN I want to speak to you something
about the voice frightened and comforted
as CP 096 at the same time it spoke with
a greater degree of sympathy than the
creature had heard in a long time and
yet something about the way it spoke
implied evil in its
intent I know what you
want I know what you
fear wouldn't it be nice if they could
never look at you
again if you could cover that face of
yours I can help
you it will be so
simple all you need to do is put me on
little by little 096 felt more of these
strange thoughts filling up the
emptiness in its head replacing the few
little thoughts the creature itself had
it felt itself lifting its hands from
the ground lifting them and reaching
towards something a glass box the glass
shattered and those long white fingers
reached for something within a mask just
like the voice had said a mask to stop
people from looking at its
face
yes yes you're doing so well you're so
close just the even further as scp096
lifted The Mask to its face feeling
black liquid that burned its skin
dripping from the porcelain and put it
on and in that moment everything changed
the Shy Guy's body began to seize up
rattling as the mask Unleashed a web of
psychic tendrils through its body
mapping out across every inch like a new
nervous system taking control the
possessive mask had never experienced a
a host like this before that incredible
perfect mix of physical durability and a
mind so insubstantial that it was easy
to
sublimate oh this was going to be fun
for the first time the shy guy now under
the full control of the possessive mask
stood at full height on its high legs
its spine and shoulders clicking into
place for its new stance The Mask crack
its neck getting used to the new
dimensions of its physicality its
indestructible bones its long grasping
limbs its skin burning and fizzling with
the gooey black secretions but growing
back just as quickly the foundation had
every reason to fear it now a group of
security Personnel had gathered in the
Ragged hole where the chamber's north
wall used to be some were wielding light
Firearms the guard at the front was
carrying an opaque black bag The Mask
laughed with its new body and turned to
the crowd the second they saw it on 0
96's body their faces fell for a moment
their bodies went slack with Terror this
situation was unprecedented what course
of action could they possibly take at a
time like this it looked at the bag held
by the leader of the security force and
projected a single thought into his
mind you won't be needing that before
any of the guards even had a chance to
open fire The Mask lunged forwards using
the long terrible arms of the shy guy to
tear through the guards they were dead
in seconds their bodies strewn about the
hallway The Mask porcelain was twisted
into a wide sadistic grin it could tell
that it was about to have some real fun
around here and once it slaughtered
everyone here it could finally stretch
its legs out in the open again true
freedom to spread misery fear and pain
everywhere it went there were just a few
hundred members of foundation Personnel
it needed to turn into corpses first
more Containment Breach alarm sounded
around the site as the mask began its
Rampage running through the hallways and
tearing apart any unfortunate Foundation
personality could get 0 96's Hands-On
guards researchers administrative staff
and even one extremely unlucky Jam
in hallway C6 it was having the time of
its long and terrible life and much to
its Glee it seemed that this new host's
body was still holding up it was perfect
symbiosis a twisted brilliant mind and a
body that could forever support it there
would be no stopping it a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around
the site soon realized on their own
terms 096 was indestructible but it was
as dumb as a brick and had an easily
exploitable weakness get the bag on its
head and you're home free this new
composite creature was a different story
it could think tactically avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak
attacks and the monster had as much
psychic combat potential as physical
guards roving the building and teams
heavily armed with antimimetic
protective gear still reported feeling
immense feelings of psychological dread
for comms that was the greatest sign
that the mask would come bursting
through the wall moments later and tear
them to shreds the site director put out
an urgent call for all nearby mobile
task forces to intercept and help them
take care of the unfortunate situation
thankfully a Detachment of MTF 8 of1
also known as see no evil was operating
on a case in close proximity given their
specialization in anomalies with a
mimetic visual property many on the team
had dealt with 096 breaches before that
at least gave them experience in half of
this situation and one operative among
them Sergeant henrique Ramirez would be
the one to bring this nightmare to an
end but it would cost him his life in
the process the mask was still using its
new indestructible body to wreck havoc
on the containment site once it had
taken out the primary contingent of
guards it was free to have its fun with
the rest stalking defenseless
researchers through the HS making sure
to induce maximum Terror before finally
striking the killing blow every single
one of them died with a head full of
demonic Whispers it told them of the
mask's Eternal Dominion now it had found
the perfect host nothing on Earth would
stop it humans would be mere ants under
its feet 8 of 10 touched down and
entered the building Ramirez was
pointman leading the others into the
bowels of the blood drenched containment
site they been briefed on what they were
heading in for 096 and 035 had reached
symbiosis and were displaying
unprecedented anomalous effects enter
with Extreme Caution they're beyond
dangerous even more so together than
alone ideally Ramirez would have wanted
to go in with a comprehensive plan but
lives were on the line here they needed
to leap off the cliff and build their
wings on the way down it was only when
they finally encountered the monster
that they realized just how outm Ed they
were despite their best efforts the
combined speed intelligence and ferocity
of the mask's new form allowed it to
make short work of 8 of 10 only Ramirez
was left heavily injured even if a
miracle happened he knew he wasn't
getting out of here alive The Mask
grabbed him with one of 0 96's Claws and
lifted him up it would take its time
with this one make him suffer watch him
squirm destroy his mind MZ felt The
Masks psychic tendrils penetrate the
membrane of his mind those Whispers
those terrible Whispers reciting all his
worst fears with terrible Glee his gun
was out of ammo his knife was broken all
he had left on him was a pocket mirror
and that was his Eureka moment it was a
long shot but it was also his only shot
he reached out and grabbed the bottom of
the Mask pulling for dear life his other
hand shot into his pocket and grabbed
the mirror opening its lid with a deaf
flick of his thumb it was too fast for
the mask to even register what was going
on Ramirez forced his eyes shut and
lifted up the mirror the mask saw its
own reflection in the glass as the
bottom of its face came loose revealing
the reflection of the face underneath
the mask squeezed killing Ramirez but it
was already too late it had finally seen
the face of its host and that would cost
it dearly The Mask felt a sudden
tremendous push back to its psychic
forces a blind Despair and then rage
that choked out everything scp096 began
to sob and howl somehow the mask was no
longer in control despite its psychic
protests 096 reached up and tore the
terrible mask from its face tossing it
against the wall with such force that it
was embedded in the brick work its last
thoughts as other mobile task force
operators descended on the area to bag
096 and return it to its containment
chamber were what the hell just happened
and the next thought that crossed the
mind of the site director was request
site transfer for 035 as soon as
possible don't want a repeat of this
incident anytime
soon here we go again it's time to
return to the acid filled containment
chamber of SCP
682 more commonly known as the hard to
destroy reptile we've spoken about him
and the ways the SCP Foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then we really
only scratched the surface of the huge
number of insane ways the foundation has
tried to wipe this cranky lizard off the
face of the Earth today we're filling in
some of the cracks and taking a look at
the secret test logs detailing the
foundation's unsuccessful quest to
finally destroy SCP
682 some of these may surprise you and
if you're a real SCP expert you may just
recognize some familiar faces we meet
along the way esteemed Foundation
researcher Dr Alto cleff famed for his
somewhat unconventional personality
entered the test chamber to see if he
could intimidate the Beast to death this
resulted in a long staring contest
between Dr cleff and 682 towards the end
of the competition Dr cleff began to
lose his nerve he tried to leave the
room only to find that the door was
locked causing him to swear loudly Dr
cleff Who always tries to find the most
direct solution to his problems blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran
off the result test failed next came SCP
662 a silver handbell that summons The
supernaturally Helpful Butler Mr Deeds
when Mr Deeds was summoned Foundation
researchers asked him if he could kill
SC P 682 Deeds politely explained that
he wouldn't be capable of killing 682
it's just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test failed the
foundation brought in SCP 689 a
terrifying soapstone statue of a sitting
skeleton that can kill you if you see it
and then stop paying attention to it 682
first observed the statue and then the
foundation turned off the lights when
they turned them back on SCP 682
appeared to be dead in a puddle of gray
and black liquid d-class Personnel were
sent in to confirm that 682 was actually
dead but it instead got up and killed
them researchers theorize that 682
definition of life is not quite the same
as ours during 689s death related Powers
ineffective test failed yet again SCP
807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words Last Chance Diner
printed on the edges in white any food
placed on it becomes Irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate Cardiac Arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
680 2 special 10 kg of rotten Mead and
sharpened bone splinters 10 L of rancid
mayonnaise 1 lit of potassium Cyanide
and 1 kg of morphine hydrochloride
combined into a solid mass and
transmuted by 807 when 682 consumed this
disgusting meal it appeared to collapse
however when d-class Personnel were sent
in again to see whether 682 was truly
out for the count multiple holes opened
up in its body these holes fired out
high-press Jets of blood killing the
nearby DCL classes and destroying the
containment cell 682 was fine afterwards
another test failed to kill 682 it
seemed that the foundation really needed
to have God on their side so they tried
to recruit SCP 343 also known as God to
help them destroy the Beast however when
he entered the containment chamber he
somehow couldn't even see the beast when
researchers asked asked him whether he
could kill 682 God replied he's not one
of mine deal with him yourself test
failed before it even began next the
foundation recruited SCP 524 a small
white rabbit that can eat literally
anything including itself without being
harmed the rabbit was released into
scp-682's chamber at which point it
approached 682 and began to eat one of
its legs 682 roared in pain and scuttled
up the wall out of 524 reach where it
remained for a number of hours at this
point SCP 524 seemed to become bored and
began eating its way out of containment
through a nearby wall test failed maybe
the Luck of the Irish was what the
foundation needed to finally put this
monster to rest they recruited SCP 1933
a fat man dressed as Santa Claus whose
bodily fluids consist entirely of the
alcoholic beverage known as Irish cream
if enough of this man's self-produced
Irish cream is f fed to something
they'll find that all of their bodily
fluids have become Irish Cream 2 killing
them the foundation fed large quantities
of this Irish cream to SCP 682 and it
actually had an effect causing 682 to
appear intoxicated which was a promising
sign however it soon vomited out a
massive quantity of SCP 1933 bodily
fluids turning the walls of its cell
into Irish cream and allowing it to
escape and wreck havoc test failed big
time the foundation recruited the help
of SCP
2337 an intelligent corn C known as Dr
Spano with a voice so loud it can quite
literally talk its victims to death if
it speaks to them for an extended period
of time it was sent into SCP 682s
chamber to attempt to destroy the beast
but 682 just told it to leave and the
talkative bird obliged by blowing away
one of the chamber walls with a yell
allowing SCP 682 to breach containment
again terrible job Dr speno test failed
the foundation researchers were starting
to get a little frustrated with their
lack of progress which you can no doubt
sympathize with and they even pitched
the possibility of sending SCP 682 into
an alternate Dimension where perhaps it
would enter into a stalemate against its
altern itself but this pitch was shot
down by the 05 Council on the grounds
that it was way way way way too risky
back to the drawing board by which we
they literally transformed 682 skin into
a kind of drawing board SCP 2521 is an
anomaly that manifests anytime
information about it is recorded and
immediately grabs the source of the
information wrapping it in its tendrils
and taking it away with it the
foundation sought to take advantage of
this by using a laser cutter to cut this
anomalous information into SCP 682 side
however this didn't have the results
they were hoping for SCP 2521 did turn
up to take the information but it only
took the skin on which the information
was carved 62 survived and quickly grew
back its skin test failed again
researchers suggested tracking down SCP
169 an obscenely massive underwater
creature known as the Leviathan and
feeding 682 to the Beast however this
idea was also immediately shot down by
the 05 Council if 682 did what did best
which was surviving attacks and adding
them to its own Arsenal then it might
grow to the size of SCP 169 which would
likely trigger an XK Class end of the
world scenario it simply was not worth
the risk test failed before it even
started the foundation released two
specimens of SCP 939 into 682s test
chamber these voice imitating Amnesia
inducing monsters have caused huge
damage to human targets so it was hoped
that they may be able to do something to
682 but this hope turned out to be
misplaced both specimens seemed
extremely distressed by 682s presence
and refused to engage at all 682 did not
share the same apprehension about
attacking it charged in and brutally
killed both before devouring their
corpses test failed in a very well
documented case the adorable SCP 999 was
introduced into 682s test chamber The
unsalable Good Vibes Prov divided by 999
as well as an intense tickle fight did
actually lead to the temporary
incapacitation of SCP
682 however the otherwise wholesome
incident ended in tragedy when 682
adapted to the Good Vibes and was able
to release a kind of violent laughter
wave this incapacitated much of the
staff and allowed 682 to breach
containment and go on another Killing
Spree before being recontained test once
again failed the next test involved SCP
294 an anomalous coffee machine that can
produce any liquid typed into its keypad
Foundation researchers requested SCP 682
killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results during tests on
the liquid with SCP 682 tissue samples
the liquid was surprisingly effective
and caused the 682 tissue to Decay and
crumble tests on the living creature
were similarly promising the acid in 68
2's tank was temporarily lowered and one
L of SCP 682 killer was poured onto the
reptile's head causing that portion of
its flesh to immediately Decay when the
acid was returned the same portion that
had the liquid poured on it dissolved
instantly test well not quite successful
but promising and requiring further
Research Foundation scientists believe
that if they could one day get a large
enough quantity of this liquid they
might have a viable option but until
until then the tests march on for
another experiment they introduced SCP
055 into the containment chamber of SCP
682 SCP 055 also known as the self-
keeping secret is a mysterious anomaly
that can only be described by what it
isn't for example we know that SCP 055
is not round but that was pretty much it
now however we know something else about
SCP 055 that it can't kill SCP P 682
test failed but at least we know twice
as much about SCP 055 as we did before
next came SCP 082 better known as ferand
the cannibal ferand was first presented
a piece of Flesh from 682 but rather
than eating it he inspected it and began
to express joy that his friends still
live when introduced into 682s testing
chamber Ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his Steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
ferand and the idea of being ridden like
a pony and the two of them engaged in
combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an SCP who responded to reason
much better SCP
049 the plague doctor this Sinister
surgeon can kill with a touch and the
foundation hoped that his abilities
would extend to
682 however the result was a dud the
plague doctor did touch 682 but it
experienced no adverse effects and
eventually swiped at the doctor upon
leaving 049 reported feeling emotionally
disturbed by his encounter with SCP 682
yeah yep you guessed it test failed if
it gives you any indication of just how
desperate the researchers were at this
point Dr Graham pondered whether
introducing 682 to a human with just as
pessimistic and misanthropic feelings as
itself would somehow pacify it they sent
in a particularly nasty d-class and the
two spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't
attempt to harm this d-class they just
shared their profane and Bleak
sentiments about the human race with one
another however some of 68 2's opinions
were a little too spicy for this d-class
after listening to the reptile speak for
20 minutes the d-class fell into a
catatonic state from the sheer
depression of it all he died not long
after one researcher suggested perhaps
the worst idea of all letting SCP 682
out into the wild not even really to
terminate it just to see what it does
the scientists figured there would be
some Merit in analyzing the creatur's
behavior this idea was submitted
anonymously of course it seems even the
most sadistic of researchers know better
than to put their name on an idea like
that as you can probably guess this
request was shot down by the 05 Council
the note attached to the request by one
of its members summed it up best I'll
tell you what it will do it'll go out
for a nice stroll murder a few innocent
people go fishing slaughter a few more
innocent people start up a tech company
eat a few more innocent people go on a
vacation to Florida dismember a few more
innocent people I swear when I find out
who wrote this you can personally enter
682s containment chamber to analyze him
yourself this has been far from an
exhaustive account of all the different
ways the SCP Foundation has tried to
terminate SCP 682 but it shouldn't be
surprising that all of their ideas have
either been failures or were too risky
to even try sadly for the SCP Foundation
and the human race it's likely we'll be
dealing with SCP 682 for a long time to
come but do you have an idea for how you
think 682 could finally be killed
something that even the foundation
hasn't thought of to try let us know in
the comments hello everyone if you're a
fan of SCP explained you'll know that we
regularly post interesting questions in
our community tab asking for responses
from you our dear fans these have ranged
from questions about specific anomalies
like scp096 or your suggestions on how
we should actually kill SCP ab2 the hard
to destroy reptile we've even asked you
which anomalous Powers you'd want to
have and posed your questions directly
to SCP 343 also known as God and of
course the terrifying and Infamous
Scarlet King but in our latest Community
question asking you about hypothetical
crossovers between the SCP Foundation
and the weird wild Multiverse of all
fiction you truly outdid yourself with
thousands upon thousands of responses
and we thought rather than just making
one video selecting our favorites we
turn each of our favorites into whole
videos and how are we going to do that
that's where this wonderful
state-of-the-art Gizmo comes into play
you may remember the
anamatronic intelligence-driven
supercomputer designed specifically to
run simulations for the SCP Foundation
we fed this computer data from countless
SCP Foundation experiments and cross
tests and all the data from your
suggestions this will allow the fine
folks at the SCP Foundation to explore
any anomalous hypothetical without
risking the lives of Staff members or
civilians this brings us to our first
simulation suggested in a huge number of
comments could SCP 682 be contained
within the back rooms for those not in
the know the back rooms is an internet
urban legend that spiraled into a
full-blown phenomenon it's built on the
premise that if you're not careful and
enter certain specific circumstances you
can no clip out of our reality and enter
a terrifying multi-level alternate
reality where you're stocked by a
variety of bizarre and frightening
creatures this could be a complete
nightmare for your average person but
how would it play out if SCP 682 the
endlessly angry hardto destroy reptile
found its way inside also for another
back rooms related surprise stick around
until the end of the video in the
meantime though let's boot up the
the worst had happened again SCP 682 had
busted out of containment during a cross
test and started making a beine for the
nearest populated area several
helicopters containing heavily armed MTF
new7 hammerdown members were in Hot
Pursuit attempting to slow The Vicious
reptile down with targeted sniper fire
at its legs but it seems that these
efforts were all for not as CP 682 had
already reached the defunct industrial
district on the edge of a nearby City
and if the Beast managed to actually
reach a populated area all hell would
break loose that's when they pulled out
the heavy Weaponry Min guns mounted to
the helicopters Unleashed a rain of
Hellfire down onto SCP 682 however 682
managed to dodge most of the bullets and
simply tank the rest command authorized
the use of heavy ordinance the
helicopter's missile launchers they'd
pick up the pieces afterwards once SCP
682 was back in containment however the
reptile had plans of its own it charged
into a nearby abandoned chemical plant
to avoid the gunfire from above this was
exactly what hammer down wanted the
helicopter circled around the chemical
plant and Unleashed a barrage of
powerful incendiary missiles blowing the
plant to Kingdom come in hopes of
dragging an incapacitated 682 out of the
rubble afterwards but when the smoke had
cleared and only the rubble was left 682
was nowhere to be seen even for the
hardcore operatives of hammerdown
this caused an anxiety Spike had it
tunneled into the ground had it adapted
to the attack by turning invisible or
getting tiny to escape they' done all
these things before or after all the
deranged attempts at putting SCP 682 in
the ground had some light firebombing
killed the monster whatever the case
they need to search in case SCP 682
popped up somewhere else and started
causing Havoc if it was still alive
which it probably was they couldn't rest
on their florals until they'd found it
again meanwhile as SCP 682 woke up it
felt groggy and irritated its body
resting against an unpleasant soggy
carpet it licked the carpet the moisture
had the distinct flavor of human spinal
fluid which 682 had tasted many times
before the sickly yellow walls and
incessant buzzing from the fluorescent
lights up above were nauseating and it
gave 682 a nagging headache this only
made 682s default emotion blistering r
Ag and hatred even worse it began
walking around exploring this strange
spatial anomalous environment was this
more of that frustrating Foundation
trickery another one of those purile
cross tests the last thing 682
remembered was running at one of the
walls in the chemical plant a wall that
in hindsight seemed darker than all the
others but rather than shattering
through the brick work it was here now
in this strange tacky Lobby that never
seemed to end it was like a kaleidoscope
of Mt 19 1990s office kitch endless
worthless yellow walls arranged like
some Labyrinthian nonsensical maze
leading nowhere and devoid of all life
as SCP 682 wandered through it and of
course SCP 682 found it disgusting it
was only on level zero and already 682
hated the back rooms just as much as it
hated our Dimension someone or something
had to pay for the crime of
inconveniencing it this way and it would
happily turn this whole dimension inside
out just to find some beings to kill
inside it yes that would be great fun
SCP 682 began its frantic search for an
exit evolving an innate sonar ability
and picking up speeds that would be
impossible for human beings this is the
part where most people would go mad or
die from Hunger or thirst SCP 682 not so
much it could keep searching and
searching and searching until the Stars
burned out in the sky it was would find
its prey somehow and when it did it
would put them through hell and as it
turned out this new universe rewarded
682s dog stubbornness because when it
passed through a seemingly random
hallway after hours of searching it was
in a different place entirely this place
looked like some huge abandoned
warehouse complex with water shining off
the ground if 682 had more advanced
knowledge of the back rooms he would
have known this was level one but the
only number SCP 682 cared about was body
count and in that regard it would find
level one to be a vast Improvement two
groups of humans had established bases
in this level of the back rooms the
major Explorer group a faction of
professional back rooms Travelers who
maintained their base Alpha on this
level in the back room's non-aligned
trade group a commercial group whose
primary base is an economic Hub on this
very level a Fortified city-like Area
with a population of 412 which would a
few hours after 682s appearance
be a population of zero but before all
of that it felt like grabbing a bite at
the diner Tom's Diner is a refuge for
many people trapped in the back rooms a
casual eering nestled into the cold
Warehouse environment of level one where
people could get a warm meal from Tom a
former cook who's been trapped in the
back room for years SCP 682 was eager to
be part of this Grand tradition but the
hard to destroy reptile decided to Buck
the trend a little by just devouring Tom
himself from there decided to launch its
rage fuel offensive against the various
humanoid inhabitants of the level both
the major Explorer group base Alpha and
the back rooms non-aligned trade group
tradee were heavily fortified against
the kind of entities these folks had
gotten used to facing in the back rooms
but they were completely unprepared for
a creature of SCP 682 sheer power
intelligence endurance and ferocity the
SCP Foundation had been studying the
creature for decades with far more
resources than either of these two
backrooms bound groups and they still
had a hard time keeping the Beast
consistently contained sadly for the
great Bastion of human hope in the
backrooms SCP 682 swept through both
outposts in a matter of hours killing
everyone there without an ounce of
remorse the only person there it took
its time with was the final human being
left in the decimated remains of the
major explorers group base Alpha it
grabbed the man by the throat and
squeezed asking with its guttural
growling voice you were you and your
dead Brethren allied with the SCP
Foundation despite his fear the Explorer
told 682 that he had never heard of the
SCP Foundation nor did he know what kind
of entity 682
was then what is this place tell me and
I might give you a quick death the
Explorer gave as good a response as he
could 682 was trapped in the back rooms
a multi-leveled interdimensional
nightmare filled with dangerous
creatures that made 682 curious
dangerous creatures that could make an
interesting challenge 682 asked the
Explorer how it could access these other
levels and find these creatures and the
Explorer explained that through
exploring these levels enough anyone
could noclip into the next one it really
was that simple with that 682 knew all
it needed to know and carelessly
murdered the final human being of level
one it had killed so many humans over
its long and twisted life it was no
different from breathing air now an
utterly perun action it was eager to
discover these other creatures on the
lower levels and teach them a new level
of fear they'd never experienced 682
stormed the Halls until it achieved the
next successful noclip into level two
which manifested as a series of old
dilapidated maintenance tunnels that
seemed to stretch on for millions of
miles wonderful there were humans here
too apparently but who cared about them
this was the first level to feature a
smorgus board of entities ripe for The
Killing It sped through the tunnels
teeth and fangs born eager to deal death
with gleeful abandon the first entities
it encountered in the expansive tunnels
of level two were a collection of beings
known as crawlers insect-like creatures
infected with an extremely aggressive
fungal growth just getting close to them
could present an active risk to humans
not so much for a creature that could
easily regenerate after being tossed
into the Sun as the creatures tried to
LUN SCP 682 simply crushed and devoured
them with little effort they tasted a
little stale on account of the fungus
but the chewi was pleasing hopefully
there would be more challenging foes
down in the tunnel than these mere
insects as CP 682 thought to itself
while journeying deeper into the endless
network of tunnels soon enough as CP 682
ventured into a section of the tunnel
engulfed in total darkness its eyes
quickly adjusted developing Immaculate
night vision that's when it spotted
another creature sharing this little
slice of Darkness with it a pair of
floating glowing eyes and almost
cartoonish teeth grinning like some
manal Looney Tune this is an entity
known as a Smiler and they're a
terrifying threat to any humans
venturing through the back rooms SCP 682
wasn't impressed it began a perfect
adaptation for the situation its body
began to Glow emitting incredible levels
of both heat and light carving through
the darkness of the tunnel and causing
The Smiler to emit a terrible piercing
shriek the sheer heat of this new
ability melted sections of the level two
tunnels around SCP 682 when the light
finally dimmed down to slightly more
reasonable levels where The Smiler once
stood was instead a fizzling black
Scorch Mark another creature had
painfully bitten the dust and SCP 682
was starting to have some fun it took
off further down into the tunnels
looking forward to finding its next
victim sadly for SCP 682 it wouldn't get
to kill the next set of victims a group
of four child facings spooky faceless
little girls who like to cut apart their
typical human victims with small objects
were waiting a little further down the
pipe however when they felt SCP 682
approaching they almost sense the power
and cruelty of the Beast coming towards
them even being little monsters
themselves game recognized game and they
knew that they needed to get the hell
out of there before the monster arrived
they climbed between the pipes on the
tunnel walls and skittered off into
hiding places deep in the dark lucky for
them SCP 682 passed them and just kept
going what would be the point in wasting
time on these little morsels when there
were apparently so many other creatures
to Massacre down here next SC SCP 682
came across a truly pathetic creature
something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even
interacting with it was a creature known
as a clump a strange bundle of living
limbs that will move at Great speeds and
attack its usually human targets it
tried to do the same to SCP 682
maniacally flailing its many Twisted
limbs 682 killed it in a single Stomp
and moved on feeling its own
psychological equivalent of pity but not
that much of it not long after mercy
killing the clump SCP 682 came face to
face with a series of hounds mutant
humanoids who travel on all fours
behaving in a wolf-like fashion this
would of course be the stuff of
nightmares for your average human being
but would far more likely put a being
like the hardto destroy reptile to sleep
with sheer boredom humans acting like
dogs that makes them even more worthless
the creature thought as it charged
forwards and began tearing the group of
hounds to shreds minutes later it was
splitting off into an adjoining tunnel
searching for more easy entertainment
but the deeper SCP 682 made its way into
the bowels of level two the more it
approached a truly horrifying
realization the creatures it was
slaughtering here were even more boring
than the ones the SCP Foundation
ceaselessly threw at it back on its
native reality or at least the reality
where they contained it back in that
world it had faced giant flaming
demigods with swords hotter than the sun
it had faced some pale shrieking
monstrosity that didn't seem to die no
matter what the reptile threw at it
there was the dark gooey old man The
Immortal Warrior from the Black Coffin
and even the all devouring bunny rabbit
here it was killing the same wretched
selection of beasts again and again a
truly pitiful offering was this really
the best this world had to offer
incidentally the next creature had found
was literally known as wretches by the
human inhabitants of the back rooms they
were fleshy zombie-like creatures that
SCP 682 figured the sarcs back home
might enjoy it couldn't believe that it
was thinking fondly of that old place
while it carved the monsters to ribbons
with its claws it missed its old enemies
like Dr brght Dr clef and even that
irritating yellow blob of snot the mo
tried to take its mind off the old world
by killing its way through this Ant Farm
of endless tunnels the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic for example
there were the play goblins impish
little creatures with masks like that of
a plague doctor 682 found itself
thinking almost fondly about SCP 049
while it listlessly ate the tiny
mischievous creatures like a depressed
person binging an extra- large pack of
chips even their tiny squeaks as they
crunched between the reptile's terrible
teeth gave it no joy what a bleak turn
of events this had all turned out to be
as it wandered through the infinite
tunnels killing creatures and even
humans as it found them SCP 682 made a
quiet promise to itself somehow some way
it would make its way back to the
universe it so recently departed it
would leave the back rooms no matter how
many levels a quiet burning husk and
returned to the world of Fools and
fiends that had taken for granted all
this time a visit to the back rooms had
taught the hard to destroy reptile an
all to human lesson sometimes you don't
know what you have until it's gone sure
the SCP Foundation may have tried to
kill it in a new bizarre and
increasingly sadistic way every single
day but that variety was the spice of
life it would return home someday it
knew that much but of course a lot of
creatures and people would need to die
before then but if that's what it took
well so be it SCP 682 licked its
dagger-like fangs and kept crawling
another day another failed attempt at
death if SCP 682 had anything even
resembling a sense of humor he might ask
for it to be printed on a motivational
poster and stuck to the side of his
containment chamber where he eternally
melts and regrows at the mercy of high
concentration acid they just cross
tested him with AEL again unlike some of
the others he'd been forced to face that
tattooed swordsman seemingly wasn't
intelligent enough to fear he'd always
come back just as stupid and violent
this encounter had left the heart to
destroy reptile at 30% of his previous
body mass bloody and bashed he'd
survived the encounter he always
survived they brought what was left of
him back to his cell in a forklift a
blasted forklift how could it even be
more humiliating as his eyes started to
grow back in his head he could swear he
even saw one of the technicians laughing
at him his name tag read agent Nigel
Kelly noted 682 would specifically hunt
down and kill him the next time he
breached of course every single day he
plotted revenge against the human race
along with everything else but the sum
they owed in pain blood and despair
could never be repaid in full after all
every single one of them except Dr brigh
could only really die once they'd
brought 682 to the precipice a thousand
times only for his own body to cheat him
and deprive him of the sweet release of
death and if the foundation had their
way it would be done a thousand times
more and they wouldn't even stop there
682 couldn't even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to
deal a blow even comparable to the one
he had faced all he could do was dream
dream of a reckoning that would turn the
tables something that would plunge
Humanity into the state of constant pain
and Terror that had been all he'd ever
known since these fumbling ssts and
white coats had locked him up here what
a beautiful day that would be little did
SCP 682 know that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where SCP 682 was kept after
all orders from the 05 Council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a sight holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents
watched their children laughing and
frolicking in an idyllic playground some
squealed with Glee as they descended the
slide some of the more ambitious Little
Tykes tried to go over the bar on the
swings others waited in line for some
delicious soft serve at a parked ice
cream truck one mother brought an ice
cream cone and walked walked over to a
nearby bench where she began to enjoy
her delicious Frozen treat it was a
remarkably hot day out and a little ice
cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied
you could see the distant air wobbling
in the heat already her ice cream was
starting to melt white rivulets
dribbling down the sides of the cone and
onto her hands suddenly almost
imperceptibly the quality of the light
shifted the kind of thing you dismiss as
a trick of the eyes and forget just as
quickly were it not for the catastrophic
effects that were about to unfold as the
woman leaned forward to lick her melting
ice cream something dripped onto her
skirt but as she looked down she slowly
realized that what dripped onto her
wasn't the Pure White of her ice cream
it was the same exact tone as her skin
she felt a terrible burning sensation
all through her body the most horrible
debilitating pain she ever experienced
like every cell in her body was
screaming and trying to make a break for
it she turned to the other parents
sitting near the playground they were
screaming too each collapsed to the
ground with agonizing slowness different
parts of their body falling at different
speeds as they transition through states
of matter when they hit the ground they
were taking on a liquid state screaming
worthless boneless blobs the woman even
saw her own arm wilting like a
time-lapse video of a Dying flower she
dripped and sosed through the cracks in
the bench until nothing recognizably
human was left only a soggy ice cream
cone sitting une eaten in an instant
billions of Screams rang out over planet
Earth Day had broken things would never
ever be the same again as almost half of
humanity instantaneously ly took on a
liquid state needless to say with the
most dangerous and far-reaching
anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind
of warning the SCP Foundation was
incredibly busy this would take some
unprecedented action the members of the
05 Council who weren't melted during the
initial blast convened over secure video
link while sequestering themselves
underground and what amounted to
multiple human lifetimes of some of the
most high pressure choices is imaginable
they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the SCP
Foundation in the service of all mankind
they would now break the Masquerade the
SCP Foundation would at long last step
out of the Shadows to save the rest of
humanity from the tyranny of the light
broadcasts went out all over the globe
every TV screen every live stream every
radio broadcast was commandeered they
gave instructions based on the scattered
Intel they had for some reason the sun
had turned against them exposure would
lead any biological creatures melting
away into sentient piles of flesh
colored sludge people would remain in
doors and away from any light sources
all windows must remain covered travel
only at night and even then heavily
covered with protective gear there can
only be one objective for whoever is
left make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek
Refuge inside if anyone could figure out
the answer to this terrifying
existential riddle it would be the SCP
Foundation anyone who is exposed should
be considered lost while as always the
SCP Foundation did all they could to
project a sense of control over the
situation on the inside it was
pandemonium somehow despite everything
this event had taken all of them by
surprise how could anyone have predicted
that the Cradle of our Solar System's
delicate living balance would suddenly
become a meat grinder a huge number of
foundation operatives were wiped out in
the initial exposure Global
Communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to SCP
682 as another evil tactician once put
it chaos was a ladder from the inside of
his acid tank 682 could sense the fear
and pain suddenly exuding from his
surrounding environment it was greater
than ever before what was happening out
there there this was no average
Containment Breach something was really
really happening out there 682 began to
adapt and finally attune its hearing
until it could pick up the chatter from
outside uh maybe we can convert some of
the d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh God oh God we've lost sight 7 sight
10 site 23 sight 40 site 52 a death toll
looks to be in the billions well we
don't know if they're dead technically
but they're sure as hell not human
anymore for well this is the big one
this is it XK class even 2,000 is
unaccounted for is all five crazy that
they think we're fighting the freaking
son needless to say 682s curiosity was
peaked anything that could light a fire
under the foundation like this was
something he could enjoy and with his
impressively strategic intellect he
intuited that a time of great Strife for
the foundation would be the perfect time
to breach containment cuz whenever
there's violence fear and Chaos on a
scale SCP 682 will be there causing it
682 began adapting his pores and
endocrine system to begin releasing a
powerful alkaline substance little by
little the alkaline neutralized the acid
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely
complely froze around him the ice
expanded beyond the limit of the
containment unit busting the rivets of
the metal frame and shattering the
reinforced glass with his goal achieved
682 raised his internal temperatures to
incredible highs melting the ice around
him once again he was free and ready for
some good old-fashioned Carnage and
Mayhem perhaps he could get a better
handle on this strange new situation too
it was all rather exciting just a girl
with goals huh SCP Foundation Personnel
were already running around like ants
trying desperately to avoid the costic
laser beam of the magnifying glass you
can only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall Kool-Aid Man style and began to
ruthlessly Massacre everyone around him
just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 Containment
Breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular Containment
Breach was that given the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran into
682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who Dar to get in
his way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed and bit and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
Glee leaving great piles of bodies in
his wake all the while he was pondering
the things he heard those Foundation
drones saying something about the Sun
and an XK class scenario H interesting
682 also observed that any apertures
that could potentially allow light into
the facility had also been shuttered
perhaps they weren't overreacting this
time like they always did with him maybe
they were dealing with some kind of
phenomenon that would Now cast this
wretched world and those who lived in it
into the void wouldn't that be A fitting
karmic fate for them all still 682s
bloodlust didn't outweigh his logic he
needed to know more about the situation
before proceeding and in this maybe he
could kill two Foundation birds with one
stone elsewhere in the building alarms
blared the air was suffused with
panicked voices and frequent screams
nobody knew what was going on on not
really they'd only gotten details here
and there and the details they' received
were terrifying all their families and
loved ones outside probably gone so many
of the people in so much of the world
they'd been fighting for risking it all
for had disappeared in an instant
carried to Hell on a ray of sunshine why
were they still here was this horror not
truly uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent Nigel
Kelly as he stood alone in his office
almost catatonic he' had his friends and
family on the outside all likely reduced
to those horrible fleshy blobs he was
alone in the world risking his life for
nothing how could this get any worse his
mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again and the universe
gave him an answer in the form of a deep
reptilian voice saying found you into
his ear from behind he turned with a
shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee or reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
Furious Beast 682 reached out with a
massive clawed hand and grabbed him by
the Torso lifting him up into the air
the creature was gripping so tight that
he could feel his ribs starting to crack
you laughed at me Agent Killy the
monster hissed am I funny to you do I te
like the time to tell
jokes do you feel like laughing now
agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his
life fighting for his next breath from
the crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent Kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
hups were calling this SCP 001 when day
breaks the sun had gone Rogue somehow
and being in contact with any kind of
sunlight would now cause people to
instantaneously melt into horrifying
living sludge and it wasn't just people
the condition also affected anomalies
and interestingly it appeared to negate
all previous anomalous effects so 682
adaptational ability may not even save
it if it was exposed he told 682
everything he knew are you are you going
to let me live agent Kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682s terrible ma
Twisted into What Might Have Been a
Smile agent Kelly he said with
unsettling joy that was a joke didn't
you find that one funny a terrible
scream emanated from the agent's office
if one good thing could be said for what
happened to agent Kelly that day at
least he didn't live long enough to see
the ravages of the terrible Sun
firsthand 682 began to formulate a plan
he took agent Kelly's wristwatch and
integrated it into his body so he'd have
a permanent internal clock it was the
middle of summer so the sun would have
reliably set at 900 p.m. and would
likely begin its rise around 5:00 a.m.
it would be relatively easy to avoid the
sun All Things Considered for lack of a
more eloquent way to put it when it
comes to adapting to new threats SCP 682
is Simply Built different after
slaughtering a few other members of SCP
Foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began enacting the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carpes and
his front set of Limbs began to grow his
muscles bulging and his claw growing the
tips turning into Sharp flat Scoops with
sudden and tremendous Force 682 began
boring his way into the ground tunneling
clawing through concrete and dirt with
absolute ease normally the SCP
Foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture
him but during the endless horrors of
the breaking day he had Kar blanch to
escape and Live It Up from the ruins of
this rapidly Dying World eventually 682
had boor his way into a roomy sewer pipe
the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the SCP
Foundation had been yet to account for
well they knew that those melted by the
Rogue Sun were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering what the foundation didn't
know was that these former humans were
incred L dangerous in their own right
The sun hadn't just irreparably warped
their bodies it had also irreparably
warped their minds it has enslaved them
made them zealots acolytes they
developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant fleshing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose of finding victims
and dragging them into the light where
they too could be converted into these
terrible fleshy creatures and add to the
masses they were the Rogue son's boots
on the ground metaphorically speaking
and now they were the foundation's
greatest Challenge and getting a handle
on this situation again before it was
just encouraging people to avoid the sun
now the sun was actively trying to
increase its exposure but 682 who was
having a relaxing evening not being
melted for once down in the sewers
couldn't care less he was having the
most calming few hours he' had in years
he waited checking the time making sure
that it would be dark before he began
tunneling back up to the surface world
he surfaced in the middle of his City
miles away from the foundation facility
he'd spent so many decades being
tortured in he tasted the cool night air
and observed the Desolation that had
been rought all around him buildings
were on fire cars were crashed and
overturned the ground was cracked
garbled SC SCP Foundation Public Service
Announcement played to nobody in the
broken display Windows of electronic
stores giant wads of human flesh roamed
slithering around searching for new
victims one noticed 682 and began to
approach him gibbering madly in a chorus
of strange voices the hard to destroy
reptile wasted no time in attacking it
tore apart most of the Hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks the
form may have been different but it
still tasted like human flesh and SCP
682 savored every bite it would be so
simple these Blobs of idiotic flesh were
so easy to kill and there would be so
many terrified humans in this devastated
World hiding away in Dark Places holding
out the hope that maybe they could reach
the safety of a foundation facility 682
chuckled at the very thought foolish
hope would drown in an endless well of
black costic despair he would find them
he would rest underground in the day and
then hunt them in the dark they would
all die screaming bloodying his claws
and fangs nothing and nobody would stop
him he looked out over the strange new
world and laughed a little
[Music]
louder it was just Delight ful Abel
wandered through the Sands a lone
Warrior dragging a Long Dark Sword
behind him his black cloak flowing in
the gentle breeze the sword was thirsty
it had been too long since it tasted
blood what had it been a day since he
cut down 10 men in a Tavern without
breaking a sweat they bled and screamed
like pigs as he diced them into bloody
chunks he couldn't remember their faces
they hadn't earned that
very few combatants had been remarkable
enough to Warrant committing to memory
it was all just more dead flesh he took
a sip from his canteen inside did this
world hold no more challenges what a
boring eternity was laying out before
him his burden as The Greatest Warrior
of all time weighed on him heavier than
the chain it was old and Rusty levered
over his shoulder and grasped in one
bloody hand about 15 ft behind him the
chain was connected to a a dark stone
sarcophagus that was as much a part of
him as his eyes skin or heart if ever he
was slain in the Glorious heat of battle
he'd rise out of it ready to fight and
kill another day all because of the
actions of his worthless good Forno
brother he looked up when he heard the
rush of footsteps and the clanking of
armor Warriors or whatever pass for them
around here about 20 of them circled all
around him yes oh yes his grip tightened
around his sword one of the Warriors
called out something about him being
under arrest by order of the king for
murders Beyond counting Abel couldn't
help but yawn words words words why even
bother he dropped the chain and in one
fluid motion he threw his sword in a
fraction of a second it pierced the
armor of the chattering man spearing him
through his formerly Beating Heart the
scream died in his throat he fell to his
knees then collap collapsed entirely the
other soldiers sent to kill or apprehend
him turned to their Fallen leader in
gasp it was that little gasp that moment
of distraction that sealed their Fates
ael's face cracked into a whisper of a
grin as he drew two long daggers from
the darkness of his coat he'd at least
try to have fun with this before the
others could even get over their
Leader's sudden death Abel had vaulted
forward and begun his delicate dance of
Slaughter every swing found its way
through armor and into skin he sliced
throats cleaved off heads parried blows
and pierced Hearts there was barely a
single scream Abel killed too quick for
screams in what would seem like the
blink of an eye for some the soldiers
around Abel fell most dead the rest
dying some looked up to him in their
dying moments in terrified awe of the
efficacy of their killer in their dying
moments they knew that they never had a
chance they might as well have facing
the glistening Scythe of death himself
on the battlefield Abel on the other
hand rolled his eyes and sigh another
pathetic waste of time he sensed
movement in the corner of his eye one of
the wounded soldiers was limping to his
feet trying to use the sword to lever
himself off of the ground with a flick
of each wrist Abel tossed his knives
into the man killing him instantly it
really was that easy your attempt to
kill me does not offend me he said to
whoever was still able to here what
offends me is that they would send so
few and that those few would be such
pitiful excuses for soldiers this wasn't
a battle it was a mercy killing he was
ready to turn around grab the chain and
carry on walking when he felt a sudden
pain in his back there was a slight
whistle then another sharp Spike of pain
there were now two arrows sticking out
of his back Abel turned surprised and
saw a much larger Force standing behind
him Swordsmen archers men with clubs and
axes and chains the ones he'd killed
were little more than a distraction this
was the real threat this was a real army
perhaps these fools would give him some
actual exercise he reached into his
cloak and pulled out a mighty obsidian
battle axe at the very least he tried to
have a little fun turning this fighting
force into cold cuts a fog of arrows
sailed through the air as he charged
forwards Perforating his body but the
injuries didn't slow him down he lunged
slashed and cleaved even as the weapon
struck him he carried on killing person
after person at times it was almost
exciting almost but not quite by the
time he was done none were left standing
30 arrows were sticking out of him he'd
been cut deep by more weapons than he
could count on his fingers and toes he
was breathing deeply scarred chest
pumping up and down he coughed blood and
cracked his neck back into place they
might have cut him a little too deep
this time no matter Abel fell to his
knees feeling the life draining from him
he wondered when he awoke from the
coffin again what the world would look
like sometimes it was days sometimes
weeks months or even years as he fell
forward dying once again he'd hoped that
he'd wake into a world with a warrior or
beast that could actually challenge him
maybe someday this was one of Abel's
many lives hundreds of years before he
was contained by the SCP Foundation he's
perhaps The Greatest Warrior who ever
lived died and lived again he's a man so
individually deadly that not only is he
kept in a containment chamber Under the
Sea surrounded by highly trained and
armored guards he has his own localized
on-site nuclear weapon ready to blow
away and annihilate him and his entire
containment area if deemed necessary he
may not be a contagious anomalous
pathogen or a lethal medic Hazard or a
giant Beast shooting World destroying
Fireballs in every direction but if this
onean massacre was left to his own
devices there's no doubt that he would
methodically Slaughter his way through
the human race until an XK Class end of
thee World scenario was practically
inevitable he was fueled by pure hatred
and an almost bottomless blood lust he
simply lived to fight and kill and not
only did he have the will and the skill
to be a pure force of annihilation but
his anomalous abilities also make him
perfectly tailored to the task he has
massively enhanced physical strength
speed and durability taking the kind of
damage that would kill several normal
humans to reliably put him down though
even that is only a temporary measure
AEL will always resurrect back into his
black sarcophagus to Menace the SCP
Foundation another day it is also
effectively impossible to disarm able
because he has the anomalous ability to
pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket dimensions at will and his
proficiency with these weapons is unlike
any Warrior the world has ever known
before or since during containment
breaches he's regularly killed scores of
train Foundation guards with both
numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons despite
being a simple humanoid he was taking up
a truly insane amount of containment
resources despite his violent tendencies
Abel is still a recognizable sentient
human albeit an extremely deadly
anomalous one this led some higher-ups
at the foundation to come up with an
interesting idea what if Abel's Eternal
rage could be harnessed what if they
could use their resources to reshape
this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the foundation's cause after
all if he wanted worthy opponents what
could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the foundation faced on a
daily basis and as long as they kept the
sarcophagus even if Abel was killed in
the line of duty he'd still be accounted
for in many ways if he could be trained
and truly brought to heal there could be
no better asset to their coming
struggles it was this logic allowing
anomalies to work for the SCP Foundation
in exchange for benefits that led to the
creation of a new groundbreaking mobile
task force MTF Omega 7 Pandora's Box
this group became the SCP foundation's
hail Mar pass for any particularly
dangerous or potentially Deadly Mission
they could send in AEL along with a
group of highly trained Foundation
soldiers that even the ancient blade
wielding Warrior held respect for while
like their namesake Pandora's Box it
would all wind up in terrible tragedy to
begin with they achiev some of the
highest mission successful results of
any mobile task force on the
foundation's payroll no task was too
challenging for them to swoop in and
crush it this was far from expected AEL
one of the most violent scps they'd ever
contained suddenly became a great asset
to their operations a vital tool in
their quest to keep the anomalous at Bay
he cleaved through Legions of chaos
Insurgency soldiers during breaches into
their secure SES he fought off well-paid
well-trained and well-armed Bodyguards
of Marshall Carter and dark limited
during Foundation raids on their
clandestine operations he'd even gone
toe-to-toe with some of the deadliest
anomalies in containment during mass
escapes it was hard to imagine how
they'd ever lived without him of course
while able was happier than he' had been
in years in his element in fact as a
working Warrior giving varied missions
and frequent opponents there was still
something nagging at him his thoughts
were hounded by his white whale the
endless search for a truly worthy
opponent someone or something that could
really give him a run for his money
after Millennia of leaving opponents
dead in this wake nothing would bring
him more joy than meeting someone that
actually knocked him on his ass a new
are somewhere above him to work towards
oh what a glorious day that would be
eventually the foundation started to run
into a problem they were running out of
missions to give AEL after all he wasn't
the kind of operative you could just
give any mission to his potential for
collateral damage was truly staggering
he'd neutralize the anomaly then
Slaughter everyone within 100t range
just to work off some of the excess
energy like a hand grenade he was
powerful but Dangerously imprecise if
they ran out of high priority missions
what were they supposed to do just put
AEL back in his box to gather dust until
someone else rolled around he was
getting antsy enough between missions
already that's when an unexpected member
of personnel stepped forward Dr Jack
brigh you see Dr bright and Abel had a
history and not an altogether Pleasant
one not that anyone could really have a
pleasant history with AEL Jack was only
a junior researcher when he had his
runin carrying a seemingly worthless
Medallion dubbed SCP 963 back to its
containment Locker that's when a wall
next to him exploded showering him with
brick fragments and dust only to reveal
Abel standing behind the new aperture
before young Dr brigh even had a chance
to scream Abel had already cleaved
through him leaving him in two distinct
parts that were both very much dead at
least it seemed that way until it was
revealed that Dr Bright's Consciousness
had actually been eternally bonded with
SCP
963 giving him the gift and curse of
immortality since then Dr Bri had become
increasingly reckless in his conduct
perhaps hoping that the next time he
Fades to Black the movie that is his sad
Strange Life won't just start to roll
again of course he hasn't been lucky in
that regard yet naturally this has given
Dr brigh complex feelings about his
fellow anomalous Foundation employee so
when the call came around all the SC
senior researchers and site directors
asking if there were any tasks that AEL
seemed fit for he had one very pressing
suggestion after all it wasn't that long
after Dr brigh had been forced into a
cross test with the intention of
terminating 682 which had not only been
a failure but a generally painful and
exhausting experience now perhaps it
would be Abel's turn to take his lumps
he happily put forth a suggestion
claiming that surely the foundation's
new sword wielding gold Golden Boy could
give the hardto destroy reptile the old
College try after all even if Abel was
killed in the process he' just come
right back it was a situation where they
really could not lose so why not take a
chance what's the Worst That Could
Happen the 05 Council found Dr Bri's
pitch extremely compelling he succeeded
in every Mission they'd given him so far
so perhaps he could carry that success
into the Herculean task of actually
terminating 682 one boundlessly
bloodthirsty killer might be the only
thing truly capable of taking out
another of equal magnitude when able was
informed of this latest Mission he got a
scary glint in his eye they gave him
warning after warning the Beast is said
to be unkillable it can adapt to
anything it's killed scores of people
and survived the attacks of anomalies
thought to be Flawless Killers the more
it was explained to him the more Abel
felt the tingling sensation deep within
was was this it had he now discovered
the perfect opponent something that
would actually challenge him would
actually put him through his Paces yes
yes yes he accepted the mission without
question Abel would fight SCP 682 until
his breath was no longer in order to
prepare for the match SCP 682 was
released into a secure area Rocky
desert-like terrain boarded on all sides
by a foundation perimeter hundreds of
meters away on on all sides they thought
it best for The Showdown to happen here
after all with combatants like Abel and
682 it was bound to make a mess one way
or another Abel stroe with pronounced
Swagger onto the Battleground shortly
afterwards carrying perhaps the most
powerful sword he'd ever summoned it was
somewhere between a claymore and a
chainsaw an Unholy Union that gave the
resulting weapon a degree of deranged
badassery not ever seen on the
battlefields of planet Earth before for
carrying this thing AEL felt like a king
and he was about to slay the most
ancient and beastial of monsters as he
approached 682 and took in the hole of
it he could feel his heart pounding with
excitement in his chest it was a huge
reptilian nightmare he could see its
scales hardening into a mighty carapace
as he approached its huge serrated fangs
its bulging sinin muscles and insane
dagger-like claws oh oh yes this would
be the one the Beast snarled at him as
he approached he just smiled puffed out
his chest and said I have heard Tales of
creatures like you glorious beasts of
scale and flesh Talon and Fang a prowess
in battle even greater than the immense
intellect hiding behind those beastial
eyes they said your kind once Ruled the
Earth from enormous stockpiles of
treasure killing and eating all who
displeased you but you were knocked from
your throne one by one by the great
warriors who walk this world no longer
until they were no more and you became
but a mere myth even I had thought you
to be nothing but fairy tales but yet
here you stand before me a living dragon
in response to ael's lofty speech the
monster merely grumbled and chided him
claiming he was little more than a
pathetic SCP Foundation lap dog
following orders and being manipulated
it showed no respect for Abel as a
valued enemy combatant merely another
nuisance thrown at it in a feudal
attempt to finish its wretched and
seemingly eternal life AEL couldn't take
such insolence he leapt forwards
bringing down his mighty chainsaw
Claymore ready to cleave the beast in
two however what he didn't expect was
the move SCP 682 pulled next throwing
its head up against the blade of Able's
sword shredding away huge chunks of
Flesh and Bone and utterly confusing
Abel in the process for the first time
in a lifetime of intense battles Abel
found himself thinking what the hell am
I up against here the force of 682s
headbutt threw Abel off balance leaving
his stomach briefly exposed but briefly
was all SC SCP 682 needed it thundered
its massive Stony fist into Abel's gut
throwing him like a ragd doll into a
nearby Rock rock with such a force that
it nearly shattered The Rock behind him
it was a force like he hadn't felt in
years he spat some bloody teeth and
grinned this was just what the doctor
ordered he issued a challenge to the
beast in a long dead language as it
seized violently regenerating rowing
taking on the Stony qualities of the
ground around it it looked like a
vengeful living Mountain a true Behemoth
of a beast in other words challenge
accepted Abel pulled an obscenely giant
maze from the shadows of his cloak the
handle 6 fet long with a chaos of
swirling blades and spikes a perfect
weapon for slaying a dragon like this he
thought to himself the two charged at
each other full of power and fury able
swung the mace once again shattering the
creature's head and flinging it back
across the battlefield with a sheer
force of its strike the decimated lizard
clawed its way into the ground devouring
The Rock in the earth integrating more
matter to fuel its regeneration but it
wasn't long before Abel was upon it
again striking mercilessly giving blows
as the monster gave brutal claw strikes
in return they were ripping each other's
bodies apart piece by piece but Abel
felt so exhilarated he could barely even
notice it was the fight of his life a
battle against a truly worthy opponent
this was Heaven Abel leaped into the air
and Unleashed a volley of deadly shakum
down onto the Beast shredding into its
reinforced flesh as the force of gravity
brought him down he pulled a mighty axe
from his cloak and bellowed A Warrior's
Roar as he brought it down splattering
into the nightmarish body of SCP
682 however this did nothing to even
slow the Beast Down it flipped over
slashing Abel with its claws when abble
stumbled it leaped on top of him
unleashing devastating slashes and
punches onto the falling warrior with
the speed of a machine gun firing when
it raised its claw to deal with the
killing blow though Abel once again
turned the tables he produced a giant
pair of mechanical scissors from thin
air and sliced off both of SCP 682s four
legs the Beast descended with its Mighty
Jaws to devour Abel but he kicked up
with freakish strength behind his bladed
boot the sheer force of the kick flipped
SCP 682 onto its back now it was ael's
turn to execute his opponent
though on some level he thought it would
be an awful shame to lose such a
terrific beast from this world of
cardboard still a battle is a battle and
this is how they go he jumped on to 682
and went berserk slashing into it
relentlessly with blade after blade
pulling out a new one every time the old
one broke down from his sheer ferocity
he screamed an incoherent battle Fury
tearing slicing ripping rening yes yes
yes yes yes as Abel stepped away to
breathe the Beast began to regenerate
releasing a shock wave that started to
warp reality around it but Abel wouldn't
have this no he would give this Beast No
Quarter it was time to present the true
pain he was Notorious for he pulled a
long sword from his cloak and charged
taking air and bringing it down towards
SCP 682s head the Beast sensing the
Warrior's presence opened its mouth
unleashing a Chasm of horrifying teeth
within the two were on a fierce
collision course as the Jaws closed able
descended both roared an infinite rage
and blood lust both combatants fell to
the ground just twitching oh what a
glorious terrible day it had been
neither had died for good but both would
remember this incredible battle forever
when Abel awoke once more in his dark
stone coffin he did so with a smile what
a battle what a fight what a truly
honorable Pursuit after so long being
bored and unfulfilled he found an
opponent that got his blood pumping once
more his stomach grumbled a post battle
Feast was an order now where did they
put that magic pizza box please good sir
I beseech you as a man of science nay as
a man of reason you mustn't stifle my
research at this critical juncture you
have no idea how close I am to finding a
cure for this blasted pestilence I need
only a handful of Liv subjects to
complete my research the plague doctor's
emphatic pleas fell on deaf ears as a
stoneface researcher took notes on his
latest pontifications the doctor whom
these claws had reduced so rudely to a
mere number SCP 049 banged his gloved
fist up against the wall and to think he
once thought of these men as as
intellectual equals fellow Travelers on
the road to Scientific Enlightenment
what a positively sick joke before the
doctor got another chance to appeal for
his right to experiment the researcher
left him alone once more a truly sad
State of Affairs nobody appreciated a
true scientist in this day and age it
was sure to be another day of
languishing alone in his cell wishing he
had the capacity to do more so he was
surprised as anyone when when the alarm
started going off and the door of his
cell swung open automatically the plague
doctor stepped out of his cell and into
the Hall where many other humanoid
anomalies were roaming confused as to
why they'd been suddenly released what
was happening as it turned out what was
happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high press nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly trained
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over 2 weeks and they did a
fine job of lowering the metaphorical
draw bridge for a heavily armed Invasion
Force the guards who weren't plants were
quickly murdered by the infiltrators and
even some of the on-site task forces
were quickly overwhelmed and gunned down
by the high Precision rifles of the
chaos insurgency's finest while the
frontliners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
Foundation agents and cast Insurgency
mercenaries clashed Sabers high priority
anomalies like SCP 049 simply wandered
the facility watching the Calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
Foundation Personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though H this definitely won't do
my research any good unless I can escape
and find my way to a suitable laboratory
ooh now there is an idea but his
scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his Aven exos skull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it momentarily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to take
another swing before the Insurgent could
do anything the plague doctor lunged out
with practice speed grasping him by the
throat immediately everything went black
and the Insurgent limp corpse collapsed
to the ground s right the doctor
internally mused soldiers attacking
Medics is violating even the most basic
rules of gentlemanly warfare then
another flash of immense pain as a
different rifle butt collided with the
back of it his head the doctor fell to
one knee feeling dizzy but before he
could retaliate he felt the two sharp
prongs of a cattle prod pressing up
against his neck the Sudden Rush of
electricity surged through his neck
sending his muscles into a wave of
involuntary spasms the insurgents
crowding around him chimed in with their
own agonizing cattle prods relentlessly
shocking him until the flashes of white
hot pain soon became an oppressive
blanket of total dark even on his most
cantankerous days the SC Foundation had
never treated him like this when he
eventually came to he was still in
darkness standing upright with high-tech
shackles holding every limb in place it
was beyond uncomfortable for the poor
plague doctor but it succeeded in the
task of keeping him under control he
couldn't move an inch there were muffled
voices beyond the dark beyond the
confines of this new containment the
modulated gas mask voices of insurgents
and something else faintly accented
oddly familiar but he couldn't quite
place it soon the voices were replaced
by another sound the grinding of
crowbars Levering Nails out of cheap
wood with a creaking tumble a rectangle
of bright light opened up in front of
him populated by a number of silhouettes
on either side were chaos insurgents in
familiar tactical Garb and in between
them stood a tall well-groomed man with
an expensive looking purple smoking
jacket and a pencil mustache for a few
fractions of a second his face was a
portrait of excitement but as he took in
the sight of the plague doctor standing
before him all the joy drained from his
snoody countenance what the hell am I
looking at here the man in the smoking
jacket said the doctor indignant add
such a response from the man who'
presumably ordered his assault rasped a
man of science good sir the man in the
smoking jacket ignored him and continued
to berate the chaos insurgents with an
odd level of confidence for someone
reprimanding trained cold-blooded
Killers I wanted SCP 650 the startling
statue not this clownish renfair
cosplayer what the hell did I pay you
Ruffians for I was told you chaos
insurgents were the very best at this
and for your FY price I expect
Excellence the ran continued much like
this leaving everyone in attendance the
insurgents the plague doctor feeling
thoroughly exhausted by him and unable
to do anything about it you see this
wasn't just any chaos Insurgency client
your average tinpot dictator or arm
stealer you know the time this was the
one and only Pascal Legette one of the
most famous or rather Infamous anarch
collectors in the game he'd been a
founding Person of Interest for years
due to his dealings with the chaos
Insurgency and Marshall Carter and dark
limited all to the end of expanding his
anarch collection but his vast wealth
and connections had always shielded him
from Foundation probes for those
unfamiliar with the subculture an art
short for anomalous art is exactly what
it sounds like artistic projects with
anomalous properties to give it that
extra kick one of the most popular
groups of Interest dealing in an art is
the iconic are we cool yet which
incidentally had recently excommunicated
Pascal Legette for being an exceedingly
wealthy uptight Square who really didn't
represent the collective's rebellious
ethos and considering his response was
to pay the chaos Insurgency to raid site
19 for a few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
sa to say he wasn't taking it well look
we got you that other Statue and that
thing killed four of our best guys so
how about we just call it even said one
of the insurgents I'm sure you can have
fun with bird brain here too Pascal
tutted and reluctantly dismissed The
Hired Guns having the plague doctor here
definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate an art exhibition to put are we
cool yet
worthless magn to shame but he would
make do with what he had perhaps he
could say that 049 was a commentary on
the everpresent nature of disease in
Mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his wooden box to a glass one
in one of lett's many opulent hallways
there were other glass cases on either
side of him and more on the other side
of the hall all too reinforced for the
plague doctor to even smash through it
on his own damn it Legette own private
Anar exhibition probably wedged between
his oversized dining room and his jewel
encrusted crapper occasionally Pascal
himself would jaunt down the hallway to
gaze upon his new stolen anarch pieces
and of course the plague doctor would
try his best to reason with him I am a
patient man M leet but this is simply
barbaric by what right do you imprison
me here is your intention to deprive the
world the entire human race of my
valuable medical breakthroughs could you
live with that on your conscience good
sir there was never any meaningful
response the plague doctors soon learned
that Pascal Legette didn't like his art
interactive it was simply meant to
languish away in a glass box being
watched being passively looked at those
chaos Insurgency Lots hadn't even
bothered to bring his notebook or
medical bag so he was without the tools
to even perform his experiments as
loathed as he was to admit it this was
even worse than being mocked up by the
SCP Foundation but all this wasn't
entirely unfamiliar there was something
in the glass box across from the plague
doctor that he vaguely recognized back
from site 19 he' never seen it up close
but he'd heard researchers speaking
about it and even seen a few pictures
and such a strange construction it was a
peculiar halfhazard sculpture made from
concrete rebar and spray paint quite
ugly in this humble doctor's opinion but
there was something oddly entrancing
about it and for reasons beyond the
doctor's recollection four of lett's men
stood around the glass box in where it
was being stored always watching the men
were frequently switched in and out as
though they were watching in shifts
always fixing their Gaze on its peculiar
malformed body maybe it was all the
electrical shocks and knocks to the head
but he just couldn't remember why Pascal
was having the Peace So carefully
observed but he knew on some Primal
level that the secret to this would
perhaps be the key to his own Escape if
only he could remember still time passed
Pascal drifted in and out sometimes with
guests the plague doctor had learned not
to speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe OB erve until
his observations bore fruit he noticed
that Pascal's guests all people who
looked equally as wealthy and pompous as
Pascal himself all seemed to look right
over him and instead focus on the ugly
statue across the hall still forever
observed by any four of Pascal's men
some of them looked actively nervous
just being in its presence curious the
plague doctor made a mental note of this
just as he did when Pascal gave his
guests a reassuring pat on the shoulder
and told them please calm yourself it's
harmless while my Personnel are keeping
an eye on it little by little the plague
doctor's memories of his Infamous
neighbor had begun to return he knew
what he must do to escape now all he
needed to do was wait for the perfect
moment soon enough Pascal's Mansion was
filled with a bevy of anart snobs from
hither and yarn a private Suare to show
off his new collection they wandered the
halls in three-piece Tuxedos and
designer ballroom dresses sipping
champagne from imported Crystal all such
lovely refined High Society people and
if the good doctor's plan went off as he
intended they would all be such lovely
refined High Society corpses the plague
doctor waited until mercifully he and
the four members of personnel watching
the sculpture were the only ones left in
the hallway he'd been so good so patient
that none of the men guarding the
sculpture at present had ever heard him
make a noise he was so invisible to them
that that in all likelihood they
probably didn't even notice he could
make a sound and that worked for his
purposes just fine though in any case if
he wanted this to work he would need to
time his plan perfectly even a fraction
of a second out of place and the whole
thing would have dire consequences still
the doctor was still a Frenchman at
heart and as a Frenchman he knew he
would rather die nobly in the process of
Escape than remain captured by this
worthless buffoon he'd be sure to take
as many of these men down with him in
the process as he was able the plague
doctor exhaled deeply drawing a lung
full of air then bellowed as loud as he
possibly could the sudden unexpected
noise was so shocking that it joged the
four Watchers almost reflexively to turn
and look at him and in the split second
that they did the plague doctor closed
his eyes in the dark time seemed to move
slower perhaps due to the doctor's Keen
Focus cultivated over many a century he
listened carefully to the sequence of
sounds
glass shattering four choked gasps in
sequence four brutal crunches then Nan
seconds later more glass shattering the
plague doctor's eyes snapped open just
in time just as predicted the sculpture
being entirely unobserved had smashed
through its glass case murdering all
four members of personnel by snapping
their necks and then smashed through his
own glass case to do the same to him the
plague doctor had cut it so close in
fact that he opened his eyes to the face
of the sculpture staring into his own
its concrete limbs wrapped around his
neck very good timing indeed with a sigh
of relief the plague doctor slipped out
of the sculpture's concrete grasp and
backed down the hallway keeping his gaze
fixed stun the sculpture the entire time
he had heard it decimate Pascal's men he
certainly didn't fancy undergoing the
same fate the second the plague doctor
backed around the corner rendering the
sculpture or as the SCP Foundation
called it SCP 173 out of sight he could
hear terrify F screaming coming from the
other end of the hall he was not a
sadistic man but the plague doctor would
be lying if he told you he didn't take
just a little bit of pleasure in hearing
that sound somewhere else in the vast
Mansion of Pascal Legette the sculpture
was slaughtering its way through
servants and party guests while the
plague doctor searched for some kind of
exit anyone who dared get in his way was
given a Swift and merciless Touch of
death sending their body unceremoniously
to the ground anyone in his way was
preventing him from finding a cure for
the pestilence and thus endangering
countless lives it was of course
regrettable to have to kill anyone but
some sacrifices must be made for the
greater good of mankind well it's not
necessarily always regrettable per se on
his way out while the murderous Rampage
of SCP 173 seemed to distract anyone of
note the plague doctor just so happened
to encounter a fleing pascal Legette
hoping to find some kind of Escape
himself it seemed that now fate was on
his side once more to have his Jailer
right here in the palm of his hand would
be such a perfect Parting Gift funnily
enough Pascal was far more talkative to
him now he rattled off a rapid fire
series of threats bribes and pleas
claiming in the end that he never meant
any harm he was the one who freed the
plague doctor from the SCP Foundation
they were on the same side here all this
was for the art no offense was ever
intended Pascal Legette simply lived for
art then die for it good sir the plague
doctor said and with a single touch
Pascal's eyes rolled up into the back of
his head and he fell to the ground dead
it was one of the few non-scientific
deaths that he felt truly no guilt for
after some time searching the screams
around the rest of the Mansion
eventually went silent that did wonders
for his focus it didn't take long for
the plague doctor to locate an exit a
fine mahogany door with elaborate
adornments be a man as Gody as Pascal
and began strolling towards it his chest
swollen with pride and a sense of
accomplishment then he blinked and a few
feet in front of him stood the sculpture
it was there so suddenly that the plague
doctor fell backwards in shock but he
devoted everything to keeping an eye on
that monstrosity with everyone else in
the Mansion presumably dead at this
point it had now come back for him it
stood there staring silently ready to
exact the terrible price for freeing it
as soon as the doctor dared to Blink the
plague doctor began crawling backwards
down the hall just wanting to put some
distance between himself and the
sculpture as the seconds past he could
feel his eyes drying out until the
inevitable blink the sculpture was
standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner or later he
was going to have to bang the front door
flew open and in an instant the hallway
was filled with heavily armed troops all
wearing the familiar black and gray of
the SCP Foundation the plague doctor had
never been so relieved to see the
organization that had kept him locked up
for so many decades for once they'd
saved him from something even worse of
course the sculpture didn't say anything
but the disappointment of losing that
one more victim seemed to radiate off of
it like a lingering bad smell the plague
doctor willingly gave himself up and
heavy machinery was brought in to pick
up SCP 173 with the help of the iPods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit Pascal had gotten
away with his Shady dealings for years
but the Brazen attack he funded against
site 19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can happily tell you that that nobody
was disappointed by the evening the
plague doctor was happy to be back in
his cell his research could continue
here and in time he knew that the
Personnel of the SCP Foundation would
listen to reason and comply with his
demands after all science Marches On
regardless of who chooses to march with
it but he would forever feel a little
nervous in sight 19 after that knowing
the concrete monster he was sharing the
building with he hoped that if ever
there was another Containment Breach in
involving that thing that it didn't feel
like paying him a visit for Old Time
sake SCP 049 also known as the plague
doctor is an SCP Foundation fan favorite
This Charming anomalous surgeon can
terrify with a glance and kill with a
touch in terms of his Origins his
methods and his thought process around a
disease he calls the pestilence this is
one of the most mysterious scps out
there and thankfully we didn't have to
investigate this one alone we made a
community post asking you the fans of
SCP explained to give us your questions
and theories about the good doctor that
we all hope doesn't give house calls and
you didn't disappoint let's grab our
masks and hand sanitizer and take a look
at what you had to say about SCP
049 first the questions Bob candle asked
why does he refuse to tell researchers
about the pestilence that's a good
question and also one of the biggest
mysteries surrounding 04 9's lore for
the uninitiated the pestilence also
known as the great dying is the nickname
given to an unknown disease that SCP 049
has dedicated his life to curing
whatever curing means to him when asked
by Foundation researchers 049 refuses to
give up even the most basic information
about the pestilence such as how he
diagnoses it what its effects are or how
it's transmitted it seems that part of
the reason that 049 refuses to tell
researchers about it is that he
apparently assumes that they as fellow
doctors inherently know what he's
talking about when he brings up the
pestilence he has acted with confusion
and frustration during questioning and
049 seems to believe that the pestilence
is such common knowledge among medical
practitioners that it would be a waste
of time to explain it if he even had the
words to do so Dad gamer 56 asked why is
he so Cooperative if humans have the
pestilence he wants to cure so bad one
of the most remarkable things about 049
is how reasonable he's been with
Foundation staff in the past he's polite
friendly and treats his jailers as
equals when he's not murdering them and
turning them into zombies but that is a
good question if he believes humans have
the pestilence why is he so Cooperative
with them thankfully the answer here is
simple while 049 believes that the
pestilence is widespread he doesn't
believe that every human is carrying it
in fact when he was first contained by
the foundation and brought into an SCP
facility he complimented the staff on
how little pestilence there was inside
the building compared to the outside
while we don't know what leads 049 to
think a person is healthy or diseased we
do know there is a distinction and he's
Cooperative with those he sees as
healthy stard doggo gaming asked how
would he interact with 610 AKA The Flesh
that hates I wonder if he would view the
infected as pestilence another great
question 610 is an extremely dangerous
saric SCP that presents as a zombie
likee virus that causes horrific fleshy
mutations because of the extremely high
infection rate of the flesh that hates
it's been quarantined in its present
location in the isolated Siberian
Wilderness while it would be too
dangerous to bring anyone or anything
into contact with the flesh we're
betting that 049 would find the flesh
utterly repulsive whether even he would
be able to cure this horrific infection
is another question
the flesh that hates is best left alone
at all costs M Cipher 50 asked SCP 049
notebook appears to be written in a
language no human can decipher could
another SCP like 343 or 662 decode The
Notebook the answer to this is a solid
maybe these two scps known as God and Mr
Deeds respectively maybe able to
translate the contents of 04 9's
mysterious leatherbound notebook the
problem is given that we've seen 049 is
a pretty terrible doctor when it comes
to anything other than raising mutant
zombies from the dead the contents of
his notebook might just be as useless as
the interviews with him have proven to
be that said it probably is worth a try
just to find out if he's actually been
pretending to write this whole time
Green Angel snake YT asked do other
living creatures like pigs cats or
literally any animal have this thing he
calls the pestilence what even are the
living things he considers cured to the
best of our knowledge 049 only believes
humans can contract the pestilence how
do we know this this leads us to our
next question Mia the hot dog asked if
he touches the immortal lizard will the
lizard die and be rid of disease or will
the lizard be immune or will it attack
the doctor the foundation did attempt to
terminate 682 with 049 but the effort
was unsuccessful 049 when encountering
the lizard commented that only humans
can contract the pestilence when he
tried to touch 682 the lizard swiped at
him with its claws 049 then requested to
leave and later interviews revealed that
the plague doctor felt emotionally
disturbed by his time with 682 gamer
duck YT asked where did he originally
come from well evidence suggests that
049 is extremely old and very well
traveled he was first discovered by the
foundation in the town of montabon in
southern France given that he speaks
fluent medieval French as its first
language it's safe to assume that France
is probably his country of origin and
could have existed for hundreds of years
if not longer interestingly his famous
plague doctor appearance is more similar
to those first worn by Italian doctors
in the 17th century which only deepens
the mystery of SCP
049 Garrett eborn asked why does he
insists that he isn't doing harm when
he's clearly in violation of his
hypocritic oath 049 does seem to regret
the harm he causes but he also believes
that the small sacrifices are necessary
in the quest to cure the pestilence also
a fun little history lesson given that
04 9's knowledge of medicine appears to
be medieval meaning potentially as early
as the 5th Century he actually would
have predated the hypocritic oath coming
into Universal use by doctors which
didn't become widespread until the 19th
century despite the oath itself first
being created around 400 BC Phoenix Fain
asked if he has to wear gloves of any
kind would he still kill you all
evidence seems to point to no only skin
to skin contact with 049 is fatal so a
good pair of gloves could really be a
lifesaver Alice Verdugo asked what would
happen if he went one-on-one with a shy
guy would he cure him or not do anything
well we can't know for sure because
scp096 aka the shy guy isn't human it's
likely that 049 wouldn't even consider
him in affected if the two came into
contact it would probably result in a
stalemate much like the time scp096
faced off against SCP 682 however if it
did come to blows between the two 096 is
undeniably a much more dangerous
combatant and may be able to narrowly
defeat the plague doctor in a direct
confrontation while in its rage State
anything goes asked if he died could he
bring himself back to life or have
something prepared to bring himself back
to life like a lot of anomalies it seems
that 049 is abnormally hard to kill
given that he's seemingly impervious to
most physical damage however seeing a 04
9's Resurrection is both a lengthy
medieval process and never brings its
subjects back correctly it's likely that
if someone could successfully put 049
down he wouldn't get back up I'm not
coming asked we know that doctors are
wearing masks to protect patients but is
his mask part of his skull or face all
of of 04 9's clothes including his
plague do mask are technically part of
his body the mask is part of its bone
structure and the other clothes are like
layers of skin which leads us nicely to
the next question ream asked if the
clothing around him is skin does he shed
it we're not sure but it's definitely a
thought we all wish we could
forget God now let's take a look at some
of your more interesting theories
Clarence IAM theorized p Pence is sin
and he's trying to take it away this is
certainly an interesting Theory while we
can't find much in his file that
suggests 049 views the pestilence as a
result of sinful Behavior or the concept
of sin itself it's worth considering
that his medical background seems to
come from medieval times Medical Science
was in its infancy back then and many
still believe that diseases were the
result of loose morals or even demonic
interference so there might be some
truth to this Theory Thomas has
theorized I feel like he isn't really
bad all he wants to do is help and cure
everyone but his cure is death if we're
def finding bad as a malicious desire to
cause harm for its own sake then this
Theory holds a lot of water for all
intents and purposes it does seem that
049 does genuinely want to cure his
patients of the pestilence and he does
seem to express remorse when they die
however by his own admission his cure is
imperfect and he hasn't found full
success in curing the disease without
causing death yet cat and dog live
theorized the plague doctor has seen the
end of the world and travels in a loop
back in time aiming to eventually stop
it the pestilence is the way each
human's impact on the end of the world
is and once he touches their flesh they
realize this and die of the realization
of what they've done the plague doctor
may be looking for a human or an SCP
that is pestilence free for what reason
we don't know we don't have an awful lot
to say about this one because there's no
real evidence either way but given that
time travel does seem to be possible in
the SCP Foundation Universe it's a cool
possibility that we definitely can rule
out it does however leave a lot of loose
ends about the gaps in 04 9's knowledge
such as the fact he doesn't know about
the Black Death Vladimir lennin
theorized he's the best doctor ever he
cures depression pestilence and
sometimes his patients even come back
from the dead five-star rating this is
certainly an extremely charitable way to
view scp's 049 one that he himself would
likely very much appreciate however
considering he changes his patience into
mindless zombified mutants a better
course of action may just be to attend
therapy chaotics theorized the
pestilence is death he is literally
trying to cure death well this could be
one interpretation of why 049 resurrects
his patients as zombies death is
something that affects all living
nonanomalous humans and 049 seems to be
selective on which humans it identifies
as being infected with the pestilence as
a result it is unlikely that the
pestilence refers to death itself and
death is also likely a preferable
alternative to being turned into a
zombie by 049 experimental treatments
the blue Guardian theorized the
pestilence is an entity in our
Collective unconsciousness described in
SCP 5000 why this is an extremely
interesting Theory and one that could
hold water too if you check out our
series on SCP 5000 you'll find that the
foundation discovered a being known as
it hiding inside the collective
unconsciousness of humankind while the
foundation doesn't know about this in
our Dimension it's possible that SCP 049
does and simply doesn't realize that
everyone is infected with it yet but if
this is the case and SCP 049 realizes
that the whole world is infected is
likely to become a much more dangerous
anomaly that refuses to cooperate with
anyone Moon Leaf's 430 theorized the
pestilence is the foundation and 049 is
a disciple of the Scarlet King this is
another incredibly fun Theory however
there are two big problems the first is
that 049 has historically identified
people with no Foundation affiliation as
being infected with the pestilence and
the second even more important issue is
that SCP 049 is a highly scient ific
creature whereas the Scarlet King hates
the very idea of science with a burning
passion as a result SCP 049 and the
Scarlet King are likely natural enemies
and finally zerra theorized his theme
song should probably be gangst as
Paradise it's just a speculation though
on this Theory we wholeheartedly agree
and there you have it thanks to
everybody who sent in their great
questions and theories about SCP 049
keep an eye on our Community post to see
what anomalous entity we need your
thoughts on next got an SCP you'd really
like us to cover in a video like this in
the future let us know down in the
comments and remember to stay safe and
healthy because if you start feeling a
little under the weather you can expect
a visit from SCP 049 sometime soon the
day is January 5th 2012 at an
undisclosed off-site location Dr Bannon
leaves home and begins his commute to
work while in the car he plays a video
on his phone of his 12-year-old's
birthday party from the previous night
the sight of it makes him smile he would
need that smile he thought as today was
not like any other today was different
he had been anxious about the coming day
for several weeks now ever since the
near unanimous vote by the 05 Council
that the containment chamber of SCP 106
was to be reopened the opportunity was
too great to be wasted they said the
research that could be gained too
tempting studying SCP 106's molecular
makeup its unique ability to open a
pocket Dimension or even just the black
sludge likee substance that appeared
whenever the subject traveled through
solid objects was far too valuable to
science to be outweighed by its
potential for danger he pleaded with
them begged them but as Dr Bannon and
his team of seven researchers and
accompanyment of 40 security Personnel
began applying their protective
equipment he couldn't help but think
that he could have done more to stop
this only God knew how hard he had tried
to make them see reason he had seen what
had happened in previous containment
breaches at the facility he had seen
what had done to the poor members of the
SCP staff that became its victims Fates
worse than death limbs a mangled mess of
melted fused skin faces sunken and
Hollow with eyes and tongues burned out
he shuddered to think of what would
happen if containment failed again this
time but despite his misgivings he knew
full well that regardless of his
participation This research Mission
would go on with or without him and no
one knew as much about containing
scp-106 than he did slowly they
proceeded to dismantle each of the
containment facil outer barriers 16
separate circular Chambers surrounded as
SCP 106's inter containment facility
each filled with a variety of different
fluids fluids in each chamber varied in
consistency and viscosity from ionized
water to ammonia to kerosene scp-106 had
the peculiar ability to be able to
change its molecular makeup to meld with
objects and phase through solid forms
like walls and doors it could literally
melt into the space between walls this
made containing SC cp16 almost
impossible by conventional methods
liquids confuse the creature enough to
slow him down in theory anyways the
secondary containment Chambers were a
recent addition to the facility since
the breach incident 3 years years ago Dr
Bannon had been a new addition to the
research staff then he had joined the
team with bright eyes and a desire to
use their research to help Society
little did he know he would instead do
everything in his power to keep whatever
they found from ever leaving the
facility back then a breach in the
containment of SCP 106 led to countless
deaths of SCP Personnel when a
researcher working on the top floor of
the outer layer of the containment
facility un knowing of the danger they
were in brought his child to work one
day it was thought that the outer layers
of the facility were enough to be
considered a safe Zone from the inner
Vault that was as CP 106's containment
but it wasn't enough to stop the old man
SCP 106 preferred human prey between the
ages of 10 and 25 and the sound of a
child's cry or yell was enough to
capture its immediate attention what
preceded was unimaginable horror but
despite the unfortunate events of the
previous breach the expedition continued
their descent into the bowels of the
building after several hours of draining
individual fluid Chambers one by one and
inputting complex codes and biometric
scans from simultaneous top security
clearance Personnel at a time the
Expedition team had eventually reached
the lower levels of SCP 106's
Containment facility suspended in midair
by ELO IID electromagnetic supports in
the center of a vast Subterranean
chamber was a massive leadline steel
Cube for layers thick each layer
separated by 36 cm of empty space with
support struts between layers randomly
spaced to confuse scp-106 from being
able to phase through one layer to the
next surrounding the cube on every
surface were military-grade automated
light systems capable of 80,000 lumens a
piece spaced every 2 ft around the
perimeter of the inner containment
chamber the team felt the resolve chip
away the closer they got to the
suspended creature Dr ban in motion to
overhead surveillance cameras above the
cube and waited slowly the cube was
lowered to the ground until it hit the
floor with a soft thud that lightly
rumbled the ground above the Expedition
team's feet with a resentful look at the
Red Dot on the camera above Dr Bannon
initiated the release protocol all seven
researchers inputed their key cards and
submitted themselves to retina scans as
the 40 security Personnel established
defensive positions on every side of the
leadline cube for a moment everyone held
their breath in silence you could almost
feel the thumping of everyone's nervous
heartbeats as they looked on to Dr
Bannon as he pulled out his key card
everyone knew that as soon as it was
scanned the barrier between them and the
old man would no longer exist if the
rest of the Personnel could see bannon's
hand shaking as he gripped the key card
tightly between his fingers it would
cause a possible mass panic among the
whole team as the spearheading
researcher on the job that day Bannon
knew what he was up against just the
same as everyone else if not more more
he knew he couldn't show the fear that
was pulsing through his veins this
wasn't his first rodeo here at the
foundation he took a moment to collect
his thoughts get a hold of yourself
Bannon he thought Dr Bannon took a deep
breath and scanned the card the door
slowly opened armed with powerful rifl
length flashlights the researchers
cautiously waited into the dark entrance
of the large Cube inside the structure
they found a cell with a solid steel
door signs of corrosion could be seen on
the door's handle and from the outer
walls of the cell rust and rotted iron
but no breaches in the Integrity of the
cell there were no more security codes
at this door it was a simple round metal
turn lock Dr bennon swallowed and began
to turn the handle open the sound of
metal echoed through the chamber as the
door creaked open each of the
researchers immediately pointed their
flashlights into the room there in the
corner standing motionless and
undisturbed stood SCP
106 the old man he stood with eyes
closed locked in a dormant State the
researchers had planned for this SCP 106
spent up to 3 months at a time in this
subdued state in between periods of
otherwise agitation where it would lash
out at its containment and attempt to
breach the research team wasted no time
they began to collect data on the
creature's biological makeup taking
whatever samples they could from the
walls and floors and recording photo and
video of the specimen while collecting
any method of conventional analysis they
could manage under the given
circumstances Dr Bannon kept an eye on
the old man's face the entire time
refusing to look away for one second for
fear of it waking in the absence of his
gaze but to his relief the creature did
not stir and the data collection process
went smoothly in a short period of time
the team had packed their gear and
proceeded to carefully Retreat from the
inner chamber of the cube making sure to
keep their lights pointed at the
creature the entire time once the team
exited the steel lined Cube they
motioned again to the camera and the
huge heavy doors of the cube closed back
in on itself the electromagnetic
supports came back online and the cube
was suspended once again in
three-dimensional space without any
immediate contact with Solid Surfaces
the security detail began packing up
their positions as everyone seemed to
take a collective sigh of relief that's
when Dr Bannon noticed the security
camera the Red Dot on the device had
stopped blinking the camera was off a
sudden feeling of dread entered Dr
bannon's stomach as he turned in time to
see all the cameras around the room
turning off before he could react the
chamber was plunged Into Darkness as the
electricity left the room in the
immediate Darkness came a deafening bang
followed by a gust of wind and the
weight of a force strong enough to shake
the ground and knock the researchers off
their feet the power of the
electromagnetic supports were down the
cube had fallen Dr Bannon shouted to his
team to immediately exit the facility he
reached for his flashlight in the
darkness he could hear screams in the
background gunfire he managed to
illuminate the space in front of him and
saw his molecular biologist Dr burn
scrambling to get her gear back up over
her shoulder leave it Dr Bannon cried
only to see a hand emerge from beneath
her and pull her down into a black
viscous substance that swallowed her
whole and then vanished into solid
concrete after hearing the cries to his
left he swung his flashlight just in
time to see him the old man had its hand
on the chest of a security personnel and
entered him exiting through the other
side leaving a gaping hole in between
bullets were useless as they seemed to
get trapped on Entry of his body slowly
melting into his skin scp-106 then
vanished into the floor and appeared
behind another member of the security
detail grabbing him by the heel and
dragging him as he pleaded and reached
out to Dr Bannon for help pulling him
halfway into the wall and then letting
go as the creature melted into the space
between the walls leaving behind half
the poor man's body bleeding and still
squirming to get away one by one he
could hear his researchers crying out
for help before their voices were
extinguished before he could think of
what to do next the power came back on
and lights flooded into the large room
he gazed at the creature as it stood
momentarily stunned by the influx of
light the old man had gone piercing
Hollow eyes in a face covered in dark
melting skin and a lipless mouth that
displayed terrible decaying teeth its
corrosive hand had a grasp on the arm of
Dr Brier the physicist burning the skin
beneath its grip as he cried out in pain
and then without warning the creature
placed a hand on the wall of the metal
cube and disappeared into it pulling the
doctor in with him into the pocket
Dimension between the walls 48 hours
later in containment site 9 19 located
in the state of data expunged SCP
Personnel opened the door to an
observation chamber where SCP 049 is Led
in wearing steel covered hand restraints
on the other side of a glass panel Dr
Blake sat impatiently watching the
humanoid creature known as SCP 049 the
plague doctor take a seat and face his
Direction Dr Blake hesitated to address
the entity that sat in front of him but
putting aside his reservations he spoke
into the microphone Blake informed SCP
049 of the recent breach that had
transpired at the SCP 106 containment
site the doctor seemed intrigued at the
news and when asked if he would provide
assistance the doctor agreed SCP 049 had
exhibited abilities to produce instances
of SCP
049-2 reanimated corpses that he alone
had the ability to control by Will in
the past the plague doctor had been
allowed certain privileges deceased
subjects for the doctor to experiment on
in his quest to finally cure for what he
referred to as the pestilence though
none of the researchers could pinpoint
exactly what the symptoms of this
perceived illness was or any specifics
about it at all however the supply of
subjects was halted after an incident
where SCP 049 struck a Personnel member
killing him instantly with his Touch of
death an ability that ceases all bodily
function upon contact since then the
plague doctor refused to cooperate
unless he was provided with live
subjects for experimentation up to this
point he had been denied but Dr Blake
needed the plague doctor's help and time
was not on his side Dr Blake agreed to
provide SCP 049 with several live
declass Personnel in return for his
assistance as we've come to learn time
and time again here on SCP explained the
foundation has no qualms about ridding
the lives of these X death row inmates
d-class are essentially the foundation's
lab rats and treating them as such is
more than worth it if dealing with an
SCP 106 Containment Breach bring in the
orange jumpsuits Splendid remarked 049
the plague doctor was taken to the
secret site of SCP 106's Containment
facility and briefed on the old man's
ability to meld and travel between walls
floors and Solid Surfaces as well as its
ability to pull objects into its own
pocket dimension of which there was
little information about SCP 049 grew
more and more intrigued by the the
description of the old man upon arriving
a laboratory was prepared at the site
for SCP 049 for proxies to serve as
lures to bait
scp-106 the team procured the bodies of
a recent public transportation bus
wreckage that had left 12 younger adults
dead as the plague doctor began his
surgeries on them Dr Bannon could think
only of the prior containment breach the
staff suffered many casualties to
personnel and ever since then anyone
under the age of 30 were barred and tree
within 20 mi of the containment site
just as Dr Bannon began to rub his
Temple to think about how they managed
to return SCP 106 to his cell that day
there was a yell of excitement marvelous
Cried Out SCP 049 the plague doctor
informed SCP staff that he had finished
his work and the surgeries had been of
Paramount success the doctor had indeed
produced 12 instances of SCP 049-2 as
predicted the subjects were horrid
Abominations some some with inverted
faces and others with added appendages
and gaping holes where limbs should be
but they were ambient and the research
staff would soon learn if they would be
enough to lure
scp-106 back into containment staring at
the dimly lit White Room crowded with
malformed ambient corpses Dr Banning
couldn't help but feel a sense of dread
filled the pit of his stomach but there
was no time to second guas with rifles
and flashlights in hand the team led the
troop of SCP 049-2 out and down the
concrete hallways and into a large
freight elevator that led down to the
vast chamber that housed the inner
containment Cube that was SCP 106's home
since arriving at the facility the Drone
likee d2s did not speak during this trip
they did not blink they simply stared
straight ahead and acted at the behest
of the plague doctor without any verbal
input the macabra parade arrived at the
entrance of the cube and proceeded
inside Dr Bannon informed SCP 49 that
the dash tws needed to make noises of
some kind to cry out if they could
anything would work as long as it was
audible enough the plague doctor nodded
his head and all 12 of the reanimated
corpses began to scream in terrifying
Unison in the hollow distance a roar was
heard in response it dripped from the
ceiling first a drop then many more
until a puddle formed on the ground in
front of the cube the plague doctor
approaching with intrigue out of the
floor rose up the creature known as
scp-106 coming face to face with the
plague doctor upon seeing the creature
SCP 049 was ecstatic he began to examine
scp-106 closely without fear of bodily
harm with lightning speed he produced a
violin Pinchers from a medicine bag of
black leather he kept under his robes
and snatched a sample of the creatur's
black viscous skin the plague doctor was
overjoyed this will lead to my greatest
work and the cure for the pestilence
once and for all but the old man did not
seem to acknowledge or even enjoy the
presence of SCP 049 and reacted
violently lashing out to strike the
plague doctor sensing danger 049 jumped
back and willed the 049 d2s to attack
the creature but before they could reach
it scp-106 melted into a pool of black
and disappeared into the floor the
instances looked around dazed another
black pool appeared under one of them
causing it to fall into the portal and
then out from the ceiling elsewhere in
the vast Stadium sized room another Pool
opened up under one of the ambient THS
sucking it down into the black abyss and
then another and another and soon loud
thuds could be heard echoing through the
chamber as bodies began to appear from
the top of the 100t ceiling falling to a
splatter on the concrete floor below
upon witnessing SCP 106's abilities
firsthand SCP P 049 nodded to Dr Bannon
as he swiftly packed up his medicine bag
and made for the door only to be blocked
by a SCP 106's materializing form the
plague doctor grew angry and struck the
neck of the old man with his cold Touch
of death but it seemed to have no effect
on SCP 106 the black substance on his
body started to creep over 04 9's hand
sizzling and Searing skin and flesh as
it went up the forearm sensing danger
the plague doctor pulled out a large
scalpel and in one quick motion sliced
off his own arm at the elbow the severed
limb fell to the floor engulfed by the
black bubbling substance scp-106 then
lunged at the doctor whose quick agility
allowed him to dodge and make for the
doorway once in the hall SCP 049 quickly
pulled out a roll of brown gauze from
his medical bag and began to wrap his
bleeding wound tight as he hurried
through the dimly lit Corridor lights
flickering on and off as SCP 049 turned
a corner a black substance appeared on
the wall in front of him and a chair
came flying out of it towards his head
the doctor dodged it but did not Dodge a
sharp metal Spike that materialized from
another hole appearing on the wall to
his left it pierced the outside of his
knee causing his movement to be slowed
hearing the sound of clanking metal the
doctor looked up in time to see a desk
falling out of another dimensional
portal above him he managed to roll
sideways missing the blow but straight
into another one of SCP 016 F's portals
causing the doctor to fall through the
wall and into the floor of the room
below with a falling crash the doctor
landed in the lower room and looked
around quickly seeking to regain his
footing the old man was nowhere to be
seen but he could hear him bumping in
the darkness traveling through the walls
of the building the plague doctor
quickly analyzed the office room for
something useful on the wall he found a
map of the facility and studied the
schematics on the floor was a dead body
he crouched down close to it and stabbed
it with a syringe from his cloak
animating the corpse and commanding it
to run serving as a distraction to lead
SCP 106 away so he could make it to the
adjoining hallway just a few hundred ft
away that was the Armory limping from
his injured leg the plague doctor waited
for the old man to be led away as he
made it to the room he began tearing
through the Weaponry that lined and
leaned up against the walls in every
direction ignoring the automatic rifles
as they were useless there he found what
he had been searching for for flash
grenades as the form of another black
portal began to materialize in front of
him he pulled the pin and tossed the
grenade in that putrid puddle a blast of
light erupted from within followed by
the sound of the creature recoiling in
pain the plague doctor pulled another
pin and another and in this manner he
led scp-106 toward the secondary
containment facilities that had begun
filling with fluid when he reached a
level where he could recognize the smell
of kerosene he stopped there he waited
as cp16 emerged from the darkness in
front of him it snarled and howled
spitting black bits of tar as its
gnarled yellow teeth came close to the
plague doctor's face the plague doctor
calmly turned and waited out of the
half-filled room SC SCP 106 tried to
Lunge at him to follow but it could not
it found itself rooted in liquid unable
to easily open a portal in the space
between the walls stepping out of the
room the plague doctor reached into his
cloak and pulled out a large match from
his leather bag without glancing back he
struck the match and gave a ginger toss
into the Flames sliding the door closed
behind him the resulting explosion and
subsequent Inferno damaged the walls of
the secondary containment facility and
caused significant seismic activity
within the outer walls of the
containment site emergency lights
flickered on and off in the darkness and
debris rained down from the ceiling in
every direction in this Haze of rubble
the plague doctor picked himself up off
the ground and began to dust his cloak
clean with the one hand he had left
satisfied he took a contens sigh and
began to make for the exit to the
outside world where he would resume his
quest to rid the Earth of the pestilence
that had plagued mankind though an
unexpected surprise made him pause a
flaming corpse began to emerge from a
black hole in the wall beside him SCP
106 intact and hole the Flames slowly
seeping into his skin until they were
all extinguished and only smoke smoke
Rose from his body this time the doctor
was not so fast to react the creature
grabbed him by the face and slammed it
into the nearby wall cracking the marble
surface the black substance pulled
around the plague doctor's face SCP 106
opened a portal in the wall pushing the
doctor's head into it the events that
followed afterwards are difficult to put
together as camera footage from the
facility suffered severe damage due to
SCP 049 explosion of the secondary
containment Chambers SCP 106 was found
back inside his cell in the containment
Cube back to his dormant state where he
would remain again for the next few
months that is until he would feel the
need to hunt prey once again as the
doors of the 40 layer steel Cube closed
the electromagnetic supports came back
online and the fluid Chambers repaired
and refilled the committee is currently
voting on whether or not to allow SCP
106's Containment facility to be opened
again for now the world could rest once
more Dr Bannon could take a sigh of
relief but for how long he thought for
that there was no way to tell a world
that's lost its way needs a Healer
someone to patch up its wounds and tend
to its pain it needs a doctor when day
broke the sun turned from a Giver of
Life the thing that wakes the rooster
and makes the crops grow to an
indiscriminate killer wiping out all
organic life forms the world seemed
truly lost but one anomalous being made
it his goal to soothe the hurt to make
it safe to step into the light once more
the plague doctor had done his best with
the limited resources afforded to him at
the abandoned Foundation site the
scientists had left behind all of their
equipment when the Red Sun came when
they all were transformed he had
appointed himself the site director
willing to take up the mantle when no
one else would he had assembled a brave
brilliant team of fellow anomalies the
bothast Dr speno the eloquent
adventurous Lord Blackwood and the
charismatic but ravenous Ferdinand their
had of course been those who scoffed at
his vision who did not share his Noble
goal the Abominable possessive mask
taunted him persistently trying its best
to get under his kitous skin but he did
not have time to waste on Such trivial
psychological games and he ignored its
taunts to focus on the work it hadn't
been easy captain caping one of the
infected specimens the former human
being turned mass of oozing gelatinous
flesh by the Unholy light in the sky one
had made its way into the abandoned
facility sliding its way across the
floor with an air of confused malice it
wanted to hurt but it didn't know where
it was who it was anymore but it was
frightened the plague doctor could tell
a good physician always knows and can
sense the fear and pain of a suffering
person it made his heart ACH to see and
he knew there was only one thing to do
try to make this poor soul well again
everyone please assist me in escorting
the patient to my laboratory the doctor
called out this was once a man and I
believe with our combined intellect and
resources we can return him to his
former State Ferdinand took a step
toward the slimy creature licking his
lips a bit do you think I could have
just a little bit of it oh I'm so hungry
dog
he begged no no it would go against my
oath as a physician to allow any more
harm to come to this poor fellow the
plague doctor shook his head solemnly
ferame pouted but did not press the
issue further no the doctor rubbed his
gloved hands together in anticipation of
the next task it is imperative we
contain our new friend safely if you
would please he gestured to several of
his previous patients now reanimated and
ready to Aid him with his resar search
the shuffling figure surrounded the
Blobby entity ushering it down the hall
confused lost with no real sense of a
plan left in its mushy Consciousness the
creature followed where it was led the
group made it back to the doctor's
laboratory shouted Dr Spano from his
perch at top a nearby shelf yes indeed
the doctor replied his standard
operating table wouldn't do for such a
special patient I have nowhere to place
the restraints you see I will have to
make do with the floor f my bag if you
please the giant rushed to his side
dropping the bag at his feet if he dies
then can I eat it he asked shifting from
one foot to the other like a child
asking a parent for a second helping of
ice cream if I am unable to save the
patient which I do deem unlikely then
yes you may help me dispose of their
Remains the doctor relented but I do not
hope it comes to that he pressed a hand
to his beak in deep thought for a moment
before opening his bag and pulling out a
syringe filled with clear liquid to
begin we must sedate the patient he had
no way to find a veins and so he plunged
the needle into the nearest section of
the creature's soft surface injecting a
dose of sedative then he waited the
using motion of the entity slowed and
stopped it laid there on the ground a
still mound of Flesh save for the
occasional expanding and Contracting
motion almost as if it was breathing
excellent now there was no risk of the
patient fleeing the operating room mid
procedure he could truly begin it was an
arduous process that took hours of
effort of taking small tissue samples
attempting to make incisions only for
the flesh to fuse back together seconds
after the scalpel was taken away this
was truly an advanced illness unlike
anything he had ever seen before it was
enough to make him question his
abilities as a doctor but he shook the
thought away self-pity never helped
anyone after about 8 hours of continuous
work he had a break bre through a
solution he had created long ago a thick
green liquid sealed in a Dusty jar had a
miraculous effect when dripped onto one
of the tissue samples the melted flesh
reconstituted became solid and human
again H he cried out unable to restrain
the sudden joy that leaped into his
heart this could be it very carefully he
filled a dropper with the green liquid
if these initial trials had been
successful then perhaps he couldn't f
fin the thought best not to get ahead of
himself he crossed to his patient and
slowly began to pour the solution over
the creature's viscous surface he
watched as the flesh toughened coming
together into a surface resembling human
skin it was working it was working but
then the creature began to quiver
shaking uncontrollably like a bowl of
jelly in an earthquake the surface
rippled and the doctor could hear a
high-pitched whine filling the room then
with a wet pop the patient exploded
sending chunks of Flesh splattering all
over the room painting the walls and
ceiling the doctor cried out in shock
and horror and in spite of himself fell
to his knees in despair he had been so
close but still he had failed and who
could say when he would find another
test subject if he would ever find a
cure I'm afraid I do not know what to do
now the doctor admitted Fernand side the
next several days passed in a haze the
doctor paced around his la laboratory
mulling over his possible mistakes again
and again he had rushed the process he
was certain of that now it was a novice
mistake the sort of thing he might have
done a century or two ago how could he
have been so foolish how could he have
made that innocent pay the price for his
own hubris as the doctor locked himself
away in his mind Palace Fernand occupied
himself by practicing his favorite songs
Lord Blackwood rode on the massive man's
shoulder as he sang through the Opera
Don giovan bnie I once saw a production
of this at the theatr LA fenice in
Venice Lord Blackwood interjected his
Rhino pores twitching in delight at the
memory marvelous production marvelous
City I was there hunting a rogue tatel
worm wrecking Havoc through the canals I
nearly lost my life on that
Voyage would you all be quiet for once
in your miserable lives a voice hissed
from the Shadows there in the doorway
its face fixed in a frown was the
possessive math
black slime Dri from its eyeh holes
spilling down onto the plastic mannequin
body it had taken hold of listening to
you both is worse than being locked in
that infernal box The Mask looked around
the room searching for
someone where is the good doctor it
asked voice dripping with
disdain still moping about counting his
failures ignore him my fine fellow Lord
Blackwood whispered to Fernand only
those with weak constitutions and no
achievements of their own spend their
days dragging others down when you have
lived as long as I you will learn
[Laughter]
this careful my
Lord I'll stop by the kitchen and find
some salt to pour on you if you wish to
fight me then challenge me to a fair
duel like a man the colorful slug
bellowed drawn by the sudden shouting
the doctor walked into the room what is
all this
commotion oh good The Mask clapped its
plastic hands together its face warping
back into an eerie
smile there you are this has all been so
dreadfully
boring I came to see the remnants of
your greatest shame are there still
blood stains on the floor in your
pathetic little
laboratory you are a villain the doctor
seed uncomfortable with the air of
conflict in the room ferand and Lord
Blackwood quickly exited to find another
space where they could sing and share
stories in
peace I simply speak the truths no one
wants to hear the mask crossed to the
doctor's side with a series of light
dance-like steps that made the mannequin
body
Creek in fact I have quite a few truths
to share today I've been outside you see
whatever's become of the sun only
affects organic beings and so he
gestured from his ceramic face to his
plastic
body I am quite safe from its Rays
you've been outside the doctor couldn't
keep the Curiosity out of his voice he
was a scientist after all my yes would
you like to know what I've seen black
slime dripped from the m mask's mouth
pulling on the floor with a sizzling
sound I in no mood for tricks the doctor
warned the mask held up his hands in
mock
surrender no tricks doctor but if You'
rather take your chances outside and see
for yourself I can take my leave now no
the doctor shook his head please do tell
me it's so much worse than you could
could even imagine the mask's words were
Bleak but its tone was
gleeful everywhere you look out there
the light has made
monsters humans dogs cats mice the wild
beasts of the forest all melted down to
creatures you would not even
recognize but that isn't all no that is
not all there are massive beasts 10 ft
tall and more made from dozens and
dozens of the creatures coming together
they fuse and meld into one giant entity
roving the streets in search of more and
more bodies to add to the pile and
oozing gaping M hunger and hate that
seeks only to consume and destroy it
calls out to surviving humans in the
voices of their fallen loved ones tugs
at their heartstrings to lure them out
of their hiding places and then it
around them with fleshy tentacles
pulling them in until they are no more
just another part of the
monster oh doctor it's Terror it's an
Abomination I could watch it all
day the doctor wanted to believe the
mask was lying that it was trying to
torment with him with awful Fabrications
but after all he had seen so far he knew
that its words were true get out of my
sight he said or or what the mask stared
him down with its unmoving smile I've
seen what you do to your hosts you know
your body won't last forever the doctor
growled true maybe next I'll take
yours The Mask laughed a long dark laugh
of something ancient and evil then it
turned turned and walked out the door
leaving the doctor alone he spent so
much of his time that way lately his
assistants were preoccupied his former
patients provided no real company and so
he did what he did best carry on in
solitude he couldn't be sure how long he
stood there in silence thinking of what
the mask told him he knew it was
dangerous outside knew he was up against
powerful destructive forces but it was
even worse than he had thought what if
the world was truly doomed what if this
was how it all ended not with a bang but
with a great melting suddenly the doctor
heard a sound he hadn't heard since the
sun turned wrong a scream a human scream
could it be he had to see for himself he
grabbed his bag of tools and rushed down
the hall his robes fluttering behind him
there it was again a different human
voice screaming in Terror as he grew
closer to the sound he could hear
footsteps various other voices
overlapping with each other he rounded
the corner and there they were a group
of five humans wrapped in tattered
clothes dirty and exhausted behind them
was the entrance to what looked like a
tunnel somehow they found a secret
passage and made their way inside then
he saw what made them scream clearly
these people were afraid and
unaccustomed to the sight of a man of
ferdinand's stature especially when the
man was drooling and staring at them
with hunger in his eyes he would have to
diffuse the situation quickly hello
welcome we mean you no harm strangers he
stepped between Fernand and the humans a
man at the front of the group brandished
a firearm pointing the barrel directly
at the doctor's beak please sir there's
no need for violence what are you the
man stammered the other members of his
party cowered behind him an ally if you
will permit me to be I'm a physician you
see working on a cure for the condition
that plagues the world with a shaking
hand the man slowly lowered his gun he
did not put it away though you've
figured out a cure for those things I am
in the process of developing it so far I
have not been successful but perhaps
with your help how do we know we can
trust you the man demanded how am I
supposed to know you're not part of this
do you know who this man is Fernand
bowed this is Dr John Watson and I am
detective Sherlock Holmes the greatest
investigator in the world there isn't a
case we can solve the man looked at the
woman next to him in the two shared a
wide-eyed glance this this guy's crazy
he whispered furtively put your weapon
away and we can speak more calmly the
doctor proposed at this inopportune
moment a few of his revived patients
shambled into view and the man screamed
again this time he fired his weapon
shooting at one of the walking corpses
the bullets ricocheted off the walls and
several of the patients were hit please
stop with no other option the doctor
grabbed the man's arm hoping to get a
hold of the weapon and end the potential
Bloodshed as soon soon as his gloved
hand made contact the man went limp and
dropped to the ground with a hard thud
the woman next to him pulled him into
her arms checking his pulse he's dead
she shrieked tears streaming down her
face I I am so sorry my lady I did not
intend she grabbed the man's gun and
trained it on the doctor once more you
killed him she cried the other survivors
were too shaken to speak to move one of
them had his back turned to the group
and was staring into the darkness behind
him whatever he was looking at it was
worse than the chaos unfolding but no
one noticed the beige flesh tentacle
snaking along the ground until it was
too late until it had grabbed a hold of
the man's ankle and dragged him into the
tunnel with a shriek of pure
unadulterated Terror the woman nearly
dropped her gun at the sound whirling
around to see what had happened deep in
the tunnel the screen warped into a wet
gurgling sound and then there was
silence for a long moment but then
something worse a gooey slimy sound the
sound of something enormous something
soft and fleshy making its way through
the tunnel and toward the group another
tentacle curled around the edge of the
opening then another joined it something
emerged that might have once been a hand
but had melted into something
unrecognizable the monster emerged piece
by piece until the doctor could see the
entire thing it looked like a heap of
people dozens of them clambering on top
of each other wrapping their limbs
together until their flesh and insides
emptied out and fused into a shapeless
Mass it moved a bit like a giant slug
slimy and slow but it seemed to know it
could take its time as the survivors
scrambled back away from it Ferdinand
and the doctor taking a few steps back
of their own the sound of human voices
filled the room there were
unintelligible Whispers the soft giggle
of a child a woman weeping come and be
with us a little boy's voice broke
through the cacophony Mommy I miss you
don't you miss me the woman with the gun
let out a broken SOB Billy she sniffled
it's me mommy the innocent voice
continued emanating from somewhere deep
inside the Monstrous mass that crept
along the ground swelling and grasping
with its ropey tentacles come play with
me outside all you have to do is come
outside Madame the creature is not who
it claims to be the doctor spoke up and
it seemed to shake the woman out of a
trance you're not my son she hissed
squeezing the trigger and firing at the
monster the bullet made contact P with a
wet useless slap and disappeared into
the roving pile of the Fallen she fired
again and again but the monster did not
stop it did not even slow down it lashed
out with a tentacle that wrapped around
her throat in a single fluid motion and
snapped her neck with a crack she fell
to the ground and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no
longer visible she hadn't been taken by
the Sun not yet but she was still lost
the rest of the survivors followed their
screams silence one by one the doctor
felt the same overwhelming sense of
hopelessness wash over him the same
shadow that had passed over him when he
lost the last patient what could he do
he was one physician against an
overpowering force of Destruction
perhaps he could touch it and would fall
dead like so many other organisms before
but what if it didn't What If instead it
wrapped around his body and squeezed the
life from him what if it carried him out
into that cursed sunlight and he melted
away like the others he had to make it a
decision because the Beast was advancing
toward him doctor ferand shouted it's
going to destroy our facility indeed the
creature was flailing its appendages
around beating against the walls and
trying to tear down steel and plaster
break down the shelter until they too
were exposed to the deadly light I'm
afraid this may be the end my friend the
doctor lamented I can see no hope for us
now no Ferdinand shook his head let me
save us let me lead it back outside
you'll be taken the doctor cried perhaps
not I am a magnificent specimen after
all I believe I can withstand the Sun
and return to continue our work together
Fernand scooped his sleeping Lord
Blackwood from his shoulder and placed
him gingerly on a nearby shelf thank you
for your company then he turned back to
the doctor and thank you for my freedom
and your friendship it has been an honor
before the doctor could protest
Ferdinand was running his Thunder steps
pounding the Earth as he led the monster
in a chase it took the bait following
this new large Target back outside he
sealed off the tunnel behind them
ensuring the Beast would not return the
way it came he wanted to believe
ferdinand's bravado to think that the
Behemoth of a man had survived outside
but that night he saw the great Beast
ooze past a window and he could make out
that familiar wide toothy grin petring
from its side just like that the
greatest assistant he had ever had was
lost thank you for your service my
friend he whispered to himself I
solemnly swear to you your death shall
not be in vain SCP 049 is a fascinating
bundle of contradictions arguably he's
the Hannibal Lector of the anomalous
World he's educated refined and cultured
a scientific man with scientific goals
capable of communicating eloquently in
both English and medieval French as
anomalies go he's one of the more more
Cooperative ones contained by the SCP
Foundation willing to understand reason
and even showing a small degree of
respect for his fellow researchers and
yet despite all this intelligence and
refinement underneath his dark organic
cloak a heart of deep red violence
steadily beats he's capable of ending
life with a mere touch causing all
biological functions in the body to
Simply cease through means that are
still unknown to s sence thanks to a
series of inconclusive autopsies on SCP
049 unaltered victims not only is
killing easy in a physical sense for SCP
049 with a few notable exceptions it's
also been just as easy on his conscience
such is the danger of the Man or Monster
who believes unshakably that his goals
are righteous any moral crime is
permissible if done in service of seeing
them through and for those who die at
SCP 049 hand an even greater indignity
awaits his inhuman experiments the
gateway to a second life as an
abominable crime against nature a glob
of malignant spit in the eye of God but
let's not get too ahead of ourselves
here students we've mentioned SCP 049
countless times in passing before some
of his Strange Tales his interactions
with other anomalies like SCP 682 and
even with some of your questions and
theories about this bone masked
scientific madman and yet he still
remains a mystery perhaps to truly
understand this fascinating walking
question we need to return to the
beginning and give the classified files
behind the plague doctor a closer look
like many of the infamous anomalies
discovered by the SCP Foundation the
files indicate that the discovery itself
was first triggered by a series of
mysterious disappearances in the Sleepy
town of montabon out in in southern
France people across races classes ages
and genders were simply falling off the
map suggesting a highly indiscriminate
as salent little did the foundation know
in the beady avien eyes of their killer
they all had an extremely important
commonality each and every one of them
was infected with the pestilence the
invisible Scourge The Great dying their
killer was the only one with the proper
diagnostic mind to even notice the
infection he was the only one who could
save the world from this Insidious
unseen threat and then the SCP
Foundation discovered his laboratory the
plague doctor had been doing his
delicate work in an abandoned house on
the edge of town the kind of place that
gets whispered about in local rumors a
bad place a cursed Place little did they
know it was only the latest in a long
line of covert research centers for this
singularly inspired medicine man while
some of the details were a little foggy
in his memory he'd been carrying out his
work for a little over 400 years now
moving from place to place causing
strings of disappearances wherever he
showed up in his own words he's an
extremely well-traveled man and still
the cure for the Blasted pestilence
continued to evade him he sat in that
decrepit montabon house surrounded by
groaning writhing Abominations of his
own creation taking meticulous notes
nothing would break his concentration
not even the strangers in the Black
Tactical Gear with large guns kicking in
his front doors his many cured patients
didn't take kindly to the intrusion on
their treatment and decided to swarm The
Interlopers What followed was a violent
struggle between The Intruders and the
cured resulting in several of The
Intruders injured and all of the cured
dead once more during all this chaos the
plague doctor never once stopped taking
notes when he was was finished with his
sentence he willingly submitted to
capture by this mysterious SCP
Foundation after all when he told them
about the true nature of his mission
they would of course see reason and
allow him to continue his research sure
he may have committed a few crimes
against nature on the way but he was
working in service of loftier ideals you
can only imagine his profound relief
when he was first interviewed by SCP
Foundation researcher Dr Raymond Ham in
sight 84
he was in the presence of fellow
Scholars people of science he worried at
first that he'd been captured by some
group of Common Street Scoundrels when
in fact the hands of Providence had
delivered him into the perfect place to
continue his research the warm light of
Fate was now smiling on him after so
long languishing in the dark all he
needed to do was allow the scientists
around him to conduct tests on his own
body while he conducted tests on others
at first the SCP Foundation believed he
was an anomalous human being wearing a
costume but they soon discovered that he
was something very different what they
thought was a mask was actually an
outgrowth of his skull a kind of
insect-like
exoskeleton the robes were also a
component of his body a kind of thick
hide that developed over the years the
thickness of the Hide itself also made
him impervious to a great deal of
physical damage despite his politeness
research notes on the plague doctor
indicated that Foundation Personnel
found interacting with him uncanny there
was an oddly Eerie quality to him
something indistinguishable that just
felt off the foundation also found that
the plague doctor whom they initially
addressed as Doctor rather than SCP 049
out of a sense of mutual respect also
came with a number of strange personal
effects these included a long pointing
stick similar to the ones used by
medieval plague doctors to touch things
without fear of contamin ination this
stick was soon confiscated it didn't
possess any anomalous qualities but the
plague doctor had a tendency to gesture
grandly with it as he spoke and the
foundation feared he absent-mindedly
take someone's eye out with it if he
wasn't careful the other two personal
effects that the plague doctor prize
greatly was his old-fashioned medical
bag and the notebook that he obsessively
recorded his observations with the
medical bag which seemed to exhibit
anomalous properties contained a mix of
archaic medical tools as as well as some
that the foundation has been unable to
identify it's through the tools in this
bag that the plague doctor is able to
create instances of SCP
049-2 as we alluded to earlier the
plague doctor can kill with a touch but
that's only part of what he does to his
victims after causing all their
biological functions to cease he takes
the tools out of his medical bag and
begins performing crude surgery on their
corpse including using a syringe to
inject an unknown anomalous liquid into
their flesh while the specifics on the
plague doctor's modifications can vary
from victim to victim the result is
often the same they're converted into
strange shambling Abominations that
aren't capable of any kind of higher
thought for the most part their
movements are extremely basic and
limited however if they're provoked they
can become frighteningly violent more
than capable of killing an armed
Foundation guard if they don't remain
alert during the engagement the SCP
Foundation was given a unique
opportunity to understand more about SCP
049 Twisted experiments as part of his
conditions for containment they agreed
to provide the Diabolical doctor with a
number of fresh test subjects the doctor
was eager to continue his work and
through watching him work the SCP
Foundation could learn a great deal more
about him though we wouldn't even
pretend that the plague doctor's work
has ever been enjoyable to watch they
presented him with some live subjects
and a much greater number of M million
corpses he would spend several days
working intensely on each one then
documenting his findings in his precious
notebook as a mark of respect for the
foundation scientists around him the
plague doctor was more than eager to
share his research with them and compare
notes he was always a talkative one
perhaps just as excited to discuss his
experiments and theories with
like-minded Scholars after so many years
of working alone here are four notable
instances first the plague doctor was
presented with a live d-class specimen
he thanked the foundation greatly for
this gift then set about his work he
asked the unaware d-class several
questions about his medical history
while retrieving tools from his bag
before quickly touching and killing the
man he performed extensive modifications
on the d-class corpse and when he was
resurrected as an SCP 049-2 instance he
was barely recognizable as his original
form he was a bizarre flailing creature
constantly groaning and gasping from the
oblong shaped hole that the plague
doctor had carved into his chest while
performing this horrifying work the
plague doctor eagerly remarked to the
observing researchers that The Cure
appears to be extremely effective next
he was provided the corpse of a recently
deceased goat which he also expressed
gratitude for after performing surgery
on the creature it was successfully
resurrected into a bizarre SCP
049-2 instance however the plague doctor
readily admitted that this definitely
wasn't his best work commenting the
disease was still in its ncient stage my
Veterinary practice is rudimentary but
the Patient responded well to the
procedure next he was provided the
corpse of a recently deceased orangutan
the plague doctor was delighted by this
commenting that given primate
similarities to human physiology this
would be the next best thing from a true
human test subject however this research
became surprisingly fraught he killed
and reanimated the Beast four different
times seemingly un satisfied with the
result each time and when he failed to
reanimate the creature a fifth time he
seemed disconcerted in a debriefing
discussion the plague doctor said I have
learned so much from this though I fear
my early optimism was misplaced I hadn't
yet come across such a a a stumbling
block on my road to the Cure more
subjects like this would do a great deal
in advancing my research next it was
provided with the corpse of a recently
deceased cow this irrit SCP 049 who
wanted test subjects who were
physiologically closer to humans still
despite his frustration he continued to
work he took only brief breaks to enjoy
a meal of hard cheese salted pork and
thin crackers test showed that SCP 049
didn't require sustenance to survive but
he enjoyed the act of eating and found
that it helped him with his work he
embalmed the cow rearranging its organs
and even inverted its head however this
didn't impede his work he injected it
with a variety of liquids which he
described as the essence of the humors
when asked to elaborate further on this
he said the pestilence may bring about a
systemic imbalance in such a case before
true healing can begin one must find the
humor inbalance or the body will reject
the Cure this is of course Elementary
knowledge for the Practical physician I
would have thought you have learned this
during your education after being
provided a working cattle prod to induce
a little electricity into the equation
the plague doctor 6 successfully
reanimated the mutant cow from here
things started to go downhill Dr Ham
decided to conduct another interview
with SCP 049 hoping to get into the
finer details of his scientific process
however they hit some major road blocks
SCP 049 seemed to be unable to actually
articulate the true nature of the
pestilence or his process in seeking The
Cure even his notebook wasn't written in
any known language and proved impossible
to decipher
as the interview went on the plague
doctor seemed to become increasingly
distressed insisting on the importance
of his work to helping the human race
prosper and survive this terrible plague
all he needed in exchange was more test
subjects the practice civility that had
been built up between the plague doctor
and the SCP Foundation crumbled in 2017
after a tragic incident in the plague
doctor's cell with Dr Ham when he
entered to perform a very standard
interview with the plague doctor the
doctor appeared to become anxious and
asked Dr Ham if he was feeling well
today Dr Ham thought nothing of it and
tried to continue the interview but by
that point it was already too late the
plague doctor had come to believe that
Dr Ham was infected with the pestilence
and of course there was only one cure
the plague doctor gave Dr Ham his Touch
of death the man died instantly and the
plague doctor immediately went about
turning his corpse into another SCP
049-2 instance because ham was killed so
quickly he didn't have to time to
activate his emergency security signal
meaning what was left of him wasn't
discovered until 3 hours later guards
and researchers were horrified to see
one of their own turned into a Mindless
deformed Monster by an anomaly they all
thought they could trust following this
tragic incident Dr thuren Sherman
chastised the plague doctor for this
appalling breach of trust and the
cold-blooded murder of Dr Raymond Ham
the plague doctor in a state of
increasing distress insisted that ham
was infected and he did all that he
could to cure him and while the plague
doctor insisted a certain level of
scientific distance from his subject it
seemed that deep down he regretted the
loss of a friend and fellow researcher
in his Endless Quest against the
pestilence after this incident the
plague doctor truly became SCP 049 he
lost all of his Privileges and now
remains under lock and key in site 19
whenever he's transported he's kept in
shackles and supervised by a number of
armed guards after discovering that the
scent of lavender has a pacifying effect
on him it's regularly used as a
tranquilizer against him during
engagements this is how a cordial Ally
can become just another prisoner in the
eyes of the SCP Foundation in a summary
interview after the drct ham incident Dr
Elijah itkin asked if 049 had any
regrets about the incident noting that
he seemed oddly mournful 049 paused
before replying M perhaps I had not
thought that he it is lamentable that a
fellow doctor became infected but the
work continues regrettable as as it was
Dr Ham's death provided important
Insight living human subjects are the
only way to proceed forward I decided my
cure is of little use on dead flesh and
I have gleaned all I can from your
generous supply of corpses my desires
turn towards tending to those still
living who suffer from the disease Dr
itkin replied that 049 would be
disappointed on that front he just
laughed in response and
replied oh doctor I wouldn't be so sure
life at the SCP Foundation isn't exactly
made up of sunshine and rainbows it's
less of a good vibes kind of place and
more of a this is the solemn work we do
as we stand between Humanity in the vast
unfilling unknowable realm of mystery
and darkness sure sometimes there's a
magic vending machine or teddy bear
doctor but most of the time the
foundation's findings are a lot more
bite than they are bar thankfully
there's the C portion of that Infamous
acronym contain they keep their bizarre
astounding findings locked up tight
where they can't catch an unsuspecting
innocent off guard and oh hey there
little buddy it's okay you didn't mean
to scare me relax everyone it's just sc
scp-999 one of the only contained
Curiosities allowed to roam freely
around around the halls of the
foundation just look at this guy has a
sentient mass of translucent orange
slime ever been so cute you want some
chocolate buddy okay here you go it's
incredible really that the place that
houses a neck snapping sculpture in a
haunted chess playing machine could also
be the home of such a delightful little
blob you know now that I think of it
it's amazing that being in the vicinity
of unspeakable Horrors day after day has
never put a damper on 99's positive
attitude he's got the persistent
cheerful disposition of a Labrador puppy
but how well would SCP 99's inherent
wholesomeness hold up against one of the
most wicked anomalies contained by the
SCP Foundation what would happen if the
lightest of the light a slimy piece of
pure goodness came up against a deep
dark evil not the omnicidal Rage of SCP
682 we all know how that went but
something quieter well let's find out
SCP 999 was having the best day of its
life to be fair every single single day
was the best day of the tickle Monster's
life surpassed only by the day that
followed and the one after that and how
could it not be a good life at the SCP
Foundation when there were so many
friends to play with treats to eat and
so much to explore SCP 999 was enjoying
a hearty bowl of M&M's picking out and
eating the orange ones its favorites
first when a familiar figure walked into
its pen Dr Jack brigh who frequently
came by to see the Tickle Monster when
he was having a disappointing day
usually because the higher-ups had
reprimanded him for breaking the rules
yet again SCP 999 CED delightfully at
the sight of its visitor slithering over
to Dr brigh and enveloping him in an
enthusiastic hug Dr brgh immediately
began to laugh as the creatures euphoric
influence took effect hey glad there are
no hard feelings about the time I ate a
piece of
you he giggled as 999 patted his face
affectionately with one of its pseudo
pods a thanks that really takes the
sting out of getting the no chainsaws
Hammer brought down on me again he
patted the slime with his own hand in
return and satisfied that it had
sufficiently cheered him 999 ooze back
over to its breakfast to finish
consuming the sugary goodness oh I
almost forgot Dr Bri pulled something
out of his lab coat pocket it was a
small can of cola appealingly shiny in
the light want some SCP 999 gurgled
curiously and approached Dr brgh to
inspect the can he popped it open with
an inviting fizz and offered some
fortunately Dr rhs was walking by at
that exact moment don't you dare she
snatched the can out of her colleagues
hand you remember what happened last
time 999 can't tolerate caffeine or
carbonation Dr brigh pouted like a
petulant child but I wanted to see it
bounce do I need to add another rule to
the list Dr rhs crossed her arms or are
you going to behave yourself GH fine
whatever I'll find something else to do
Dr brigh rolled his eyes and left SCP
99's pen with a final friendly wave at
the creature sensing Dr rh's stress the
Tickle Monster nuzzled her leg with an
inquisitive gurgle she smiled
indulgently and gave the Slime a hug
before she followed Dr brigh down the
hall keeping an eye out for any more
potentially disruptive Antics satisfied
at having cheered everyone up SCP 999
went back to its bowl of candy and
devoured the remaining Treats but then
there was nothing left to eat and no one
in the room to visit or play with What
was a lovable slime to do why explore of
course SCP 999 had the freedom to roam
all over the foundation site until
bedtime that is and it loved oozing down
the Halls looking for friends to greet
and strangers to meet after all a
stranger is just a friend that the
Tickle Monster hasn't tickled yet as the
Slime slid along the floor it took the
time to say hello to everyone at pass by
bumping them nudging them or in the case
of Josie the half cat very gently
petting her head with one of its pseudo
pods the cat purred and 999 responded by
vibrating its gelatinous body producing
a soft purr of its own then Josie was
distracted by a dust particle drifting
through a beam of light and darted off
to chase it so the Tickle Monster
continued on its way looking for
something new and fun to do it spotted
the perfect new activity two guards were
walking into one of the sealed
containment rooms a room that the Jolly
little slime had never been inside of
before now was the perfect chance to
investigate and maybe play tickle
wrestling with the guards along the way
it had to act fast though the door was
beginning to close rearranging its body
999 squished itself into a long thin
line sliding quickly through the crack
in the door just before it shot this new
room was very messy much messier than
999 was allowed to keep its own room and
he spilled chocolate milk or smeared
cupcake frosting was either cleaned up
by staff or slurped up by the slime
itself but in in this room there was
thick black liquid dripping down all of
the walls some of it arranging itself
into patterns and words though 999
couldn't read what they said the guards
hadn't noticed the tickle Monster's
presence yet and it kept still excited
to give them a wonderful surprise when
they turned around and saw that it had
followed them inside but they didn't
turn around they were completely focused
on something in front of them what was
it it was a thick glass case that looked
as if it was about to fall apart at any
moment inside there was a mask a
porcelain mask of a frowning face with
that same strange dark fluid dripping
from its eye and mouth holes you know
the procedure right one guard said he
was holding a brand new glass case shiny
and completely empty of course I do the
other scoffed it's my first time with
this anomaly not my first day on the job
just open it up and take the mask out
and put it in here he tapped on the case
he was holding as quickly as possible
yeah I just said I know the less
experienced guard grumbled don't
patronize me he reached towards the
decaying case and prepared to unlock it
wait Did you hear that hear what I
thought i' heard never mind SCP 999
vibrated with excitement would they give
it some well-deserved attention maybe
play a game but no the guard wasn't
talking about the eager orange pal
behind him he was feeling the influence
of something much more Sinister do you
want me to do it the more experience
guard offered no just you you really
don't hear that that whispering his
colleague just shook his head fine it's
just been a long week I guess he sighed
and popped the case open reaching for
the mask inside as soon as his fingers
made contact with the porcelain surface
the black goo dripping onto his skin
where he should have been wearing
protective gloves his expression shifted
his eyes went blank like someone
sleepwalking lost in a dream even as
their body moved in the waking World
Frank what are you waiting for the other
guard nudged him but Frank said nothing
he delicately lifted the mask out of the
glass box and before anyone could stop
him placed the frowning white face over
his own only it wasn't frowning anymore
as soon as its features slipped over
Frank's covering him erasing him its
mouth curved into a malicious smile
Frank what the hell are you doing the
guard cried out as the man he had once
known grabbed hold of his shoulders not
Frank anymore a voice came out from from
behind the ceramic lips but it was
different cruel cold ancient Frank's
gone out I'm afraid and he won't be back
anytime soon the guard tried to break
away from the masked man's grasp tried
to reach for the Emergency alarm to
signal that the containment change had
gone horribly wrong but the mask shoved
him into the wall hard the guard hit his
head and slumped to the ground
unconscious and likely concussed well as
CP 999 has had just about enough of all
of this it hated seeing anyone hurt
especially humans and clearly its help
was sorely needed to make things better
it couldn't tell exactly what had upset
the man in The Mask so much that he was
acting this way but he knew one thing
that always cheered humans up it was
time for a bit of good old-fashioned
tickle wrestling as scp-999 hurled
itself across the room enveloping
Frank's Body from his feet to his neck
and it began tickling him as it did the
force of 99's tackle sent Frank's Body
careening towards the ground and when it
landed with a heavy thud The Mask flew
off his face and skittered across the
floor now that I could see Frank's face
999 looked for signs of laughter of Joy
but Frank was dead asleep eyes closed
Jaws slack his heart was still beating
but he wouldn't wake up confused
concerned and upset at what it had
witnessed in this new room the Slime
slithered along the floor toward the
mask that had caused so much trouble it
seemed to be staring at 999 with its
dark vacant eyes it didn't look like a
toy in fact it looked like something
that the Slime should avoid touching but
it couldn't help but notice that the
face had changed back to a frown could
999 really leave the mask there on the
floor frowning like that the Tickle
Monster couldn't help it with a soft
greeting by way of a high-pitched cooing
noise it reached out to the mask and
picked it up though the Slime creature
didn't have a traditional face for the
mask to sit on top of its influence
quickly grabbed hold of 99's gelatinous
frame it stopped moving stopped gurgling
stopped looking at the world through
rose-colored glasses right now SCP 999
was being piloted by the possessive mask
and it was looking for a way out once it
escaped containment it could find a new
host a proper host with arms legs and a
mouth but for now this undignified
vehicle would have to do it took the
mask some time to to learn how to Pilot
this strange softt body with its
malleable form and odd methods of moving
itself around the room but it slowly
adjusted and wearing the silhouette of
the Tickle Monster like a disguise oozed
out of its containment room and into the
Hall staff walking by barely even
noticed 99's presence they were too
preoccupied with their work they were
used to seeing it and giving it a polite
nod but most of them didn't have the
time to stop and say a proper hello at
this time of day perhaps this would be
easy after all The Mask had lost its
chosen host but found something even
better the perfect cover and the chance
to hide in plain sight it could take in
the lay of the land scope out potential
exit routes and ideally slide out of
foundation custody completely unnoticed
The Mask began to smile at the thought
as the mask steered SC SCP 99's body
around the sight A peculiar feeling
began to GW at the back of its mind like
an itch it couldn't quite scratch
something irritating that wouldn't leave
it alone what was that feeling inside of
its own Consciousness The Mask heard a
sound a sweet high pitched gurgle no
that was impossible and yet somehow the
consciousness of the Tickle Monster had
survived in the face of the mask's power
it was there still needling at the
mask's darkness with that insipid
insistent kindness shut up the mask
hissed frowning this body belongs to me
now why won't you just Die Another
gurgle this one even louder more
difficult to shut out did this infernal
thing ever shut up the mask stopped
moving for a moment concentrating the
force of its will it would drive SCP
99's mind away and reestablish dominance
just as the mask was grappling with the
influence of SCP 999 however a familiar
figure turned down the hall it was Dr
rhs from earlier SC SCP 99's exuberance
bubbled up to the surface and The Mask
couldn't stop its mouth from flipping
back to a smile what no that was
ridiculous and yet the longer the mask
was in contact with the vibrant orange
slime so delighted by every familiar and
unfamiliar face it encountered it could
feel that horrible positive influence
growing stronger and stronger it was a
nauseating warm fuzzy feeling that just
made him want to the mask let out a
giggle then another and before long it
was in the midst of an absolute giggling
fit the mask had laughed before it had
laughed plenty of times but it was
usually a mocking laugh a cackle of
Triumph This was a giggle though of pure
joy the sort of sound a small child
makes as they chase a butterfly through
a field this was the sound of innocence
of happiness it was love Now you listen
to me you vile little worm The Mask
growled it wasn't certain if 999 could
even understand it but it had to show
this rebellious creature who was really
in charge releasee your grip on me I
have won you have lost your form is mine
and you nothing more than a puppet for
me to pull on your strings and use you
to my own ends show some respect and
defer to me the voice of the Slime
creature whimpered in the mask's mind a
sound like a chastised puppy slinking
away with its tail between its legs
that's more like it the mask huffed Dr
rhs looked up from her clipboard and
spotted as CP 999 she waved about to
greet the creature when she noticed the
horrible mask perched on top she dropped
her clipboard in shock gasping at the
sight no she breathed heart sinking as
she saw one of the purest pieces of good
and all the foundation fall into the
forces of the Mask that's right the mask
would have puffed out its chest if this
body had a chest to Puff I've taken a
new host do you like my selection it
relished the tearful look in the woman's
eyes the horror that caused her hands to
shake and her cheeks to go pale show me
the way to the exit so I might take my
leave of this place and perhaps I will
spare your life the mask was just
gearing up for a good threat a really
nightmarish one filled with vivid
descriptions of Mutilation and violence
when that disgusting feeling began to
rise up again that warmth that buoyancy
it made the mask want to please don't be
sad here let me give you a hug before it
could stop itself the mask slithered the
tickle Monster's body over to Dr rhs
wrapping around her tightly not to hurt
her no to embrace her to comfort her her
horror turned to laughter as the mood
lifting effect of 99's presence began to
work its magic through her laughter she
was also confused why why she couldn't
finish the question but it was enough to
break the mask out of the spell it
reared back horrified at its action
what have I done what have I done it
slithered quickly down the hall around
the corner away from that woman who had
evoked such fond feelings towards her no
towards all of humanity The Mask steered
its body into a bathroom coming face to
face with a mirror it stared at Its
Reflection its familiar face and dark
eyes dripping their usual fluid perched
to Top This alien thing poisoning its
mind what did you do to me what sort of
magic is this of course 999 did not
answer but the mask could feel its
presence could feel its Delight in the
impact it was having you're ruining me
the mask groaned I strike Terror into
Hearts I drive men to Madness I Rend
their sanity into
I it trailed off overwhelmed Again by
The Urge to smile to laugh to frolic
though it didn't have a working nose The
Mask could swear it smelled an array of
heavenly scents of fresh roses breaking
bed in a stone oven vanilla and lightly
burnt brown sugar it reached for itself
with its pseudo pods about to tear
itself off of the slimy body all
together but it paused ah very clever I
see what your game is it lowered the
pseudopods brimming with determination
you won't trick me into sparing your
life once I found my freedom and host
worthy of me I will destroy you once and
for all but even as as the mask made
this declaration the black liquid
seeping from its eyes and mouth began to
change to take on a lighter appearance
was it a trick of the light no it was it
was orange like the gelatinous Flesh of
The Horde creature it had made the
mistake of attaching to no matter how
hard the mask fought the influence of
SCP 999 was spreading its mind raced
trying to come up with a new plan a way
to hold on to its identity but the sound
of an alarm blaring outside the bathroom
spurred it to get a move on once more
clearly Dr rhods had alerted someone
that the mask had reached containment
time was running out it needed to find
the exit fast it was now or never The
Mask oozed back into the Hall speeding
up as it went trying desperately to find
a way out before whatever transformation
had begun could complete itself but even
as it struggled it could feel itself
changing warping it burst into Giggles
again and whistled a Happy tune it
stopped running for a moment to wave at
an armed guard and blow them a kiss why
had it wanted to leave this facility in
the first place everyone here was so
kind was so lovely was its best friend
no no must resist must not give into the
optimism to the happiness to the
goodness if the mask had teeth it would
have been clenching them trying to stem
the tide of Joyful noises that threaten
to burst out it felt like something was
tickling it and the tickling just
wouldn't stop stop it the mask dissolved
into Giggles again I mean it he could
feel something coming something big a
loud cracking sound rang out and just as
the guards were closing in on the
possessed Tickle Monster they watched in
awe as cracks spread across the surface
of the possessive mask and all at once
it shattered into pieces the pieces fell
to the floor where they pulled
themselves back together with strands of
black goo meanwhile SCP 999 sat there
bouncing with Glee completely unharmed
the Tickle Monster received an extra
special ice cream sunday for its bravery
and amazing work and the mask was
returned to its containment chamber in a
brand new glass case as the mask
suffered an identity crisis for the
first time in its existence SCP 999
curled up in its pen full of sugar and
gratitude and got some well-deserved
rest there are some people who would get
tired of being placed in charge of SCP
914 or the Clockworks the monotony of it
all might make most of us go mad the
same routine day after day placing an
infinite number of objects into the
intake Booth of the machine selecting
one of the modes be it rough coarse one
toone fine or very fine and seeing just
what sort of transformation takes place
but there was one employee of the SCP
Foundation who liked that routine just
fine Dr gears was happy with his
position the Simplicity of the routine
the predictability of it all he liked
when the days stacked neatly together in
a row of uneventful stretches of time it
was why he ate the exact same meal for
lunch every day a plain turkey sandwich
on White Bread a cup of water and a
single banana of course there was some
variety in the events that came about
when testing the Clockworks there was
that incident with Dr Curtis and the
pound of bacon placed inside the machine
alongside a photograph of SCP 682 it had
resulted in a miniature replica of CP
682 made entirely out of bacon capable
of movement and extremely hostile though
its size prevented it from doing any
damage it did still attempt to kill any
staff it could find it had smelled
mouthwatering but Dr gears had suspended
Dr Curtis from testing with SCP 914 for
the trouble and a day of having bacon
grease cleaned off of every surface in
the vicinity there was also the incident
that occurred when Dr Herz in an attempt
to score some free music prod ction
placed a CD of his own original guitar
songs into the machine on the setting
very fine rather than improving the
production quality of the tracks on the
CD the machine produced a completely
silent CD as well as a collection of
books on songwriting singing and playing
the guitar for beginners Dr gears had to
physically drag Dr herdz from the room
when upset by the blow to his ego he
attempted to attack the machine and of
course there had been the highly
destructive super bouncy ball incident
which resulted in 45 casualties and
staggering damage to the facility as
well as the aformentioned ball which was
currently thought to be somewhere in
space most likely orbiting Mars but for
the most part it was always the same
thing an object went in a setting was
selected and the object came out in a
new modified State wash rinse repeat
just like it said on the back of the
bottle of the brand of unscented shampoo
Dr gears had been using for the P 30
years that was how he liked it and as he
sat at his desk going over the test logs
and preparing to supervise another round
of tests he turned on some of his
favorite Tunes well I say Tunes but it
was really a white noise machine he
didn't care for music it was a bit too
much excitement he was just getting into
the flow of his work when there was a
knock at his office door um excuse me
sir a research assistant was standing at
the door pale and anxious a clipboard in
his hands they're um requesting your
help with an emergency down the hall
what is it Dr gears asked they didn't
really say just something about Dr brigh
and um chainsaws the assistant stammered
Dr gears sighed and stood up from his
desk I'll be right there there wouldn't
be anyone keeping an eye on SCP 914 but
at this point the experimentation
process basically ran itself everything
would be fine if Dr gear stepped away
for a little while wouldn't it meanwhile
across the site a very enterprising mask
became keenly aware of an opportunity
presenting itself it had been lying in
weight meticulously planning and
plotting for days and now there was an
opening it could take advantage of you
see months ago the mask had managed to
finagle itself a host a researcher who
had just been working with a CP 914 when
the masks Consciousness took over the
mans and it delved into all of his
thoughts as they they were snuffed out
one by one it learned all about The
Marvelous miraculous Clockworks the
machine capable of transforming anything
into a better version of itself The Mask
had fantasized obsessed about getting to
SCP 914 of using it to mold itself to
change into something greater and more
powerful then perhaps it could escape
this place and return to its former
freedom and Glory of course it would
have to select the right setting one
wrong choice and the whole plan could
amount to nothing on rough The Mask
would likely be destroyed reduced to a
pile of ceramic dust or perhaps even a
ball of unmolded clay alongside some of
the black slime always oozing from its
eyes and mouth on course it would likely
be transformed into a slab of plain
porcelain uncarved and unpainted on one
to one The Mask would likely be swapped
out with another anomalous object some
other enterprising mask or perhaps a
haunted Victorian doll or some other
malicious inanimate thing and what use
would that be no that wouldn't do at all
fine could be promising and would likely
prevent the mask from degrading any
future hosts it decided to take but why
stop there why should it limit itself to
Simply fine when very fine was right
there and looking oh so promising it
decided if it could get to SCP 914 it
would find a way to transform itself
using the very fine setting and then its
enemies this pathetic Foundation the
entire world would fall to their knees
it had been waiting patiently like a
snake coiled and ready to snap up its
prey spreading its psychic tendrils as
far as they could go and anticipating
the moment that someone left SCP 914
unattended now the moment had arrived of
course The Mask would need help it
didn't have a way to reach the
Clockworks on its own so it had been
wrapping its influence around the Guard
Station just outside its door dripping
thoughts into his head Whispering
Darkness into his ear at every chance it
got shipping away at his will bit by bit
until the man was little more than a
puppet with the possessive mask tugging
at his strings The Mask gave a mental
Yank on one of those strings calling the
man in its thrall into the room first he
knocked out his fellow guard with the
butt of his gun at this point his mind
was so pliable that he would do anything
to please The Mask next the man entered
the containment chamber a glassy vacant
look in his eyes he unlocked the glass
case and reached inside lifting the mask
out and bringing it one step closer to
absolute freedom he tucked the mask
inside of his uniform hiding it away
from any prying eyes and began to walk
Stead ly towards SCP 914s room all the
while the mask whispered silent
encouragements into the man's weakened
mind promising him power and success
Beyond his wildest dreams if only he
would help it achieve this goal of
course the mask was planning to kill the
man as soon as his task was done but he
didn't need to know that yet every step
brought the mask closer to Victory and
it was practically vibrating with the
delicious anticipation of it all soon so
soon they reached the containment room
the Clockworks just beyond the door the
guard carried the mask into the room
placed the mask inside of the intake
Booth closed it and approached the
control panel in accordance with the
mask psychic instructions he selected
very fine and turned the machine on the
cogs and gears inside were to life the
engine sputtered metal clanked and pipes
exhaled hissing bursts of energy the
output chamber opened and through the
curtain of steam SCP 035 stepped in its
new and improved form that's right
stepped first one long seny leg leathery
shiny and black as the night extended
into view another leg followed and along
with it came a torso a pair of arms a
slender neck and the familiar face of
the Mask stark white against the
darkness of its new body
the feet ended in little points as if
the figure was wearing boots but there
was no visible clothing it was all one
being angular and strange with long long
fingers tipped with curved claws The
Mask let out a wicked cackle throwing
back its head in
[Laughter]
Triumph excellent it's even better than
I imagined The Mask turned to the guard
that had helped it Escape thank you for
your service now I have one last favor
to ask you it was time for The Mask to
test its powers to see how the
Clockworks had strengthened what was
already there what more it was capable
of in this enhanced State I want you to
go into the cafeteria walk into the
kitchen and climb into the oven would
you make sure you turn it on nice and
hot first it waited for a few seconds
before the man nodded solemnly turned
and left the room heading off in the
direction of the cafeteria it listened
as the moments passed and the sound of
horrified shocked screams rang out and
it knew that the man had followed its
instructions exactly at the mask's
orders he had cooked himself for lunch
The Mask clapped its hands together
cackling
again wonderful oh wonderful now that's
taken care of of what shall I try next
if the mask had eyebrows they would have
been arched in a truly devilish
expression first it wanted to test its
abilities on a truly formidable opponent
someone worthy of the Mask time and
attention casually as you please it
strowed over to one particular
containment chamber to see about an
unkillable reptile as it walked several
guards took notice pointing their
weapons at the mask and ordering it to
stand down each time it ch cled and with
a wave of its hand the barrels of their
guns warped and twisted into little
metal bows completely useless it snapped
its clawed fingers and the guards fell
to the ground in an unconscious Heap
can't have you sounding the alarm yet
the fun is only just beginning The Mask
remarked though it knew the guards
couldn't hear it it kicked open the door
to SCP 682s Containment room with a
jaunty
greeting hello you scaly fool
I come to pay you a visit the reptile
did not respond incapacitated by its
hydrochloric acid bath that just
wouldn't do the mask concentrated and
the steel chamber broke apart acid
spilling everywhere hissing as it
splashed onto any available surface SCP
682 lifted its head twitching its tail
and took in the sight of the new and
improved mask what do you think the mask
posed for the creature laughing again it
seemed it couldn't stop laughing lately
its expression fixed into a permanent
gleeful smile it couldn't help it
freedom and power just felt so good
disgusting SCP 682 remarked unimpressed
with this display it lunged at the mask
preparing to attack but the mask held up
a hand to stop it not so fast as CP 682
suddenly froze in place eyes rolling
wildly as it tried desperately in in
vain to move let's see what should I do
with you the mask was itching to test
out its reality warping abilities it had
the feeling that there was very little
it couldn't do in this state and wanted
to see just how far its power could go
but what would be suitable punishment
what could be the
cruestv PE that would be far too easy
aha a light bulb went off in the mask's
Twisted mind perfect it waved its hand
releasing SCP 682 from its paralysis but
as the massive lizard snapped its jaws
and moveed to take a bite out of the
Mask it lost its Balance Falling to the
ground its legs had begun to shrink
rapidly knocking its center of gravity
as sko soon the rest of its body began
to follow getting smaller and smaller at
an unbelievable Pace until finally where
there had once stood a massive
impossible prehistoric Beast was
something resembling a baby alligator a
tiny little tail thrashing about short
stubby legs bulbous eyes and a mouth
full of sharp but adorable
non-threatening teeth when the shrunken
SCP 682 spoke its voice was high pitched
and squeaky
Let It roared yes you you are the mask
Turned and Left thoroughly pleased with
its work and shut the door behind it now
what other fellow anomalies could The
Mask exercise its absolute superiority
over it pondered other supposedly
dangerous and deadly entities that it
had heard about over its time in
Foundation custody it all seemed so
laughable now there was only one true
danger within these walls and it was the
mask oh what about that abom om itable
sculpture the ugly thing with a pension
for snapping necks but only when a
person wasn't looking at it the absolute
coward cowards didn't deserve to live
the mask decided and it made its way
over toward SCP 173s Containment cell
inside there were several d-class
staring at the Statue with wide
unblinking eyes each person terrified of
being the one to let their guard down
and lose their life in the process none
of them some would die today however at
least not at the hands of the statue as
the d-class in the cell watched never
once taking their eyes off of SCP 173
the statue's head began to twist and
rotate the sound of cracking snow and
creaking metal reverberating through the
room the mask used its telekinetic
abilities to Ren the statue's head from
its neck relishing the irony of breaking
the thing's neck just as it had done to
so many others it wasn't about justice
of course the mask had no taste for such
incepit and human things it just found
the whole image quite funny the entire
thing began to crumble apart like a sand
castle beneath an ocean wave
disintegrating until all that was left
was a pile of Pebbles and dust just like
that SCP 173 was no more as for the
d-class in the cell well the mask could
use some servants you all come with me
the mask ordered flexing its Iron Will
and quickly capturing the weak fear
addled minds of the d-class Personnel
before it they fell in line shuffling
out the door and following the mask with
the same blank Expressions as the guard
before whatever was left of their
personalities after so much time being
used and abused by the foundation it was
gone now replaced only with the will of
the mighty mask as the mask continued
its Victory Tour of the foundation now
with four mindless servants in tow it
passed the staff breakroom through the
window it spotted one Dr brght the tell
tail amulet around his neck microwaving
some leftover pizza The Mask had always
found Dr brght distasteful with a
self-aggrandizing pranks and general
dedication to chaos with no Grand Vision
behind it no meaningful agenda it was
pitiful it was deeply ugly and now the
mask had a chance to put an end to the
immortal do Antics once and for all it
opened the door greeting Dr brigh with
that Frozen grin oh doctor Dr Bright's
eyes widened and he didn't even hear the
microwave behind him ding signaling that
his pizza was ready he was too
distracted by the horrifying sight
before him but as he opened his mouth to
scream to call for help the mask reached
out and ripped the amulet from his neck
the host's body fell limply to the
ground and The Mask looked down at the
amulet glinting in the light that held
Dr Bright's Consciousness inside it
stared at the amulet with a flinty gaze
and under its empty stare the metal
began to rust to degrade and to melt
into an unrecognizable slurry The Mask
let it drip onto the floor then when all
that was Dr brght had melted away it
wiped its hand off with a napkin and
grounded the wet puddle on the ground
with its heel goodbye doctor The Mask
hissed now what's next but as the mask
turned to walk down the hall it came
face to face with a disapproving face
SCP 343 had manifested directly in front
of the mask and he clearly had learned
of the mask's behavior so far that day
you've been
busy yes very busy lots to do you see
the mask chuckled smugly you understand
why I can't allow this to continue right
right 343's expression remains Stern but
calm you believe you can stop me the
mask tilted its head to the side of
course I can SCP 343 side but you could
stop on your own if you would rather I
prefer to avoid an unnecessary conflict
The Mask giggled uncontrollably at
[Laughter]
this I am going to Ren the the flesh
from your bones it's simply sad I
thought you might say something like
that I'm going to have to take your body
I'm sorry SCP 343 prepared to teleport
the mask's new body to another location
separating them and reducing the mask to
its original more manageable state but
before he could there was sudden
darkness in the room every light
blinking out all at once the hall was
plunged into Shadow but this was no
ordinary Darkness this Darkness was Inky
thick cloaking like smoke clinging to
the inside of your throat then just as
suddenly as it appeared the darkness
dissipated but as CP 343 was gone he
hadn't teleported himself to somewhere
else he hadn't walked through the wall
to get away from the mask he was truly
gone the mask couldn't be certain
exactly what it had done to SCP 343 but
it knew that the enemy had been truly
eradicated in fact it was fairly certain
he had been erased from reality entirely
The Mask made one final lap around the
foundation containment site bitting Fair
well to every anomaly it passed some it
transformed like it had done to SCP 682
taking inspiration from its birdlike
face the mask turned the plague doctor
into a crow others had simply EX
executed such as the poor scp096 whose
screams and shs had always irritated the
mask of course the foundation began to
notice what was happening and they tried
to defeat the mask they shotted it with
their puny weapons they sounded their
useless alarms and they called for their
laughable backup but none of it mattered
not in the face of the Mask guns melted
in guard's hands alarms went silent at
nothing more than a glance and more and
more Mindless slaves Jo joined the masks
Army it didn't want too many that would
just be difficult to keep track of but
an even dozen seemed like the perfect
number with this miniature Army in tow
the mask finally made its way to its
final destination the exit it had been
waiting for this moment dreaming of it
since it was first imprisoned so long
ago as it stepped out into the Sun the
mask realized that though it didn't have
nostrils could smell the breeze the
scent of wild flowers and grass what a
beautiful place to mold into the mask
image of an Ideal World the world was
its oyster and The Mask longed to
swallow it whole the current whereabouts
of the possessive mask are unknown the
foundation is doing its best to locate
the mask and determine new effective
measures for bringing it down and
recontain it as soon as possible The
Escape of the Mask is being considered a
possible XK Class end of the world
scenario
if it cannot be stopped the best and
brightest Minds at the foundation are
working on it aside from Dr bride of
course may he rest in peace but right
now there is very little anyone can do
so if you see a strange dark figure in a
white mask walking down the street do
yourself a favor and run the other way
before it's too late now go check out
could SCP 682 be contained in the back
rooms and scp096
versus siren head for more terrifying
anomalous
hypotheticals